[Music]
big data is that technology that
revolutionized the idea industry this
millennium and you can't think of big
data without thinking about hadoop you
could say that without hadoop much of
the big data we produce in our lives
would stay unmanaged and unprocessed hi
guys welcome to this complete hadoop
tutorial for beginners by simply none
today we'll take you through everything
important that you need to know about
hadoop aj and richard are industry
experts each with over 10 years of
experience in big data and its various
components will guide you on this
learning journey we will first start off
by giving you an understanding of big
data followed by how you can install
hadoop on windows and ubuntu then we'll
go through the various components of the
hadoop ecosystem in detail like the hdfs
mapreduce and yarn then we'll teach you
how scoop hive pig and hbase work and
how you can practically implement each
of them
you will learn about big data analytics
and some of the most popular
applications of big data following this
we'll tell you how you can become a big
data engineer and finally we've
hand-picked 80 of the most important
questions that you might face in a big
data interview before we begin make sure
to subscribe to our channel and click on
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simplyrun with that out of the way
over to you rj now when we talk about
evolution of big data we have known that
data has evolved in the last five years
like never before now in fact before
going to big data or before
understanding these solutions and the
need and why there is a rush towards big
data technology and solution i would
like to ask a question take a couple of
minutes and think why are organizations
interested in big data why is there
certain rush in industry where everyone
would want to ramp up their current
infrastructure or would want to be
working on technologies which allow them
to use this big data think about it what
is happening and why are organizations
interested in this and if you think on
this
you will start thinking about what
organizations have been doing in past
what organizations have not done and why
are organizations interested in big data
now before we learn on big data we can
always look into internet and check for
use cases where organizations have
failed to use legacy systems or
relational databases to work on their
data requirements now over in recent or
over past five years or in recent decade
what has happened is organizations have
started understanding the value of data
and they have decided not to ignore any
data as being uneconomical now we can
talk about different platforms through
which data is generated take an example
of social media like twitter facebook
instagram whatsapp youtube you have
e-commerce and various portals say ebay
amazon flipkart alibaba.com
and then you have various tech giants
such as google oracle sap amazon
microsoft and so on so
lots of data is getting generated every
day in every business sector the point
here is that organizations have slowly
started realizing that they would be
interested in working on all the data
now the question which i asked was why
are organizations interested in big data
and some of you might have already
answered or thought about that
organizations are interested in doing
precise analysis or they want to work on
different formats of data such as
structured unstructured semi-structured
data organizations are interested in
gaining insights or finding the hidden
treasure in the so called big data and
this is the main reason where
organizations are interested in big data
now there are various use cases there
are various use cases we can compare
that organizations from past 50 or more
than 50 years have been handling huge
amount of data they have been working on
huge volume of data but the question
here is have they worked on all the data
or have they worked on some portion of
it what have they used to store this
data and if they have used something to
store this data what is happening what
is what is changing now when we talk
about the businesses we cannot avoid
talking about the dynamism involved now
any organization would want to have a
solution which allows them to store data
and store huge amount of data capture it
process it analyze it and also look into
the data to give more value to the data
organizations have then been looking for
solutions now let's look at some facts
that can convince you or that would
convince you that data is exploding and
needs your attention right 55 billion
messages and 4.5 billion photos are sent
each day on whatsapp 300 hours of video
are uploaded every minute on youtube did
you guys know that youtube is the second
largest search engine after google every
minute users send 31.25 million messages
and watch 2.77 million videos on
facebook walmart handles more than 1
million customer transactions every hour
google 40 000 search queries are
performed on google per second that is
3.46 million searches a day in fact you
could also say that a lot of times
people when they are loading up the
google page is basically just to check
their internet connection however that
is also generating data idc reports that
by 2025 real-time data will be more than
a quarter of all the data and by 2025
the volume of digital data will increase
to 163 zeta bytes that is we are not
even talking about gigabytes or
terabytes anymore we are talking about
petabytes exabytes and zeta bytes and
zeta bytes means 10 to the power 21
bytes so this is how data has evolved
now you can talk about different
companies which would want to use their
data to take business decisions they
would want to collect the data store it
and analyze it and that's how they would
be interested in drawing insights for
the business now this is just a simple
example about facebook and what it does
to work on the data now before we go to
facebook you could always check in
google by just typing in companies using
big data and if we say companies using
big data we should be able to find a
list of different companies which are
using big data for different use cases
there are various sources from where you
can find we could also search for
solution that is hadoop which we'll
discuss later but you could always say
companies using hadoop and that should
take you to the wiki page which will
basically help you know what are the
different companies which are using this
so called solution called hadoop okay
now coming back to what we were
discussing about so organizations are
interested in big data as we discussed
in gaining insights they would want to
use the data to find hidden information
which probably they ignored earlier now
take an example of rdbms what is biggest
drawback in using an rdbms now you might
think that rdbms is known for stability
and consistency and organizations would
be interested in storing their data in
oracle or db2 or mysql or microsoft sql
server and they have been doing that for
many years now so what has changed now
now when we talk about rdbms the first
question which i would ask is do we have
access to 100 of data being online in
rdbms the answer is no we would only
have 10 or 20 or 30 of data online and
rest of the data would be archived which
means that if an organization is
interested in working on all the data
they would have to move the data from
the archived storage to the processing
layer and that would involve bandwidth
consumption now this is one of the
biggest drawbacks of rdbms you do not
have access to 100 of data online in
many of the cases organizations started
realizing that the data which they were
ignoring as being uneconomical had
hidden value which they had never
exploited i had read a presentation
somewhere which said torture the data
and it will confess to anything now
that's the value of data which
organizations have realized in recent
past take an example of facebook now
this shows what facebook does with its
big data and we'll come to what is big
data but let's understand the use case
now facebook collects huge volumes of
user data whether that is sms whether
that is likes whether that is
advertisements whether that is features
which people are liking or photographs
or even user profiles now by collecting
this data and providing a portal which
people can use to connect facebook is
also accumulating huge volume of data
and that's way beyond petabytes they
would also be interested in analyzing
this data and one of the reasons would
be they would want to personalize the
experience take an example of
personalized news feed depending on a
user behavior depending on what a user
likes what a user would want to know
about they can recommend a personalized
news feed to every particular user
that's just one example of what facebook
does with its data take an example of
photo tag suggestions now when you log
into facebook account you could also get
suggestions on different friends whom
you would like to connect to or you
would want to tag so that they could be
known by others some more examples which
show how facebook uses its data are as
follows so the flashback collection of
photos and posts that received the most
comments and likes okay there was
something called as i voted that was
used for 2016 elections with reminders
and directions to tell users their time
and place of polling also something
called as safety checks in incidents
such as earthquake hurricane or mass
shooting facebook gives you safety
checks now these are some examples where
facebook is using big data and that
brings us to the question what is big
data this was just an example where we
discussed about one company which is
making use of that data which has been
accumulated and it's not only for
companies which are social media
oriented like facebook where data is
important take an example of ibm take an
example of jpmorgan chase take an
example of ge or any other organization
which is collecting huge amount of data
they would all want to gather insights
they would want to analyze the data they
would want to be more precise in
building their services or solutions
which can take care of their customers
so what is big data big data is
basically a term it is used to describe
the data that is too large and complex
to store in traditional databases and as
i gave an example it's not just about
storing the data it is also about what
you can do with the data it also means
that if there is a lot of dynamism
involved can you change the underlying
storage and handle any kind of data that
comes in now before we get into that
let's just understand what is big data
so big data is basically a term which
has been given to categorize the data if
it has different characteristics
organizations would want to have the big
data stored processed and then analyzed
to get whatever useful information they
can get from this data now there are
five v's of big data volume velocity
variety value velocity although these
are five v's but then there are other
v's which also categorize the data is
big data such as volatility validity
viscosity virality of data okay so these
are five v's of big data and if the data
has one or all of these characteristics
then it can be considered as big data
including the other ways which i just
mentioned so volume basically means
incredible amount of data huge volumes
of data data generated every second now
that could be used for batch processing
that could be used for real-time stream
processing okay you might have data
being generated from different kind of
devices like your cell phones your
social media websites online
transactions variable devices servers
and these days with iot we are also
talking about data of getting generated
via internet of things that is you could
have different devices which could be
communicating to each other you could be
getting data from radars or leaders or
even camera sensors so there is a huge
volume of data which is getting
generated and if we are talking about
data which has huge volume which is
getting generated constantly or has been
accumulated over a period of time we
would say that is big data velocity now
this is one more important aspect of big
data speed with which the data is
getting generated think about stock
markets think about social media
websites think about online surveys or
marketing campaigns or airline industry
so if the data is getting generated with
a lot of speed where it becomes
difficult to capture collect process
cure mine or analyze the data then we
are certainly talking about big data the
next aspect of big data is variety now
this is where we talk about structured
data semi-structured data or
unstructured data and here i would like
to ask a question what is the difference
when do you call the data is structured
semi-structured or unstructured now
let's look at an example before we
theoretically discuss about this i
always would like to use some examples
let's look at a log file and let's see
what is it so if i look at this log file
and if i would say what kind of data is
this which is the highlighted one the
answer would be
it is structured data it has specific
delimiters such as space it has data
which is separated by space and if i had
a hundred or thousand or million rows
which had similar kind of data i could
certainly store that in a table i could
have a predefined schema to store this
data so i would call the one which is
highlighted and structured but if i look
at this portion where i would look at a
combination of this kind of data where
some data has a pattern and some data
doesn't now this is an example of
semi-structured data so if i would have
a predefined structure to store this
data probably the pattern of data would
break the structure and if i look at all
the data then i would certainly call it
unstructured data because there is no
clear schema which can define this data
now this is what i mean by variety of
data that is structured data which
basically has a schema or has a format
which could be easily understood you
have semi-structured which could be like
an xml or json or even your excel sheets
where you could have some data which is
structured and the other is unstructured
and when we talk about unstructured we
are talking about absence of schema it
does not have a format it does not have
a schema and it is hard to analyze which
brings its own challenges the next
aspect is value now value refers to the
ability to turn your data useful for
business you would have a lot of data
which is being collected as we mentioned
in previous slides right there would be
a lot of data wrangling or data
pre-processing or cleaning up of data
happening and then finally you would
want to draw value from that data but
from all the data collected what
percentage of data gives us value and if
all my data can give me value then why
wouldn't i use it this is an aspect of
big data right veracity now this means
the quality of data billions of dollars
are lost every year by organizations
because the data which was collected was
not of good quality or probably they
collected a lot of data and then it was
erroneous take an example of autonomous
driving projects which are
happening in europe or u.s where there
are car fleets which are on the road
collecting data via radar sensors and
camera sensors and when this data has to
be processed to train algorithms it is
realized that sometimes the data which
was collected was missing in some values
might be was not appropriate or had a
lot of errors and all this process of
collecting the data becomes a repetitive
task because the quality of data was not
good this is just one example we can
take example from healthcare industry or
stock markets or financial institutions
and so on so extracting lots of data is
not useful if the data is messy or poor
in quality and that basically means that
velocity is a very important v of big
data now apart from veracity volume
variety velocity and value we have the
other v such as viscosity how dense the
data is
validity is the data still valid
volatility is my data volatile or
virality is the data viral now all of
these different v's categorize the data
as big data we would like to talk on a
big data case study and we have taken an
example of google which obviously is one
of the companies which is
churning and working on huge amount of
data now it's actually said that if you
compare one grain of sand with one byte
of data then google is processing or
google is handling whole worlds sand
every week that is the kind of data
which google is processing now in early
2000 and since then when the number of
internet users started growing google
also faced lot of problems in storing
increasing user data and
using the traditional servers to manage
that now that was a challenge which
google started facing could they use
traditional data server to store the
data well yes they could right storage
devices have been getting cheaper day by
day but then how much time does it take
to retrieve that data what is the seek
time what is the time taken to read and
process that data thousands of search
queries were raised per second no doubt
now we could say millions and billions
of queries are raised per second every
query read 100 mbs
of data and consumed tens of billions of
cpu cycles based on these queries so the
requirement was that they wanted to have
a large
distributed highly fault tolerant file
system large to store to capture process
huge amount of data distributed because
they could not rely just on one server
even if that had multiple disks stacked
up that was not an efficient choice what
would happen if this particular machine
failed what would happen if the whole
server was down so they needed a
distributed storage and a distributed
computing environment they needed
something which can be highly fault
tolerant right so this was the
requirement which google had and the
solution which came out as a result was
gfs google file system now let's look at
how gfs works so normally in any
particular linux system or linux server
you would have a file system you would
have set of processes you would have set
up files and directories which could
store the data gfs was different so to
facilitate gfs which could store huge
amount of data there was an architecture
an architecture which had one master and
multiple chunk servers or you could say
slave servers or slave machines
master machine was to contain metadata
was to contain data about data when we
say metadata we are talking about
information about data and then you have
the chung servers or the slave machines
which could be storing data in a
distributed fashion now any client or an
api or an application which would want
to read the data would first contact the
master server it would contact the
machine where the master process was
running and client would place a request
of reading the data or showing an
interest of reading the data internally
what it is doing is it is requesting for
metadata your api or an application
would want to know from where it can
read the data master server which has
metadata whether that is in ram or disk
we can discuss that later but then
master server would have the metadata
and it would know which are the chunk
servers or the slave machines where the
data was stored in a distributed fashion
master would respond back with the
metadata information to the client and
then client could use that information
to read or write to these slave machines
where actually the data was stored now
this is what the process or set of
processes work together to make gfs so
when you say a chunk server we would
basically have the files getting divided
into fixed size chunks now how would
they get divided so there would be some
kind of chunk size or a block size which
would determine that if the file is
bigger than the pre-decided chunk size
then it would be split into smaller
chunks and be distributed across the
chunk servers or the slave machines if
the file was smaller then it would still
use one chunk or a block to get stored
on the underlying slave machines so
these chunk servers or slave machines
are the ones which actually store the
data on local disks as your linux files
client which is interacting with master
for metadata and then interacting with
chunk servers for read write operations
would be the one which would be
externally connecting to the cluster so
this is how it would look so you have a
master which would obviously be
receiving some kind of heartbeats from
the chunk servers to know their status
and receive information in the form of
packets which would let the master know
which machines were available for
storage which machines already had data
and master would build up the metadata
within itself the files would be broken
down into chunks for example we can look
at file 1 it is broken down into chunk 1
and chunk 2 and file 2 has one chunk
which is one portion of it and then you
have file 2 residing on some other chunk
server which also lets us know that
there is some kind of auto replication
for this file system right and the data
which is getting stored in the chunk
could have a data of 64 mb now that
chunk size could be changed based on the
data size but google file system had the
basic size of the chunk as 64 mb each
chunk would be replicated on multiple
servers the default replication was
three and that could again be increased
or decreased as per requirement this
would also mean that if a particular
slave machine or a chunk server would
die or would get killed or would crash
there would never be any data loss
because a replica of data residing on
the failed machine would still be
available on some other slave server
chunk server or slave machine now this
helped google to store and process huge
volumes of data in a distributed manner
and does have a fault tolerant
distributed scalable storage which could
allow them to store a huge amount of
data now that was just one example which
actually led to the solution which today
we call as hadoop now when we talk about
big data here i would like to ask you
some questions that if we were talking
about the rdbms case take an example of
something like nasa which was working on
a a project called setai search of
extraterrestrial intelligence now this
was a project where they were looking
for a solution to take care of their
problem the problem was that they would
roughly send some waves in space capture
those waves back and then analyze this
data to find if there was any
extraterrestrial object in space now
they had two options for it they could
either have a huge server built which
could take care of storing the data and
processing it or they could go for
volunteer computing now volunteer
computing basically means that you could
have a lot of people volunteering and
being part of this project and what they
would in turn do is they would be
donating their ram and storage from
their machines when they are not using
it how would that happen basically
download some kind of patch on their
machine which would run as a screen
saver and if the user is not using his
machine some portion of data could be
transferred to these machines for
intermittent storage and processing
using ram now this sounds very
interesting and this sounds very easy
however it would have its own challenges
right think about security think about
integrity but those those problems are
not bigger as much as is the requirement
of bandwidth and this is the same thing
which happens in rdbms if you would have
to move data from archived solution to
the processing layer that would consume
huge amount of bandwidth big data brings
its own challenges
huge amount of data is getting generated
every day now the biggest challenge is
storing this huge volume of data and
especially when this data is getting
generated with lot of variety when it
can have different kind of formats where
it could be viral it could be having a
lot of value and nobody has looked into
the veracity of data but the primary
problem would be handling this huge
volume of data variety of the data would
bring in challenges of storing it in
legacy systems if processing of the data
was required now here again i would
suggest you need to think what is the
difference between reading a data and
processing a data so reading might just
mean bringing in the data from disk and
doing some io operations and processing
would mean reading the data probably
doing some transformations on it
extracting some useful information from
it and then storing it in the same
format or probably in a different format
so processing this massive volume of
data is the second challenge
organizations don't just store their big
data they would eventually want to use
it to process it to gather some insights
now processing and extracting insights
from big data would take huge amount of
time unless and until there was an
efficient solution to handle and process
this big data securing the data that's
again a concern for organizations right
encryption of big data is difficult to
perform if you would think about
different compression mechanisms then
that would also mean decompressing of
data which would also mean that you
could take a hit on the cpu cycles or on
disk usage providing user authentication
for every team member now that could
also be dangerous so that led to hadoop
as a solution so big data brings its own
challenges big data brings its own
benefits and here we have a solution
which is hadoop now what is hadoop it's
an open source framework for storing
data and running applications on
clusters of commodity hardware hadoop is
an open source framework and before we
discuss on two main components of hadoop
it would be good to look into the link
which i was suggesting earlier that is
companies using hadoop and any person
who would be interested in learning big
data should start somewhere here where
you could list down different companies
what kind of setup they have why are
they having hadoop what kind of
processing they are doing and how are
they using these so-called hadoop
clusters to process and in fact store
capture and process huge amount of data
another link which i would suggest is
looking at different distributions
of hadoop any person who is interested
in learning in big data should know
about different distributions of hadoop
now in linux we have different different
distributions like ubuntu centos red hat
susie debian in the same way you have
different distributions of hadoop which
we can look on the wiki page and this is
the link which talks about products that
include apache hadoop or derivative
works and commercial support which
basically means that apache hadoop the
sole products that can be called a
release of apache hadoop come from
apache.org that's an open source
community and then you have various
vendor-specific distributions like
amazon web services you have cloud era
you have hortonworks you have ibm's big
inside you have mapper all these are
different distributions of hadoop so
basically all of these vendor-specific
distributions are depending on using on
core apache hadoop in brief we can say
that these are the vendors which take up
the apache hadoop package it within a
cluster management solution so that
users who intend to use apache hadoop
would not have difficulties of setting
up a cluster setting up a framework they
could just use a vendor-specific
distribution with its cluster
installation solutions clustered
management solution and easily plan
deploy install and manage your cluster
so look into this link which talks about
different distributions of hadoop coming
back what is hadoop hadoop is a open
source framework for storing huge amount
of data and processing it it also
depends on commodity machines and it
does not need carrier class hardware now
when we say commodity machines we are
still talking about machines which are
higher than a basic laptop or a basic
server but then they are not at the
level of a carrier class hardware and
costing huge to the organization hadoop
as a framework has two main components
or i would say two processing layers it
has a storage layer which is called hdfs
hadoop distributed file system and it
has a processing layer which is called
yarn which can handle different
processing frameworks in which hadoop
map reduce is the oldest most mature and
most evolved processing framework sdfs
derives its existence from gfs it solves
the issue of storing huge amount of data
in a distributed fashion and mapreduce
is a programming model which allows to
process data which is distributed across
a cluster we will learn on sdfs and
mapreduce in further slides sdfs is a
storage layer now compare your laptop
compare your desktop that also has a
processing layer and a storage layer
your disks are your storage layer your
ram and cpu core is your processing
layer similarly hadoop as a solution has
a storage layer that is a distributed
file system which can store
huge amount of data in multiple machines
instead of a single machine or a single
server which basically makes it highly
reliable highly fault tolerant and
distributed for parallel processing
consider a data file of size one
gigabyte now if that was getting stored
in one single machine we would still
have the data getting stored in one or
multiple disks and if you would try to
read the data the seek time time taken
to read the data would be very high in
comparison to reading it from multiple
machines now sdfs like your gfs divides
the file into smaller chunks and stores
the data across the hadoop cluster in
previous versions of hadoop the default
block size was 64 mb however from hadoop
version 2 onwards the block size is 128
mb now that's customizable depending on
the average
size of the data which is coming into
the cluster the block size can be
changed the minimum block size is 128 mb
which basically means that every file
which is
less than or equal to 128 mb would use
one block and any file which goes beyond
the size of block will use multiple
blocks and these blocks would be
residing on the underlying slave
machines files are automatically split
by hadoop framework into blocks of
default block size and stored across the
cluster each node in your hadoop cluster
would have a bunch of disks that would
be storing these blocks now once we have
the data stored in a distributed fashion
that also gives us the flexibility of
going for distributed computing and when
we say distributed computing we are
talking about performing distributed
parallel processing on large volumes of
data take an example where we are
talking about one single machine or one
huge server which has four i o channels
and each input output channel can take
care of 100 megabytes of per second 100
megabytes of data per second so if we
have a data file of one terabyte it
would take approximately 43 minutes for
one machine to process one terabyte of
data if you compare that with
distributed computing where we are
talking about hundreds of machines each
machine having similar number of input
output channels in each channel having
the same capacity to handle 100
megabytes of data per second if a data
file of one terabyte had to be processed
in a parallel processing fashion using
distributed computing
it would take just 26 seconds for 100
machines to process one terabyte of data
in this environment now all of you might
be thinking that yeah this is right but
then what about the processing logic
that might be complicated and yes that
would be but then we have a mapreduce
programming model and a processing
framework to help us doing that now when
we look at one of the distributions of
hadoop that is hortonworks it also has
different resources that provide
security to your big data now before we
start talking on these different
services like apache nox apache ranger
which basically allow you to monitor
authorize and audit your hadoop clusters
let's also look at the history of hadoop
which started in 1999 with apache
software foundation in 2002 a nudge
created by doug cutting and mike
caffrell then duck cutting joined hadoop
and took
nuts product with him 2008 nudge was
divided and hadoop was born in 2008
yahoo released hadoop as an open source
project to asf in 2008 also hadoop based
startup cloud era incorporated cutting
left yahoo for cloudera yahoo was then
coming out with hortonworks as a
commercial hadoop distribution map r
technology also released hadoop
distribution green plum released hadoop
distribution and pivotal hd so this is a
brief on history of hadoop you can
always read about history of evolution
of hadoop how it started and today there
are more than 10 distributions which are
existing in market however cloudera is
the dominant one and as per recent news
items cloudera and hortonworks have
merged as one entity which will bring up
better solutions to the market here is a
quick demo on setting up cloudera quick
start vm in case you are interested in
working on a standalone cluster you can
download the cloudera quick start vm so
you can just type in download cloudera
quick start vm and you can search for
package now this can be used to set up a
quick start vm which would be a single
node cloudera based cluster so you can
click on this link and then basically
based on the platform which you would be
choosing to install such as using a vm
box or which version of cloudera you
would install so here i can select a
platform so i can choose virtualbox and
then you can click on get it now so give
your details and basically then it
should allow you to download the quick
start vm which would look something like
this and once you have the zip file
which is downloaded you can unzip it
which can then be used to set up a
single node cloud error cluster so once
you have downloaded the zip file that
would look something like this so you
would have a quick start virtual box and
then a virtual boss disk now this can be
used to set up a cluster ignore these
files which are related to amazon
machines and we you don't need to have
that so you would just have this and
this can be used to set up a cloud error
cluster so for this to be set up you can
click on file import appliance and here
you can choose your quick start vm by
looking into downloads quick start vm
select this and click on open now you
can click on next and that shows you the
specifications of cpu ram which we can
then change later and click on import
this will start importing virtual disk
image dot vmdk file into your bm box
once this is done we will have to change
the specifications or machines to use
two cpu cores minimum and give a little
more ram because cloudera quick start vm
is very cpu intensive and it needs good
amount of ram so to survive i will give
2 cpu cores and 5 gb ram and that should
be enough for us to bring up a quick
start vm which gives us a cloudera
distribution of hadoop in a single node
cluster setup which can be used for
working learning about different
distributions in cloudera clusters
working with sdfs and other hadoop
ecosystem components let's just wait for
this importing to finish and then we
will go ahead and set up a quick start
vm for our practice here the importing
of appliance is done and we see cloudera
quickstart machine is added to my list
of machines i can click on this and
click on settings as mentioned i would
like to give it more ram and more cpu
cores so click on system and here let's
increase the ram to at least
five and click on processor and let's
give it two cpu cores which would at
least be better than using one cpu core
network it goes for nat and that's fine
click on ok and we would want to start
this machine so that it uses two cpu
cores 5gb ram and it should bring up my
cloudera quick start vm now let's go
ahead and start this machine which has
our quick start vm it might take
initially some time to start up because
internally there will be various
cloudera services which will be starting
up and those services need to be up for
our cloud era quick start vm to be
accessible so unlike your apache hadoop
cluster where we start our cluster and
we will be starting all our processes in
case of cloudera it is your cloudera scm
server and agents which take care of
starting up of your services and
starting up of your different roles for
those services i explained in my
previous session that for a cloud era
cluster it would be these services let
me just show you that so in case of
apache cluster we start our services
that is we start our cluster by running
script and then basically those scripts
will individually start the different
processes on different nodes in case of
cloudera we would always have a cloudera
scm server which would be running on one
machine and then including that machine
we would have clouded icm agents which
would be running on multiple machines
similarly if we had a hortonworks
cluster we would have ambari server
starting up on the first machine and
then embody agents running on other
machines so your server component knows
what are the services which are set up
what are their configurations and agents
running on every node are responsible to
send heartbeats to the server receive
instructions and then take care of
starting and stopping off of individual
roles on different machines in case of
our single node cluster setup in quick
start vm we would just have one scm
server and one scm agent which will
start on the machine which will then
take care of all the roles which need to
be started for your different services
so we will just wait for our machine to
come up and basically have cloudera sem
server and agent running and once we
have that we need to follow few steps so
that we can have the cloudera admin
console accessible which allows you to
browse the cluster look at different
services look at the roles for different
services and also work with your cluster
either using command line or using the
web interface that is
now that my machine has come up and it
already is connected to the internet
which we can see here we need to do
certain things so that we can have our
admin console accessible at this point
of time you can click on terminal and
check if you have access to the cluster
so here type in host name and that shows
you your host name which is
quickstart.cloudera we can also type in
hdfs command to see if we have access
and if my cluster is working these
commands are same as you would give them
in a apache hadoop cluster or in any
other distribution of a loop sometimes
when your cluster is up and you have
access to the terminal it might take few
seconds or few minutes before there is a
connection established between cloudera
scm server and clouded scm agent running
in the background which takes care of
your cluster i have given a hdfs dfs
list command which basically should show
me what by default exists on my sdfs
let's just give it a couple of seconds
before it shows us out we can also check
by giving a service cloud era scm server
status and here it tells me that if you
would want to use cloudera express free
run this command it needs 8 gb of ram
and at least to virtual cpu codes and it
also mentions it may take several
minutes before cloudera manager has
started i can login as root here and
then give the command service cloud
error scm server status remember the
password for root is cloudera so it
basically says that if you would want to
check these settings it is good to have
express edition running so we can close
this my sdfs access is working fine
let's close the terminal and here we
have launch cloud error express click on
this and that will give you that you
need to give a command which is
force let's copy this command let's open
a different terminal and let's give this
command like this which will then go
ahead and shut down your cloudera based
services and then it will restart it
only after which you will be able to
access your admin console so let's just
give it a couple of minutes before it
does this and then we will have access
to our admin console here if you see it
is starting the cloudera manager server
again it is waiting for cloudera manager
api then starting the cloudera manager
agents and then configuring the
deployment as per the new settings which
we have given as to use the express
edition of cloudera once all this is
done it will say the cluster has been
restarted and the admin console can be
accessed by id and password as cloudera
we'll give it a couple of more minutes
and once this is done we are ready to
use our admin console now that
deployment has been configured client
configurations have also been deployed
and it has restarted the cloudera
management service it gives you an
access to quick start admin console
using username and password as cloud
error let's try accessing it so we can
open up the browser here and let's
change this to 7180
that's the default port and that shows
the admin console which is coming up now
here we can log in as cloud error cloud
error and then let's click on login now
as i said cloudera is very cpu intensive
and memory intensive so it would slow
down since we have not given enough gb
ram to our cloud error cluster and thus
it will be advisable to stop or even
remove the services which we don't need
now as of now if we look at the services
all of them look in a stop status and
that's good in one way because we can
then go ahead and remove the services
which we will not use in the beginning
and later we can anytime add services to
the cluster so for example i can click
on key value store here and then i can
scroll down where it says delete to
remove this service from the admin
console now anytime you are removing a
particular service it will only remove
the service from the management by cloud
direct manager all the role groups under
this service will be removed from host
templates so we can click on delete now
if this service was depending on some
other service it would have prompted me
with a message that remove the relevant
services on which this particular
service depends if the service was
already running then it would have given
me a message that the service has to be
stopped before it can be deleted from
the cloudera admin console now this is
my admin console which allows you to
click on services look at the different
roles and processes which are running
for this service we anyways have access
to our cloudera cluster from the
terminal using our regular sdfs or yarn
or
now i removed a service i will also
remove solar which we will not be using
for the beginning but then it depends on
your choice so we can here scroll down
to delete it and that says that before
deleting the solar service you must
remove the dependencies on this service
from the configuration of following
services that is hue now hue is a web
interface which allows you to work with
your sdfs and that is depending on this
so click on configure service dependency
and here we can make sure that our hue
service does not depend on a particular
service we are removing so that then we
can have a clean removal of the service
so i will click on none and i will say
save changes once this is done then we
can go ahead and try removing the solar
service from our admin console which
will reduce some load on my management
console which will also allow me to work
faster on my cluster now here we have
removed the dependency of hue on solar
so we can click on this and then we can
delete it remember i am only doing this
so that my cluster becomes little
lighter and i can work on my focus
services at any point of time if you
want to add more services to your
cluster you can anytime do that you can
fix different configuration issues like
what we see here with different warning
messages and here we have these services
which are already existing now if we
don't need any of the service i can
click on the drop down and click on
delete again this says that scoop 2 also
has relevance to hue so hue as a web
interface also depends on scope 2. as of
now we'll make it none at any point of
time later you can add the services by
clicking the add service option now this
is a cluster to which you have admin
access and this is a quick start vm
which gives you a single node cloud
error cluster which you can use for
learning and practicing so here we'll
click on scope 2 and then we will say
delete as we have configured the
dependency now and we will remove scope
2 also from the list of services which
your admin console is managing right so
once this is done we have removed three
services which we did not need we can
even remove scope as a client and if we
need we can add that later now there are
various other alerts which your cloudera
admin console shows and we can always
fix them by clicking on the health
issues or configuration issues we can
click here and see what is the health
issue it is pointing to if that is a
critical one or if that can be ignored
so it says there is an issue with a
clock offset which basically relates to
an ntp service network time protocol
which makes sure that one or multiple
machines are in the same time zone and
are in sync so for now we can click on
suppress and we can just say suppress
for all hosts and we can say look into
it later and confirm so now we will not
have that health issue reported that
probably the ntp service and the
machines might not be in sync now that
does not have an impact for our use case
as of now but if we have a kerberos kind
of setup which is for security then
basically this offset and time zone
becomes important so we can ignore this
message and we are still good to use the
cluster we also have other configuration
issues and you can click on this which
might talk about the heap size or the
ram which is available for machines it
talks about zookeeper should be in odd
numbers hue does not have a load
balancer sdfs only has one data node but
all of these issues are not to be
worried upon because this is a single
node cluster setup so if you want to
avoid all of these warnings you can
always click on suppress and you can
avoid and let your cluster be in all
green status but that's nothing to worry
so we can click on cluster and basically
we can look at the services so we have
removed some services which we don't
intend to use now i have also suppressed
a offset warning which is not very
critical for my use case and basically i
am good to start the cluster at any
point of time as i said if you would
want to add services this is the actions
button which you can use to add service
so we will just say restart my cluster
which will restart all the services one
by one starting from zookeeper as the
first service to come up we can always
click on this arrow mark and see what is
happening in the services what services
are coming up and in which order if you
have any issues you can always click on
the link next to it which will take you
to the logs and we can click on close to
let it happen in the background so this
will basically let my services restart
one by one and my cluster will then
become completely accessible either
using hue as a web interface or quick
start terminal which allows you to give
your commands now while my machines are
coming up you can click on hosts and you
can have a look at all the hosts we have
as of now only one which will also tell
you how many roles or processes are
running on this machine so that is 25
rolls it tells you what is the disk
usage it tells you what is the physical
memory being used and using this host
tab we can add new host to the cluster
we can check the configuration we can
check all the hosts in diagnostics you
can look at the logs which will give you
access to all the logs you can even
select the sources from which you would
want to have the logs or you can give
the host name you can click on search
you can build your own charts you can
also do the admin stuff by adding
different users or enabling security
using the administration tab so since we
have clicked on restart of a cluster we
will slowly start seeing all the
services one by one coming up starting
with zookeeper to begin with and once we
have our cluster up and running whether
that is showing all services in green or
in a different status we still should be
able to access the service now as we saw
in apache hadoop cluster even here we
can click on sdfs and we can access the
web ui once our sdfs service is up by
clicking on quick links so the service
is not yet up once it is up we should be
able to see the web ui link which will
allow you to check things from sdfs web
interface similarly yarn as a service
also has a web interface so as soon as
the service comes up under your quick
links we will have access to the yarn ui
and similarly once the service comes up
we will have access to hue which will
give you the web interface which allows
you to work with your sdfs which allows
you to work with your different other
components within the cluster without
even using the command line tools or
command line options so we will have to
give it some time while the cloud error
scm agent on every machine will be able
to restart the roles which are
responsible for your cluster to come up
we can always click here with tells that
there are some running commands in the
background which are trying to start my
cluster we can go to the terminal and we
can switch as hdfs user remember sdfs
user is the admin user and it does not
have a password unless you have set one
so you can just log in as sdfs which
might ask you for password initially
which we do not have so the best way to
do this is by logging in as root where
the password is cloudera and then you
can log in as hdfs so that then onwards
you can give your sdfs commands to work
with your file system now since my
services are coming up right now when i
try to give a hdfs dfs command it might
not work or it might also say that it is
trying to connect to the name node which
is not up yet so we will have to give it
some time and only once the name node is
up we will be able to access our sdfs
using commands so this is how you can
quickly set up your quick start and then
you can be working using the command
line options from the terminal like what
you would do in a apache hadoop cluster
you could use the web interfaces which
allow you to work with your cluster now
this usually takes more time so you will
have to give it some time before your
services are up and running and for any
reason if you have issues it might
require you to restart your cluster
several times in the beginning before it
gets accustomed to the settings what you
have given and it starts up the services
at any point of time if you have any
error message then you can always go
back and look in logs and see what is
happening and try starting your cluster
so this is how we set up a quick start
vm and you can be using this to work
with your cloudera cluster we will learn
today on setting up a apache hadoop
cluster although there are various
distributions of hadoop as we have
already discussed and you could set up a
apache hadoop cluster which is the core
distribution you could be setting up a
cloudera distribution of hadoop or even
a hortonworks however for cloudera you
would need machines which are really
powerful at least machines which have 16
gb of ram and in which you can set up
multiple virtual machines each virtual
machine of at least 4 to 5 gb same thing
applies for hotend works or you could
always download and set up a cloudera
quick start vm or a hortonworks sandbox
in this session we will learn how to set
up apache hadoop cluster which is the
core distribution and if one has learned
how to set up apache hadoop cluster then
they would understand the internals of
setting up a cluster different
configuration properties which are
needed for your cluster setup now for
this we need to set up multiple machines
as you see on my screen and for this you
will have to download the linux disk
image so we are using ubuntu for our
cluster setup you can always go to
google and type in ubuntu disk image iso
file and you could search for this
and that should show you a link like
this which says ubuntu 16.04
you can click on this link and depending
on your machine so my machine is 64-bit
machine and so i would download this
disk image which is already downloaded
on my machine and if your machine is a
32-bit machine then you can download
this one which is 32-bit pc i386 now to
set up apache cluster you could even do
it with a machine which has 4gb ram and
you could easily set up at least two
virtual machines which
can then be used to set up your cluster
now this also needs you to download a
virtualization software so you can type
in download oracle vm box it is pretty
lighter on the machine you can search
for the link you can easily say
wiki
and that should show you download oracle
vm box now i would suggest going for a
older version rather than going for the
latest version probably because that
might have some more patches to be
installed and you can click on an older
version of virtualbox and then based on
the machine which you have download the
relevant virtualbox version once you
have downloaded oracle vm box and once
you have downloaded the linux disk image
you are ready to set up machines within
your virtualization software which can
then be used to set up a cluster to set
up a machine click on new and here we
can give a name so let me give m1 i will
choose linux and i will choose windows
64 bit now in certain cases people might
have problem in not being able to list
down windows 64 bit and that basically
means that you have to enable
virtualization in your bio settings so
restart your machine get into bios
enable your virtualization and then you
should be able to see 64-bit option here
in any case and later if you face issues
with the oracle vm box you can also go
for vmware workstation click on next and
this tells you that you would want to
allocate ram so we can go for now with
1.5 gb depending on your machine you can
even give more ram to your every
individual machine within your
virtualization software so i'll choose
1.5 gb click on next now here it says
create a virtual hard disk or do you
want to add a virtual hard disk so we'll
say create a virtual hard disk now click
on create and then you can choose vmdk
that is virtual machine disk which will
also allow you to use the same disk
image in case you would want to use a
different virtualization software click
on next and then it says how do you want
your hard disk to be allocated so let's
go for dynamically allocated hard disk
that is as you store data on your disk
it will be using your parent disk
storage click on next and here we can
give the size of our disk so i'll keep
it 20 gb that's more than enough for
machines which will be hosting my apache
hadoop cluster click on create and we
have given the basic settings for my
machine however this does not have any
disk assigned to it so now while this is
highlighted click on settings and then
click on system here we can increase or
decrease the ram we can even give more
cpu to our machine that is cpu cores you
can click on storage and here where it
says empty click on this and from the
drop down select your disk image which
you would have already downloaded now
let's click on network and to have my
hadoop cluster setup i would need every
machine to have a different ip now i
could go for nat which is network
address translator but then every
machine would have the same ip address
so it's good to go for bridge adapter
and if you are using your own personal
network every machine setup will receive
a different ip address click on ok and
you have given all the settings for this
machine now you can click on start and
this will start your machine it will
recognize the disk image which you have
added and basically this should allow
you to give settings to set up your
first window machine let's just wait for
a couple of seconds and that should give
me an option which says either try
ubuntu or install ubuntu and we will go
ahead with installation of ubuntu
distribution of linux for our machine
now while this comes up i can always set
up one more machine quickly by clicking
on new giving a different name choosing
linux click on next let's give some ram
click on next create a virtual hard disk
now click on create choose vmdk click on
next dynamically allocated hard disk
click on next give the size of your hard
disk and then click on create once this
is done repeat the steps click on
settings
system
processor let's give it two cpu cores
storage click on empty and then let's
choose the disk image and in network i
will choose bridge adapter once this is
done click on ok and just to a start of
your second machine also so we can
parallely set up two machines which
might approximately take five to ten
minutes and once your machines are up we
can then go ahead installing some
relevant packages and hadoop to set up
our hadoop cluster now let's look at our
m1 machine and that's slowly coming up
using my disk image and once it comes up
i should be able to install ubuntu
in m1 so here is my machine which is
slowly coming up and let's look at the
second machine if that is also coming up
so click on machine one here and it says
the connection is established so it is
using the bridge adapter which we have
chosen and then it should show me the
options which allow me to go ahead with
installation options
here we can click on install ubuntu
it says download updates while
installing ubuntu it's good to select
this click on continue
it says erase this can install ubuntu
and we are good to do that because it's
not erasing anything from my parent disk
it is doing this for this particular
machine so click on install now
it says if you continue the changes
listed below will be written to the disk
we are fine with that click on continue
and now let's choose the time zone so in
my case it shows berlin in your case it
might show the city or the country where
you are in so click on continue and
don't worry if it says it's disconnected
from internet we don't need internet as
of now because we have already added the
disk image so the language selected is
english us unless you would want to have
it in a different language click on
continue
and it needs
name so let me give my name here i'll
say what would be my computer name so
i'll say m1 i'll give a username so we
need to have a common username across
all the machines which would be used for
hadoop cluster so pick a username and
type in a name i'm giving sdc i'll give
a simple password for my machines and
then click on continue
so all the relevant things are done for
this machine and then we will have to
give it around five to seven minutes
while it sets up everything and then
finally i will get a pop-up message
which says restart or reboot your
machine and my machine would be ready
the same things will do on my second
machine so i'll click on install ubuntu
then we can select download updates
while installing if it shows up and if
it says that there is no internet
connection nothing to worry we can
always come back to this click on
continue erase this can install ubuntu
so click on install now
click on continue
let's give a time zone here and click on
continue we can always change the time
zone later also once this is done you
will have to give your machine a name
and then also a user which you have
already set up in machine one now we
would have a hadoop cluster and we would
also have sdfs which would use the file
system from m1 and m2 does we need to
have a common user which is set up in
all the machines which you would use for
your hadoop cluster setup so wait till
it gives you different options and
carefully select your machine name your
username and give it a simple password
click on continue
and here i'll give my name i'll say this
will be my machine too i'll say hdc as
the user i'll give a simple password and
let's click on continue now we will have
to wait for five to seven minutes my
first machine is already being set up
and my second machine will start now
once both the machines are set up and
once i get a message please reboot your
machine we will have to wait both of my
machines
are almost about to be set up and they
will give me an option to reboot now
meanwhile what you can also do is you
can download the cloudera quick start vm
so you can just type in download
cloud error
quick
start vm and you can search for the
package now this can be used to set up a
quick start vm which would be a single
node cloudera based cluster so you can
click on this link and then basically
based on the platform which you would be
choosing to install such as using a vm
box or which version of cloudera you
would install so here i can select a
platform so i can choose virtualbox and
then you can click on get it now so give
your details and basically then it
should allow you to download the quick
start vm which would look something like
this and once you have the zip file
which is downloaded you can unzip it
which can then be used to set up a
single node cloud error cluster so once
you have downloaded the zip file that
would look and something like this so
you would have a quick start virtual box
and then a virtual boss disk now this
can be used to set up a cluster ignore
these files which are related to amazon
machines and we you don't need to have
that so you would just have this and
this can be used to set up a cloud error
cluster which we can learn in further
sessions there is another option that
you could just be setting up one machine
and then your vm box has an option of
cloning the machine where you can set up
one machine with all the details like
java hadoop packages and other relevant
packages and then you can clone it but
then you will have to take care that
both the machine should have different
ip which means once the machines are up
and if you have cloned the machine then
you would have to manually change the ip
address in the machines so either you
could go for this option or do it as i
am doing here that is set up two
machines individually now it would give
you this message which says installation
is complete you need to restart the
computer in order to use the new
installation click on restart now and
that should restart my m1 and similarly
i get a message for m2 so i'll click on
restart now and both my machines should
restart so click on m1 again and here it
might say you have to remove the
installation media so we can click on
enter and this should basically start my
machine same thing applies to machine 2
so this will also say remove the
installation media and we were just
using a disk image so we have to just
hit on enter and that should basically
bring up my machine it will also be
advisable that if your machine is low on
ram you can set up one machine and then
you can use ssh related utilities to
copy the data from one machine to other
machine so let's click on machine one
and let's go ahead and set this up now
we will have to install some packages
like wget which allows you to download
things from internet we will have to
download hadoop package we will also
have to download oracle jdk which will
be used although apache works with
openjdk it is advisable that we go for
oracle jdk and ubuntu machines by
default do not have java installed so we
will have to download the oracle jdk
package until it and then set up our
java and these steps have to be repeated
on both the machines so that my both
machines can be used for a cloud era
cluster
so i'm waiting for my m1 machine to come
up so that i can check its ip address i
can update its ip address and host name
and then i can start downloading the
packages which will be needed for
setting up a hadoop cluster so my
machine one is up here i can click in
the password box and i can given my
simple password which i had set up for
my machine one and hit on enter so that
should allow you to log in and same
thing applies to machine two which is
still coming up so let's go back to
machine one and let's wait for its basic
utilities and programs to come up so
that we can start configuring our
machine now remember if you can
configure your machine in the simple way
and as smooth as possible then setting
up your cluster will become a cakewalk
so you can click on cancel if there are
some issues
like this
no need to worry about it we are going
for a simple apache cluster on two nodes
so meanwhile let me also log into
machine 2 by giving in my password and
then hit on enter
now in both my machines on the right
corner you might see the double arrow
marks which basically tells that your
machine should be connected to internet
and you should have no problem in
downloading packages from internet
however if you have some issues then we
will have to troubleshoot those and make
sure that you can at least set up one
machine which can also allow you to set
up a apache hadoop sudo distributed
cluster that is a single node cluster
however to have the feel of a two node
cluster or at least a three node cluster
it would be good to have two machines up
and running both connected to internet
both having java both have their ip
addresses updated and both having the
hadoop package downloaded so now my
machine one is up it looks like it is
connected to internet from the right
corner i can click on this
and then i can type in terminal
and
click on terminal
so this is my terminal and i'm already
logged in as hdc user which i had
selected in the beginning so let's start
by
typing in ifconfig which gives me the ip
address of machine it is 0.116
and what i will do is i will log in as
root by typing in sudo su and given your
password
you're logged in as root
come back to the parent directory and
then let's go to etc
hosts where i will update the ip address
of this machine it is 192.168.0.116.
here
let's get rid of this
and let's say 192 168 0.116
and my host name of this machine is m1
so let's update this now i could get the
ip address of my other machine also so
that i could basically make these
machines ping each other so let's do the
same thing here i will type in terminal
and
click on this
and let's quickly get the ip address of
this machine which should be a different
ip address than my machine one so let's
type in ifconfig and this says 0.217
which i will update here so i will say
192 168 0.217
and that's my machine 2 and same thing
we'll do it in machine 2 also
so let's go to machine 2
let's login as root
let's give the password
and then let's go into etc
hosts
remove the erroneous entry
and then give
192.168.0.116 which is my
machine 1 192. 168.0.217.
that is machine 2 and then save it
and let's check if my machine 2 can ping
machine 1 using the host name and that
works perfectly fine let's do the same
thing for machine 1 so we'll say ping
machine 2
and that should also work fine
it would also be good and required that
we disable firewall so we can say ufw
disable the firewall on machine 1
and
let's repeat the same on machine 2 so
ufw
disable
and
the firewall should be disabled even in
machine 2. so both the machines can ping
each other both the machines have
firewall disabled their atc host is
updated and as i said
both machines would not have
java installed so if we check by giving
a command java minus version or java
hyphen version it will say java is not
installed which basically means that we
need to have oracle jdk installed on
both the machines or at least download
the jdk package on one machine which can
then be copied across other machine
so we are logged in as root and let's
first quickly start installing some
packages so i'll say apt-get install w
get now this can be used to download
packages from internet and we will
download wget
it's done now let's also
install open ssh server so that we can
later have a password less access from
one machine to other machine using ssh
so i'm installing open ssh server i've
already installed wget and these two
packages should be enough to begin with
we also need the oracle jdk to be
downloaded from web so my open ssh setup
is almost done here now let's repeat
these steps quickly on m2 so i'll say
apt get
install w get
now if you get this kind of message
which basically means that some other
process is using it then we can always
open a quickly different terminal and
that itself should resolve the issue so
now let's go in here and let's try again
it still doesn't work now let me just
login as root
give the password and then let's try
doing this or we will have to kill the
process yeah so it says there is some
kind of lock now i'm already logged in
as root so i can just say
remove from where
lib d
package
slash lock
and then let's try doing it again it
still gives a problem
let's again try doing a installation
step and sometimes you might have this
kind of error message where it says it's
not able to receive a lock or unlock so
let's go in here let's check what do we
have in where
lib d package
there is a log file
and we will have to remove this
okay and now
does that work yeah so now it says it
could not get a lock on some other file
so let's remove that also which is
cache
archives
log file and let's try it again
and it's working so sometimes we might
have such issues and we have to quickly
look what is the reason might be you can
always do a google and try to fix those
issues so it's trying to connect to
archive and basically download the
package we'll come back to this machine
let's go to machine one where we had
installed w get an open ssh server we
need java so let's open up the browser
and then let's search for oracle jdk and
we can go for 1.8 or even 1.9 that
doesn't matter we basically need a java
to be set up on our machines now if you
look in the usual path which is user lib
there might not be a directory such as
jvm we can see what is in user lib and
it has various other things but nothing
which points to java so
let's go to our browser and let's type
oracle jdk 1.8 now that is what i'm
interested in setting up on both the
machines let's look at our machine 2
status it is still trying to connect and
we might have to give it some time
that's why i was mentioning that we can
always go set up one machine perfectly
and once that is done we can always do a
clone or we can copy or download the
packages now here i have the package or
the link which points me to oracle jdk
1.8 let's click on this link
it will ask you to accept the agreement
by giving your choices and this is only
for the first time
so i say i accept all cookies
and then it basically shows me the
packages here so let's scroll up and we
have different releases of eight now you
don't need to go for a very old one but
then it would be good to have a stable
one so i can say accept license
agreement and then since mine is a
64-bit machine i can go for x64 tar file
and that should download
my java related dar file additionally we
also need hadoop package so we can open
up a different browser and i can
straight away say archive.apache.org
although you could also search for
apache releases and you could download
now this archive page will not only show
you hadoop but it will show you all
different apache packages which can be
downloaded and then we can set up on our
machines so click on archive of public
software releases and here we will
search for hadoop
click on hadoop
and then hadoop has different components
or projects you can say common or core
so click on common and here it lists
down all the different versions of
hadoop so let's scroll down and let's
pick a stable one now you can also
download the latest version and set up
that but i would suggest go for a stable
one so let's click on hadoop 2.6.5
and here we will download the hadoop
related tar file
again to repeat we will need the hadoop
tar file we will need the java to be
installed on all the nodes so my java is
getting downloaded my hadoop is getting
downloaded and these are the two things
which i need to set up my hadoop cluster
let's check what is happening in machine
2 so it has already downloaded wget now
let's also get open ssh server here
and let it install but i will not
download my hadoop and java here because
we have the tar file downloaded on first
machine and once we have a ssh setup we
can always copy the tar files from my
machine 1 to machine 2.
let's go back here and let's give it
just
one minute and it will download the
packages meanwhile what we can also do
is we can go to the terminal and we can
give our user that is hdc root
privileges so that for any other root
related work we don't have to switch to
root user every time so let's click on
this terminal and basically add our user
to the sudo list so here let's clear
screen i'm logged in as root so let's
type in vi sudo hit enter and here
scroll down to the line which says root
and here i can say escape i i can say
htc and i can say my htc user
should have the same privileges as root
now let's say control x twice and just
save it and enter so now your user hdc
will also have the root privileges and
can give a sudo command now we have also
downloaded our
packages in this path so we have hadoop
we have java and we need to basically
unpack them we basically need to untie
them so both of them have been
downloaded so let's close these browsers
let's go in here and first thing what
i'll do is i will
or i will change
my
directory to user lib i will create a
directory here called jvm i will switch
to jvm and then i will say tar xvf home
htc downloads and then given my jdk
package which needs to be untied here
so this is basically unpacking my jdk
tar file which will create a jdk based
directory which will have the binaries
for my java
once this is done we should have java
installed on this machine
it's done
and let's see this is my jdk
and if you look in jdk slash bin these
are my java related programs so my java
path is user lib jvm jdk so let's go to
this directory and let's copy this path
and let's update it in the bash file of
root and my dedicated user so every user
has a bash rc file or a batch profile
now i will update in bash rc
export
java underscore home
let's give this path let's say export
path
java
underscore home slash pin so i can give
my java commands from anywhere and let's
copy this
so that we can update the same thing in
htc user
let's save this and let's refresh this
file using a source bash rc
okay now we can test if my java version
shows up for my root user and that shows
1.8.0 this is done you can optionally
also install vim which basically gives
you a good layout when you are editing
your files in different colors
some people prefer using vim when they
are editing their files and i'll show
you the difference once you have them
installed
we can always look into the same bash rc
which will show in multiple colors
remember we need to update the java path
for our hdc user so now first let's look
at the bash rc file and look at this
this basically tells you the path which
you have set up now same thing we'll do
for our hdc user so let's login as htc
let's get into bash rc
and here
i will say
give your java path
save it
refresh it
and
your java
version should show up even if you are
logged in as htc so my java setup is
done now i also need to enter
my hadoop related directory
which we downloaded and we will do that
in a particular location so let's
switch to user local directory now you
could do that anywhere i'm doing it here
and i'll say sudo tar xvf
home htc downloads and then my hadoop
related tar file which i would want to
unpack here and this also shows that my
sudo access works fine for my hdc user
this is unpacking my hadoop tar file in
the chosen location
and once this is done we will have a
hadoop directory created under user
local
let's look and i have a hadoop directory
which is owned by hdc user and it will
always be good to have our hadoop path
more simple rather than having user
local hadoop 2.6.5
so i will create a link
and i will call it hadoop
so sometimes you have to use the sudo
permission because you are in local
directory and then let's change the
ownership to hdc
for anything which starts with
once this is done we have our link which
is hadoop pointing to 2.6.5 which is
also beneficial if you would want to use
a different version of hadoop you could
always unlink hadoop and create a link
pointing to your newer version you don't
have to then change the hadoop path in
your rc every time you work on a
different version so once this is done
let's look into hadoop
and this basically has a bin
directory which has my binaries or you
can say the programs or commands which
we will use to work with hadoop it has a
sbin directory which basically has the
startup scripts and it has etc directory
which has hadoo and that has my config
files so first let's set the hadoop path
for my user so i will go to bash rc file
again and here
i can add
some lines so i'll say export hadoop
underscore install so earlier the
parameter was hadoop underscore home but
now it's had open score installed we'll
say user
local
hadoop
then we will say export
path
you can do it in different ways so let's
keep it simple and let's say hadoop
underscore install slash bin so that i
can give my
hadoop commands from anywhere rather
than going to user local hadoop and
similarly i'll say export path
hadoop
underscore install slash s bin so that i
can even give my startup and stop
scripts from anywhere in the machine
rather than going to the hadoop specific
path once this is done save it
and refresh it
and if all is fine we should be able to
check our hadoop version by giving a
hadoop command so we have set up our
java we have unpacked hadoop and we have
given the entries in my bash rc same
things have to be repeated on machine 2
but not yet now first thing what we will
do is we will set up a passwordless
access across machines so that i can log
in from machine 1 to machine 2 or vice
versa without a password which will also
be needed when you set up a hadoop
cluster and start your processes across
machines if your ssh setup is done it
will avoid you to given password of your
machines individually so let's say ssh
key gen hyphen t rsa hyphen capital p
and without a passphrase let's set up
ssh key which now has created a dot ssh
directory that has a private and public
key and for our ssh to work fine we need
to have the public key transferred to
other machine now let's go to m2 and
let's generate the
ssh key on m2 also so our ssh server is
already installed as we did on my first
machine we will also say apt-get install
vim
we also need to make sure that our user
here has the root access so while this
is getting done you can always open up a
new terminal
you can login as root
and you can go to vi sudo
and here we will add
our user which is hdc like what we did
on first machine all
all
control x twice do a yes
and enter so we have given the user here
the privilege is to give a sudo command
this is what we did on machine one
now this machine is reacting little slow
where it needs to generate a or it needs
to download a package meanwhile let's
open up a terminal and let's do the ssh
key part which doesn't need downloading
and always remember your ssh keys are
user specific so here ssh key gen
hyphen t rsa hyphen capital p and it's
done
so we can check
even on this machine we have a ssh
directory and that has private and
public keys so what we need to do is we
need to copy our public key from machine
1 to machine 2 and from machine 2 to
machine 1 so here i'll say ssh copy id
hyphen i
i'll give my home directory i'll say
take the rsa public file and let's copy
to sdc
m2
say yes
and give your password
so that should have copied your public
key and once you have done that you can
always look in dot ssh now you have a
known underscore host file which has
entry of machine 2 where you have copied
your public key if you look on machine 2
in my other terminal
and if i look in dot ssh it has
authorized keys so when you copy your
public key from machine 1 to machine 2
in machine 2 we have authorized keys and
in machine 1 we have known underscore
host now let's repeat the same step here
let's say
home dot ssh id underscore rsa.public
and let's copy it to hdc at m1
say yes
and
give the password and that should have
copied your public key to m1 now if you
look in dot ssh this also has known
underscore host
and if we look in m1 that will have
authorized keys which basically means
your ssh setup should be fine let's test
by typing in ssh m2 and that should
allow me to log into m2 without a
password
let's log out and let's check the same
thing from m2 ssh m1 and that works fine
we also need to copy our public keys to
the same machine so i'll say cat
from my home directory
id underscore rsa dot public and let's
append it to the same location
in ssh directory in authorized
underscore keys
once this is done test the ssh to m2
from m2 itself
say yes
and it works fine to a log out and let's
do the same thing on m1 so cat
home dot ssh id underscore rsa dot
public let's append it in same location
in authorized underscore keys
let's test ssh to itself say yes and
that's fine
this will also be required when we set
up a cluster and we start our processes
that is hadoop specific processes on the
machine it will not ask for password
because you have set up ssh across
machines and locally to itself now once
this is done we basically have two
machines which can not only ping each
other but they can also do a ssh to each
other let's also check in machine 2 if
my installation of whim is done and
that's also done now what we also need
is on this machine that is m2 we
basically need the java package and we
need the hadoop package so let's copy
from machine one so i can copy the
complete directory or i can copy the tar
file so i would suggest copying the tar
files and then unpacking them so that we
can have less data transferred over
network so i can say scp
home hdc downloads
let's take the jdk package and let's
copy it to hdc at m2 in the temp
directory so this shows that you don't
need to download jdk and hadoop on all
the machines just download it on one
machine and then copy it across once
your ssh is set up similarly we can
copy the hadoop tar file to the other
machine also this is an easier way in
fact you could write your bash scripts
or ansible scripts to deploy all the
packages across the machines
now let's go to m2 and here we can then
first create a directory in user lib
and call it as jbm like what we did on
first machine and then i can change my
location to jvm i can say sudo tar xvf
and then from temp i'll get the jdk
package and i'll unpack it here
once this is done we need to make sure
that our bash rc is updated or we can
even copy that from machine 1 to machine
2. now this should create a jdk
directory here on machine 2 as it did on
machine 1 and that's owned by if there
is a problem with ownership it's good to
change the ownership manually to root
case that creates a problem later once
this is done we have our jdk let's
see
if everything is fine and it's fine now
similarly i will go to user local
directory i will say sudo tar xvf from
temp
let's unpack the hadoop in user local
location as we did on machine one and
once this is done we need to create a
link we need to change the ownership and
we need to update the bash rc
and this is
done
now i can see i have a hadoop directory
it's owned by hdc okay i can create a
link
to this call it as hadoop
let's change the ownership to htc of
anything that starts with hadoop and we
have our hadoop path also set correctly
now all i need is from my machine one
while i'm logged in as hdc i'll say scp
copy the bash rc from here into hdc m2
in home hdc which has my java path my
hadoop path updated let's go here and
let's do a source
bash rc and then let's check if my java
version shows up correctly
that's fine let's check if hadoop
version shows up correctly and that's
fine so now we have two machines which
have java which have hadoop package
which can ping each other which have ssh
access and which have firewall disabled
these two machines can then be used to
set up my hadoop cluster
once we start editing the config files
and that config files can be found in
user
local hadoop
etc
in both the machines
user
local
hadoop
etc
this is where we will edit our config
files and then we are ready to bring up
our cluster which will be a two node
cluster for my hadoop my strategy would
be
on m1 machine i would have a name node i
would have a data node i would have a
resource manager and i would have a node
manager running
on my m2 machine i would have a data
node i would have a node manager
and i would have a secondary name node
running so this is the plan for cluster
setup on these two machines to set up
our hadoop cluster we will need the
config files and i have updated my
config files in github link so let's go
to github you can always refer to this
git link which i am showing on the
screen where i have the config files
updated
and we can just easily copy our config
files from here
so
let's click on
this link
and here i have given the config files
so we can click on hadoop 2.6.5
and this basically has my
five important config files which we
need to update in both the machines now
let's go to machine one and here let's
go to user
local
hadoop
edc
and here the first config file which i
will update is core hyphen site file
let's
get into this which has nothing as
configuration specified now as i
mentioned when i was explaining hdfs
that in apache hadoop we would have to
download the hadoop related package we
will have to edit the configs we would
have to do the formatting and then we
would have to start the cluster however
if it was cloudera or hortonworks or any
other vendor-specific distribution
downloading the packages editing the
config files formatting the cluster
would be taken care by your installer
now here let's go to the git link and
let's get the contents of core hyphen
site file which basically tells the sdfs
path the location where my name node
would run and the port to which my name
node will listen to so let's click on
core hyphen site file and get the config
files
or the properties scroll down and we
just need to give this although there
can be many other properties which can
be specified but we will just go for a
simple setup
copy this
come to your terminal and here i can
just paste it now this tells the
property is fs or default fs which is
also used if developers are coding their
file system api and would want to
connect to sdfs now here i will change
my machine name m1 and this is the
machine where my name node will run and
it will use 9000 port sdfs colon slash
m1 9000 let's save this and our first
config file is edited now the next file
which we would want to edit is map red
hyphen site file and what we can do here
is my map red file shows up as template
so i'll just rename it
as map red hyphen site dot xml and then
let's edit it which tells
what processing framework we would be
using or what processing layer we will
be using let's go to the git link again
and let's
pick up the information of map red
hyphen site file which is
here and the processing layer which we
will be using
is yarn so let's copy this again there
can be many more properties specifying
your
values of memory for map and radios and
many other properties we will just go
for a basic setup which is more than
enough even to test out all the
functionalities of adobe cluster so my
processing framework will be yarn let's
save this and we have edited the second
file similarly we will also edit my
third file which is hdfs hyphen site
file so let's go into this which
basically tells what will be my
replication factor where will my name
node store metadata on disk if i plan to
run the data node here where will data
node store the blocks and so on so let's
go to sdfs hyphen site file
let's give the properties so let's go in
here
and let's get the content of sdfs hyphen
site file scroll down
and let's get all these values that is
replication
the path of metadata on disk the path
where my data blocks will get stored
what is the http port my name node will
use what is the http port my secondary
name node will use
and my secondary name notes check
pointing frequency which is by default
one hour but we will be setting it up as
10 minutes
let's copy this and
here i will
paste it now let's make some changes
here quickly so i plan to run two data
nodes so i can go for a replication of
at least two since i'm planning to run
two data nodes i've given a metadata
path that this is the path where my name
node will store metadata on disk
metadata on ram is dynamically built
metadata on disk needs a path that's why
we are giving this as we plan to run
name node here we also plan to run a
data node here and we will give the path
for my data node to store its blocks now
remember since we are in apache hadoop
cluster we will have to create this abc
directory the name and data directory
will get automatically created now this
also tells what http port my name node
will use and here i will specify my name
node would run on m1
and it will use an http port 570 for my
secondary name node i would want it to
run on my other machine so i'll specify
m2 and it will use 590 port now since
i'm planning to run my secondary name
node on my second machine i don't need
to give this property here i'll give
this property in my m2 machines hdfs
file so let's delete this and our hdfs
is set up the next file which we need to
edit is yarn hyphen site file which
tells about your resource manager your
resource tracker and some other
properties
so let's go into yarn hyphen site file
and let's get the values from here which
if you scroll down you should be able to
find
and scroll down and you have these four
properties now there can be many other
properties as i said like specifying how
much memory you want to allocate for
node manager or how many cpu cores or do
you want to enable or disable physical
or virtual memory check or do you want
to enable log aggregation so you can
copy all these properties
from yarn hyphen side file
and
let's place it in
my
machine
now these are all my properties let's
carefully check if everything is fine my
resource manager is intended to run on
m1 if you want to run it on some other
machine then you would have to give the
hostname of that machine my resource
tracker which helps your resource
manager to know about resources
will also run on m1 but on a different
port i have some shuffle classes which
are relevant now this property tells how
much amount of memory you would want to
allocate for your node manager on this
machine
now either we could keep it minimum or
we could let yan decided for us so let
me get rid of this
and the cpu course so the default memory
and the default core which yarn will
assume for your machines for your node
managers would be 8 gb and 8 cores
rest properties can be left as they are
you don't need to make any changes
save them and your yarn is also done now
we will edit a slaves file which tells
on which machines will my data nodes run
and hence my node managers run so i'll
say m1 and m2 so my five main files are
edited which is coresight map red site
sdfs yarn and slaves now you can also
edit hadoop environment and yarn
environment but that's not mandatory
which mentions about your java path
which mentions the heap size that is the
amount of ram which will be used when
your process comes up the default value
is 1gb and you don't need to make
changes so let it be as it is i don't
make any changes to hadoop environment
now once these config files are edited
let's quickly copy them across m2 and
then we can edit them in m2 i'll say scp
take the core file and let's copy to sdc
m2 in user
local
hadoop
etc
hadoop that's the path
done let's copy the other files also
which is my map red file
so map red file
let's copy this
let's copy the yarn file slaves file and
sdfs file
so that's my on file
let's copy the hdfs file
and let's copy the slaves file
so all my files are copied
or should have been copied by now
to my m2 machine and then we can
accordingly update the things
in m2 and i don't need to really switch
to m2 i can just say ssh m2
because i can log in from here i can go
into user local
hadoop
etc hadoop
and now we can look in the core file
which doesn't need any changes because
this tells what would be your sdfs path
and where your name node runs
and this would be same because we would
have data nodes running on every machine
talking to the name node so they need to
know where your name node is running on
what port so we don't make any changes
to the core file
map red file doesn't need any change
so here we have the framework as yarn
also what you can do is
to make sure
remove if there is any template file
let's look into hdfs file and this will
have some changes
so replication no that doesn't need a
change do we need a path
which tells where metadata is stored no
because our name node does not run on
this machine
do we need a path for data node yes and
let's give just a naming convention
let's add a number two here which tells
me that this is second data node http
port is fine secondary name nodes port
is fine and then we can give the
checkpoint period property which tells
how frequently should my secondary name
node do the checkpointing now as i said
the default time frame is one hour but
then we can set it to a lower time frame
by giving a property
that is in my sdfs file which we had
deleted from machine 1 but we will
retain it in machine 2.
this is the property which tells what is
the frequency of checkpointing that
secondary name node should follow
so let's give it here
and this says every 10 minutes i would
want my secondary name node to do a
checkpointing and have a copy of
metadata of name node that name node
stores on the disk now i am not
specifying a path where secondary name
node should keep a copy of name nodes
metadata on disk and by default my
secondary name node will store it in
temp and that's fine for now so let's
save this
now let's also look in
yarn file if we need any change which
tells resource manager will run on m1
that's fine resource tracker will run on
m1 that's fine shuffle classes some
other properties which tell don't check
for physical and virtual memory and log
aggregation so we really don't make any
change to our yarn file and our slaves
file which tells where my data nodes
will run that means where my data nodes
and node managers will run we don't make
any changes
so all my config files are edited on m1
and on m2 now don't forget to create the
directory which you have mentioned in
the config files that is abc and make
sure that our hdc user has the
permissions to this or you might have
some failures so i'll say
abc that's done let's do the same thing
on m1
and let's change the ownership
of this directory now once all these
steps are done
are both the machines are set up to
basically have a hadoop cluster running
but that cannot happen without be doing
a formatting formatting is the first
step which will create the initial
metadata
in the metadata path so as of now we
have nothing in abc directory so we will
do a formatting of sdfs which basically
prepares the sdfs to store the data so
i'll say hdfs name node format and this
has to be given only once because this
creates the initial metadata in the name
nodes path which we have mentioned in
this dfs file once the formatting is
done no matter how many times you
restart your machines you will never do
a formatting again because if you do a
formatting again it will bring your
cluster to the initial state
let's do a formatting which should
create my initial metadata in the abc
directory and that would also create a
slash name directory as we have
specified in our config files once this
is done have a look at your abc
directory and that has name name has
current and in current you have the
initial fs image which is the file
system image which tells as of 2327
your machine has this now once this is
done we can also look into abc slash
name slash current and here we can look
into the version file which has the
initial identifiers that is your
namespace id cluster id and blockpool id
and this was the reason i mentioned that
you should never ever do a formatting
again because reformatting will change
these identifiers and set them to new
ones however your data nodes which will
also have a copy of these
might not get updated now once your
formatting is done once your initial
metadata is created we can just say
start hyphen all dot sh and this script
internally will run two scripts
this script internally triggers start
dfs dot sh and
start yarn dot sh and internally these
scripts actually run hadoop
demon dot sh
start
and then your process name such as name
node or data node or secondary name node
and yarn daemon dot sh start
resource manager and node managers for
more information you can always refer to
the s bin directory which talks about
these scripts or which shows these
scripts which you can check in user
local hadoop s bin which has the
individual or startup scripts so now
let's click on start hyphen all dot sh
and if everything is fine it should
basically start your cluster now it says
the script is deprecated use start dfs
and start yarn but it will still work
now since we have set up ssh access it
does not ask or prompt for a password it
starts your name node it starts your
data nodes and then it will basically
start your secondary name node and
resource manager finally your node
managers so we will have a two node
cluster now which uses two machines
which we set up that is m1 and m2 it has
one single name node it has two data
nodes one secondary name node and it
will have one resource manager which is
the master of processing layer and then
two node managers which are the
processing slaves we can always check
the processes using jps command for java
related processes
and we can check on other machine
for my processes
and we have a two node cluster up and
running which has two data nodes two
node managers one name node one resource
manager and one secondary named node we
can also look into the abc directory on
m2 which will now have a directory for
data node
and that will have a version file which
can be looked into for identifiers and
you can always look into a different
version file which is
here so you have two version files and
both of these version file have the
identifiers which they have received
from the name
where will my blocks get stored it will
be stored in current finalized and then
it will be within this path if we write
data to sdfs where my blocks will come
and get stored let's check the same
thing on machine 2 which only had a name
directory in abc
which now also has a data directory
and similarly it has the version file at
under current directory or a version
file which is under the block pool
directory
so this is my two node cluster we can
quickly give a command that is
hdfs dfs admin report or you can always
check what are the options in sdfs by
typing in hdfs and here you have an
option called dfs admin again you can
check for all the different options with
dfs admin
and here on the top we will have an
option called
report so these are all the commands
used by an admin so you have report live
dead or decommissioning so we can check
how many nodes we have by typing in hdfs
the fs admin report which should show me
that i have two data nodes how much of
those nodes is configured for
distributed file system how much is for
local machine
are they responding to name node by
looking at the last contact time which
will get updated every three seconds and
you have machine one and machine two
which are two nodes or two live data
nodes of your hadoop cluster this is via
a command
we can always go
and use the browser
and look at the web ui
so i can check m1
using its http port to have a look at my
name node
which tells me what is my cluster id
what is my block pool id
the configured capacity how many live
nodes we have is there a situation of
under replicated blocks
and it tells me that there are no dead
nodes you can click on live nodes
and that gives you your two data nodes
what is their capacity how much is being
used how many blocks does that have is
there any situation of failed volumes
and you can look for more information
you can always look in here and you can
say browse the file system or look at
logs which you can also find from your
machine in your hadoop directory but you
can click on browse the file system as
of now we don't have any data and this
is the web ui for your sdfs for your
name node however this does not allow
you to work with sdfs it only allows you
to browse through sdfs and your hadoop
cluster you also have a ui for resource
manager and that should be accessible
using
the default port which is for resource
manager and as i mentioned since we did
not configure the amount of memory and
cpu cores which is allocated to every
node manager on every node it will go
for default memory settings that is 8 gb
and default cores which will be 8 cores
per node all of those settings can be
changed but then to begin with you can
have a simple cluster with two node
which says there is 16 gb memory
available although that's not true you
have 16b cores but then we have two
nodes
where we have data nodes running and we
have node managers running which will be
used for processing our data on this
hadoop cluster so this is
a simple two node apache cluster which
can then be used to write data process
it and store data in a distributed
fashion
thank you rj for that fascinating
session next up we have both ajay and
richard to take you through the entire
hadoop ecosystem and its components
today we're covering the hadoop
ecosystem at least the very fundamentals
of all the different parts that are in
the hadoop ecosystem and it's very
robust it's grown over the years with
different things added in there's a lot
of overlapping in a lot of these tools
but we're just going to cover these
basic tools so you can see what's
available in the hadoop ecosystem so
let's go back to our hadoop ecosystem as
you can see we have all our different
setup and let's focus on the hadoop part
of it first before we look at the
different tools we start with the hadoop
or hdfs is for data storage the hdfs or
the hadoop file system is currently used
by companies all over the world all the
big names uber facebook visa intel
amazon web service douchebank ebay
pivotal yahoo all of these are using the
hadoop file system and way beyond this
this is just like a small picture of
some of the main companies using it this
company used hdfs to overcome the
problem of storing a massive amount of
data let us look how hadoop or hdfs came
into existence and what hdfs is all
about in the traditional approach all
the data was stored in a single central
database with the rise of big data a
single database was not enough for
storage and i remember the old sun
computers or the huge ibm machines with
all the flashing lights now all the data
on one of those can be stored on your
phone it's almost a bit of humor how
much this has accelerated over the years
the same thing with our rise of big data
no longer can you just store it on one
machine no longer can you go out and buy
a sun computer and put it on that one
sun computer no more can you buy a craig
machine or an enterprise ibm server it's
not going to work you're not going to
fit it all into one server the solution
was to use distributed approach to store
the massive amount of data data was
divided and distributed amongst many
individual databases and you can see
here where we have three different
databases going on so you might actually
saw this in one where they divided up
the user accounts a through g so on by
the letter and so the first query would
say what's the first letter of this uh
whatever id it was and then it would go
into that database to find it so i had a
database telling it which database to
look for stuff that was a long time ago
and to be honest it didn't work really
well nowadays so that was a distributed
database you'd have to track which
database you put it in so what is hdfs
hadoop distributed file system hdfs is a
specially designed file system for
storing huge data sets in commodity
hardware and commodity is an interesting
term because i mentioned enterprise
versus commodity and i'll touch back
upon that it has two core components
name node and data node name node is the
master
daemon there's only one active name node
it manages the data nodes and stores all
the metadata so it stores all the
mapping of where the data is on your
hadoop file system now the name node is
usually an enterprise machine you spend
a lot of extra money on it so you have a
very solid name known machine and so
then we have our data nodes our data
node data node data node we have three
here the data node is the slave there
can be multiple data nodes and it stores
the actual data and this is where your
commodity hardware comes in the best
definition i've heard of commodity
hardware is the cheap knockoffs this is
where you buy you can buy 10 of these
and you expect one of them not to work
because you know when they come in
they're going to break right away so
you're looking at hardware it's not as
high-end so where you might have your
main master node is your enterprise
server then your data nodes are just as
cheap as you can get them with all the
different features you need on them as
said earlier name node stores the
metadata metadata gives information
regarding the file location block size
and so on so our metadata in the hdfs is
maintained by using two files it has the
edit log and the fs image the edit log
keeps track of the recent changes made
on the hadoop file system only recent
changes are tracked here the fs image
keeps track of every change made on the
hdfs since the beginning now what
happens when the edit log file size
increases the name node fails these are
big ones so what happens we get our edit
log it just keeps so big until it's too
big or our main enterprise
computer that we spent all that money on
so it wouldn't break actually fails
because they still fail the solution we
make copies of the edit log and the fs
image files so that's pretty
straightforward you just copy them over
so you have both the most recent edits
going on and the long term image of your
file system and then we also create a
secondary name node is a node that
maintains a copies of the edit log and
the fs image it combines them both to
get an updated version of the fs image
now the secondary name node only came in
the last oh i guess two three years
where it became as part of the main
system and usually your secondary name
node is also an enterprise computer and
you'll put them on separate racks so if
you have three racks of computers you
would have maybe the first two racks
would have the name node and the second
rack would have the secondary name node
and the reason you put them on different
racks is you can have a whole rack go
down you could have somebody literally
trip over the power cable or the switch
that goes between the racks is most
common goes down well if the switch goes
down you can easily switch to the
secondary name node and while you're
getting your switch replaced and
replacing that hardware because of the
way the hdfs works it still is
completely functional so let's take a
look at the name node we have our edit
log our fs image and we have our
secondary name node and you take that it
copies the edit log over and it copies
the fs image and you can see right here
you have all the different contents on
your main name node now also on your
secondary name node and then your
secondary name node will actually take
these two your edit log and your fs
image and it will make a copy so you
have a full fs image that contains its
current it's up to date the secondary
name node creates a periodic checkpoint
of the files and then it updates the new
fs image into the name node now it used
to be this all occurred on the name node
before you had a secondary name note so
now you can use your secondary nade node
to both backup everything going on the
name node and it does that lifting in
the back where you're combining your
edit log and bringing your fs image so
it's current and then you end up with a
new edit log and a new you have your fs
image updated and you start a fresh edit
log this process of updating happens
every hour and that's how it's scheduled
you can actually change those schedules
but that is the standard is to update
every hour so let's we took a look at
the the master node and the you know the
name node and the secondary name node
let's take a look at the cluster
architecture of our hadoop file system
the hdfs cluster architecture so we have
our name node and it stores the metadata
and we have our block location so we
have our fs image plus our edit log and
then we have the backup fs image and
edit log and then we have so you have
your rack we have our switch on top
remember i was talking about the switch
that's the most common thing to go in
the rack is the switches and underneath
the rack you have your different data
nodes you have your data node one two
three four five maybe have uh 10 15 on
this rack you can stack them pretty high
nowadays uh used to be you only get
about 10 servers on there but now you
see racks that contain a lot more and
then you have multiple racks so we're
not talking about just one rack we also
have you know rack two rack three four
five six and so on until you have rack
in so if you had a hundred data nodes we
would be looking at 10 racks of 10 data
nodes each and that is literally 10
commodity server computers hardware and
we have a core switch which maintains
the network bandwidth and connects the
name node to the data nodes so just like
each rack has a switch that connects all
your nodes on the rack you now have core
switches that connect all the racks
together and these also connect into our
name node setup so now we can look up
your fs image and your edit log and pull
that information your metadata out so
we've looked at the architecture from
the name node coming down and you have
your metadata your block locations this
then sorts it out you have your core
switches which connect everything all
your different racks and then each
individual rack has their own switches
which connect all the different nodes
and to the core switches so now let's
talk about the actual data blocks what's
actually sitting on those commodity
machines and so the hadoop file system
splits massive files into small chunks
these chunks are known as data blocks
each file in the hadoop file system is
stored as a data block and we have a
nice picture here where it looks like a
lego if you ever played with the legos
as a kid it's a good example we just
stacked that data right on top of each
other but each block has to be the same
symmetry has to be the same size so that
it can track it easily and the default
size of one data block is usually 128
megabytes now you can go in and change
that this standard is pretty solid as
far as most data is concerned when we're
loading up huge amounts of data and
there's certainly reasons to change it
but 128 megabytes is pretty standard
block so why 128 megabytes if the block
size is smaller then there will be too
many data blocks along with lots of
metadata which will create overhead so
that's why you don't really want to go
smaller on these data blocks unless you
have a very certain kind of data
similarly if the block size is very
large then the processing time for each
block increases then as i pointed out
earlier each block is the same size just
like your lego blocks are all the same
but the last block can be the same size
or less so you might only be storing 100
megabytes in the last block and you can
think of this as if you had a terabyte
of data that you're storing on here it's
not going to be exactly divided into 128
megabytes we just store all of it 128
megabytes except for the last one which
could have anywhere between 1 and 128
megabytes depending on how evenly your
data is divided now let's look into how
files are stored in the hadoop file
system so we have a file a text let's
say it's 520 megabytes we have block a
so we take 128 megabytes out of the 520
and we store it in block a and then we
have block b again we're taking 128
megabytes out of our 520 storing it
there and so on block c block d and then
block e we only have eight megabytes
left so when you add up 128 plus 128
plus 128 plus 128 you only get 512 and
so the last 8 megabytes goes into its
own block the final block uses only the
remaining space for storage data node
failure and replication and this is
really where hadoop shines this is what
makes it this is why you can use it with
commodity computers this is why you can
have multiple racks and have something
go down all the data blocks are stored
in various data notes you take each
block you store it at 128 megabytes and
then we're going to put it on different
nodes so here's our block a block b
block c from our last example and we
have node 1 node 2 node 3 node 4 node 5
node 6. and so each one of these
represents a different computer it
literally splits the data up into
different machines so what happens if
node 5 crashes well that's a big deal i
mean we might not even have just note 5
you might have a whole rack go down and
if you're a company that's building your
whole business off of that you're going
to lose a lot of money so what does
happen when node 5 crashes or the first
rack goes down the data stored in node 5
will be unavailable as there is no copy
stored elsewhere in this particular
image so the hadoop file system
overcomes the issue of data node failure
by creating copies of the data this is
known as the replication method and you
can see here we have our six nodes
here's our block a but instead of
storing it just on the first machine
we're actually going to store it on the
second and fourth notes so now it's
spread across three different computers
and in this if these are on a rack one
of these is always on a different rack
so you might have two copies on the same
rack but you never have all three on the
same rack and you always have you never
have more than two copies on one node
there's no reason to have more than one
copy per node and you can see we do the
same thing with block b block c is then
also spread out across the different
machines and same with block d and
blocky node 5 crashes will the data
blocks b d and e be lost well in this
example no because we have backups of
all three of those on different machines
the blocks have their copies and the
other nodes due to which the data is not
lost even if the node 5 crashes and
again because they're also stored on
different racks even if the whole rack
goes down you are still up and live with
your hadoop file system the default
replication factor is three in total
we'll have three copies of each data
block now that can be changed for
different reasons or purposes but you
got to remember when you're looking at a
data center this is all in one huge room
these switches are connecting all these
servers so they can shuffle the data
back and forth really quick and that is
very important when you're dealing with
big data and you can see here each block
is by default replicated three times
that's the standard there is very rare
occasions to do four and there's even
fewer reasons to do two blocks i've only
seen four used once and it was because
they had two data centers and so each
data center kept two different copies
rack awareness in the hadoop file system
rack is a collection of 30 to 40 data
nodes rack awareness is a concept that
helps to decide where the replica of the
data block should be stored so here we
have rack one we have our data node one
to four remember i was saying that used
to be only put ten machines and then it
went to twenty now it's thirty to forty
so you can have a rack with 40 servers
on it then we have rack 2 and rack 3 and
we put block 1 on there replicas of
block a cannot be in the same rack and
so i'll put the replicas onto a
different rack and notice that these are
actually these two are on the same rack
but you'll never have all three stored
on the same rack in case the whole rack
goes down and replicas of block a are
created in rack two and they actually do
they do by default create the replicas
onto the same rack and that has to do
with the data exchange and maximizing
your processing time and then we have of
course our block b and it's replicated
onto rack 3 and block c which will then
replicate onto rack 1 and so on for all
of your data all the way up to block d
or whatever how much ever data you have
on there hdfs architecture so let's look
at where the architecture is a bigger
picture we looked at the name node and
we store some metadata names replicas
home foo data three so it has all your
different infra your metadata stored on
there and then we have our data nodes
and you can see our data nodes are each
on different racks with our different
machines and we have our name node and
you can see we have a heartbeat or pulse
here and a lot of times one of the
things that confuses people sometimes in
classes they talk about nodes versus
machines so you could have a data node
that's a hadoop data node and you could
also have a spark node on there sparks a
different architecture and these are
each daemons that are running on these
computers that's why you refer to them
as nodes and not just always as servers
and machines so even though i use them
interchangeable be aware that these
nodes you can even have virtual machines
if you're testing something out it
doesn't make sense to have 10 virtual
nodes on one machine and deploy it
because you might as well just run your
code on the machine and so we have our
heartbeat going on here and the
heartbeat is a signal that data nodes
continuously send to the name nodes this
signal shows the status of the data note
so there's a continual pulse going up
and saying hey i'm here i'm ready for
whatever instructions or data you want
to send me and you can see here we've
divided up into rack 1 and rack 2 and
our different data nodes and it also
have the replications we talked about
how to replicate data and replicates it
in three different locations and then we
have a client machine and the client
first requests the name node to read the
data now if you're not familiar with the
client machine the client is you the
programmer the client is you've logged
in external to this hadoop file system
and you're sending it instructions and
so the client whatever instructions or
script you're sending is first request
the name node to read the data the name
node allows a client to read the
requested data from the data notes the
data is read from the data nodes and
sent to the client and so you can see
here that basically the the name node
connects the client up and says here
here's a data stream and now you have
the query that you sent out returning
the data you asked for and then of
course it goes and finishes it and says
oh metadata operations and it goes in
there and finalizes your request the
other thing the name node does is you're
sending your information because the
client sends the information in there is
your block operations so your block
operations are performs creation of data
so you're going to create new files and
folders you're going to delete the
folders and also it covers the
replication of the folders which goes on
in the background and so we can see here
that we have a nice full picture you can
see where the client machine comes in it
cues the metadata the metadata goes into
it stores a metadata and then it goes
into block operations and maybe you're
sending the data to the hidoo file
system maybe you're querying maybe
you're asking it to delete if you're
sending data in there it then does a
replication on there it goes back so you
have your data client which is writing
the data into the data node and of
course replicating it and that's all
part of the block operations and so
let's talk a little bit about read
mechanisms in the hadoop file system the
hadoop file system read mechanism we
have our hadoop file system client
that's you on your computer and the
client jvm on the client node so we have
our client jvm or the java virtual
machine that is going through and then
your client node and we're zooming in on
the read mechanism so we're looking at
this picture here as you can guess your
client is reading the data and i also
have another client down here writing
data we're going to look a little closer
at that and so we have our name node up
here we have our racks of your data
nodes and your racks of computers down
here and so our client the first thing
it does is it opens a connection up with
the distributed file system to the hdfs
and it goes hey can i get the block
locations and so it goes by using the
rpc remote procedure call it gets those
locations and the name node first checks
if the client is authorized to access
the requested file and if yes it then
provides a block location and a token to
the client which is showing to the slave
for authentication so here's the name
node it tells a client hey here's the
token the client's going to come in and
get this information from you and it
tells the client oh hey here's where the
information is so this is what is
telling your script you sent to query
your data whether you're writing your
script in one of the many setups that
you have available through the hadoop
file system or a connection through your
code and so you have your client machine
at this point then reads so your fs data
input stream comes through and you have
and you can see right here we did one
and two which is verify who you are and
give you all the information you need
then three you're going to read it from
the input stream and then the input
stream is going to grab it from the
different nodes where it's at and it'll
supply the tokens to those machines
saying hey this client needs this data
here's a token for that we're good to go
let me have the data the client will
show the authentication token to the
data nodes for the read process to begin
so after reaching the end of the data
block the connection is closed and we
can see here where we've gone through
the different steps get block locations
we have step one you open up your
connection you get the block locations
by using the rpc then you actively go
through the fs data input stream to grab
all those different data brings it back
into the client and then once it's done
it closes down that connection and then
once the client or in this case the
programmer you know manager has gone in
and pig script you can do that there's
an actual coding in each in hadoop or
pulling data called pig or hive once you
get that data back we close the
connection delete all those randomly
huge series of tokens so they can't be
used anymore and then it's done with
that query and we'll go ahead and zoom
in just a little bit more here and let's
look at this even a little closer here's
our hadoop file system client and our
client jvm our java virtual machine on
the client node and we have the data to
be read block a block b and so we
request to read block a and b and it
goes into the name node 2 then it sends
a location in this case ip addresses of
the blocks for the dn1 and dn2 where
those blocks are stored then the client
interacts with the data nodes through
the switches and so you have here the
core switch so your client node comes in
three and it goes to the core switch and
that then goes to rack switch 1 rack
switch 2 and rack switch 3. now if
you're looking at this you'll
automatically see a point of failure in
the core switch and certainly you want a
high end switch mechanism for your core
switch you want to use enterprise
hardware for that and then when you get
to the racks that's all commodity all
your rack switches if one of those goes
down you don't care as much you just
have to get in there and swap it in and
out really quick you can see here we
have block a which is replicated three
times and so is block b and it'll pull
from there so we come in here and here
the data is read from the dn1 and dn2 as
they are the closest to each other and
so you can see here that it's not going
to read from two different racks it's
going to read from one rack whatever the
closest setup is for that query the
reason for this is if you have 10 other
queries going on you want this one to
pull all the data through one setup and
it minimizes that traffic so the
response from the data nodes to the
client that read the operation was
successful it says ah we've read the
data we're successful which is always
good we like to be successful i don't
know about you i like to be successful
so if we look at the read mechanism
let's go ahead and zoom in and look at
the write mechanism for the hadoop file
system so our hdfs write mechanism and
so when we have the hdfs write mechanism
here's our client machine this is again
the programmer on their in computer and
it's going through the client java
machine or java virtual machine the jvm
this is all occurring on the client node
somebody's office or maybe it's on the
local server for the office so we have
our name node we have data nodes and we
have the distributed file system so the
client first executes create file on the
distributed file system says hey i'm
going to create this file over here then
it goes through the rpc call just like
our read did the client first executes
create file in the distributed file
system then the dfs interacts with the
name node to create a file name node
then provides a location to write the
data and so here we have our hdfs client
and the fs data output stream so this
time instead of the data going to the
client it's coming from the client and
so here the client writes the data
through the fs data output stream keep
in mind that this output stream the
client could be a streaming code it
could be i mean i always refer to the
client as just being this computer that
your programmer is writing on it could
be you have your sql server there where
your data is that's current with all
your current sales and it's archiving
all that information through a scoop one
of the tools in the hadoop file system
it could be streaming data it could be a
connection to the stock servers and
you're pulling stock data down from
those servers at a regular time and
that's all controlled you can actually
set that code up to be controlled in
many of the different features in the
hadoop file system and some of the
different resources you have that sit on
top of it so here the client writes the
data through the fs data output stream
and the fs data output stream as you can
see goes into right packet so it divides
it up into packets 128 megabytes and the
data is written and the slave further
replicates it so here's our data coming
in and then if you remember correctly
that's part of the fs data setup is it
tells it where to replicate it out but
the data node itself is like oh hey okay
i've got the data coming in and it's
also given the tokens of where to send
the replications to and then
acknowledgement is sent after the
required replicas are made so then that
goes back up saying hey successful i've
written data made three replications on
this as far as our you know going
through the pipeline of the data nodes
and then that goes back and says after
the data is written the client performs
the close method so the client's done it
says okay i'm done here's the end of the
data we're finished and after the date
is written the client performs a close
method and we can see here just a quick
reshape we go in there just like we did
with the read we create the connection
this creates a name node which lets it
know what's going on step two step three
that also includes the tokens and
everything and then we go into step
three where we're now writing through
the fs data output stream and that sorts
it out into uh whatever data node it's
gonna go to and which also tells it how
to replicate it so that data node then
sends it to other data nodes so we have
a replication and of course you finalize
it and close everything up marks it
complete to the name node and it deletes
all those magical tokens in the
background so that they can't be reused
and we can go ahead and just do this
with an example the same setups and
whether you're doing a read or write
they're very similar as we come in here
from our client and our name node and
you can see right here we actually
depicting these as the actual rack and
the switch is going on and so as the
data comes in you have your request like
we saw earlier it sends the location of
the data nodes and this actually turns
your your ip addresses your dynamic node
connections they come back to your
client your hdfs client and at that
point with the tokens it then goes into
the core switch and the core switch says
hey here it goes the client interacts
with the data nodes through the switches
and you can see here where you're
writing in block a replication of block
a and a second replication of block a on
the second server so blocking gets
replicated on the second server and the
third server at this point you now have
three replications of block a and it
comes back and says it acknowledges it
says hey we're done and that goes back
into your hadoop file system to the
client who says okay we're done and
finally the
success written to the name node and it
just closes everything down a quick
recap of the hadoop file system and the
advantages and so the first one is
probably one of the all of these are
huge one you have multiple data copies
are available so it's very fault
tolerant
whole racks can go down switches can go
down even your main name node can go
down if you have a secondary name node
something we didn't talk too much about
is how scalable it is because it uses
distributed storage you run into their
oh my gosh i'm out of space or i need to
do some heavier processing let me just
add another rack of computers so you can
scale it up very quickly it's a linear
scalability where it used to be if you
bought a server you would have to pay a
lot of money to get that the craig
computer remember the big craig
computers coming out the craig computer
runs 2 million a year just the
maintenance to liquid cool it that's
very expensive compared to just adding
more racks of computer and extending
your data center so it's very cost
effective since commodity hardware is
used we're talking cheap knockoff
computers you still need your high-end
enterprise for the name node but the
rest of them literally it is a tenth of
the cost of storing data on more
traditional high-end computers and then
the data is secure so it has a very
high-end data security and provides data
security for your data so all theory and
no play doesn't make for much fun so
let's go ahead and show you what it
looks like as far as some of the
dimensions when you're getting into
polling data or putting data into the
hadoop file system and you can see here
i have oracle virtual machine
manager i have a couple different things
loaded on there cloudera is one of them
so we should probably explain some of
these things if you're new to virtual
machines the oracle virtualbox allows
you to spin up a machine as if it is a
separate computer so in this case this
is running i believe centos linux and it
creates like a box on my computer so the
centos is running on my machine well i'm
running my windows 10 this happens to be
a windows 10 computer and then
underneath here i can actually go under
let me just open up the general might be
hard to see there and you can see i can
actually go down to system processor i
happen to be on an eight core it has 16
dedicated threads registers are 16 cpus
but eight cores and i've only designated
this for one cpu so it's only going to
use one of my dedicated threads on my
computer and this the oracle virtual
machine is open source you can see right
here we're on the oracle
www.oracle.com i usually just do a
search for downloading virtualbox if you
search for virtualbox all one word it
will come up with this page and then you
can download it for whatever operating
system you're working with there
certainly are a number of different
options and let me go and point those
out if you're setting this up as a for
demoing for yourself the first thing to
note for doing a virtual box and doing a
cloudera or horton setup on that virtual
box for doing the hadoop system to try
it out you need a minimum of 12
gigabytes it cannot be a windows 10 home
edition because you'll have problems
with your virtual setup and sometimes
you have to go turn on the virtual
settings so it knows it's in there so if
you're on a home setup there are other
sources there's cloudera and we'll talk
a little bit about clardera here in just
a second but they have the cloudera
online live we can go try the cloudera
setup i've never used it but cloudera is
a pretty good company cloudera and
hortonworks are two of the common ones
out there i will actually be running a
cloudera hadoop cluster on on our demo
here so you have oracle virtual machine
you also have the option of doing it on
different vmware that's another one like
virtual machine this is more of a paid
service there is a free setup for just
doing it for yourself which will work
fine for this and then in the cloudera
like again they have the new online
setup where you can go in there to the
online and for cloudera you want to go
underneath the cloudera quick start if
you type in a search for cloudera quick
start it'll bring you to this website
and then you can select your platform in
this case i did virtualbox there's
vmware we just talked about docker
docker is a very high-end virtual setup
unless you already know it you really
don't want to mess with it then your kvm
is if you're on a linux computer that
sets up multiple systems on that
computer so the two you really want to
use are usually the virtual box or do an
online setup and you can see here with
the download if you're going into the
horton version it's called hortonworks
and they call it sandbox so you'll see
the term hortonworks sandbox and these
are all test demos you're not going to
deploy a single node hadoop systems that
would just be kind of ridiculous and
defeat the whole purpose of having a
horton or having a hadoop system if it's
only installed on one computer in a
virtual node so a lot of different
options if you're not on a professional
windows version or you don't have at
least 12 gigabytes ram to run this
you'll want to try and see if you can
find an online version and of course
simplylearn has our own labs if you sign
up for our classes we set you up i don't
know what it is now but last time i was
in there was a five node uh setup so you
can get around and see what's going on
whether you're studying for the admin
side or for the programming side in
script writing and if i go into my
oracle virtual box and i go under my
cloudera and i start this up and each
one has their own flavors horton uses
just a login so you log everything in
through
a local host through your internet
explorer or i might use chrome cloudera
actually opens up a full interface so
you actually are in that setup and you
can see when i uh started it let me go
back here once i downloaded this this is
a big download by the way i had to
import the appliance in virtualbox uh
the first time i ran it it takes a long
time to configure the setup and the
second time it comes up pretty quick and
with the cloudera quickstart again this
is a pretend single node it opens up and
you'll see that it actually has firefox
here so here's my web browser i don't
have to go to local host i'm actually
already in the quick start for cloudera
and if we come down here you can see
getting started i have some information
analyze your data manage your cluster
your general information on there and
what i always want to start to do is to
go ahead and open up a terminal window
so we'll open up a terminal widen this a
little bit let me just maximize this out
here so you can see so we are now in a
virtual machine this virtual machine is
centos linux so i'm on a linux computer
on my windows computer and so when i'm
on this terminal window this is your
basic terminal if i do list you'll see
documents eclipse these are the
different things that are installed with
the quick start guide on the linux
system so this is a linux computer and
then hadoop is running on here so now i
have hadoop single node so it has both
the name node and the data node and
everything squished together in one
virtual machine we can then do let's do
hdfs telling it that it's a hadoop file
system dfs minus ls now notice the ls is
the same i have ls for list and ls for
list and i click on here it'll take you
just a second reading the hadoop file
system and it comes up with nothing so a
quick recap let's go back over this
three different environments i have this
one out here let's just put this in a
bright red so you can actually see it i
have this environment out here which is
my slides i have this environment here
or i did a list that's looking at the
files on the linuxcentos computer and
then we have this system here which is
looking at the files on the hadoop file
system so three completely separate
environments and then we connect them
and so right now we have i have whatever
files i have my personal files and the
of course we're also looking at the
screen
for my windows 10 and then we're looking
at the screen here uh here's our list
there let's look at the files and this
is the screen for centos linux and then
this is looking at the files right here
for the hadoop file system so three
completely separate files this one here
which is the linux is running in a
virtual box so this is a virtual box i'm
using one core to run it or one cpu and
everything in there is it has its own
file system you can see we have our
desktop and documents and whatever in
there and then you can see here we right
now have no files in our hadoop file
system and this hadoop file system
currently is stored on the linux machine
but it could be stored across 10 linux
machines 20 100. this could be stored
across in petabytes i mean it could be
really huge or it could just be in this
case just a demo where we're putting it
on just one computer and then once we're
in here let me just see real quick if i
can go under view zoom in view zoom in
and this is just a standard browser so i
could use any like the control plus and
stuff like that to zoom in and this is
very common to be in a browser window
with the hadoop file system so right now
i'm in a linux and i'm going to do oh
let's just create a file we'll go file
my new file and i'm going to use vi and
this is a vi editor just a basic editor
and we go ahead and type something in
here
one two three four maybe it's columns 44
66 77. of course i do file system just
like your regular computer can also so
in our vi editor you hit your colon i
actually work with a lot of different
other editors and we'll write quit vi so
let's take a look and see what happened
here i'm in my linux system i type in ls
for list and we should see my new file
and sure enough we do over here there it
is let me just highlight that my new
file and if i then go into the hadoop
system hdfs dfs minus ls for list we
still show nothing it's still empty so
what i can simply do is i can go hdfs
dfs
minus put and we're going to put my
new file and this is just going to move
it from the linux system because i'm in
this file folder into the hadoop file
system and now if we go in and we type
in our list for a new file system you
will see in here that i now have just
the one file on there which is my new
file and very similar to linux we can do
cat and the cat command simply
evokes reading the file so hdfs dfs
minus cat and i had to look it up
remember cloudera the the format is
going to be a user uh then of course the
path location and the file name and in
here when we did the list here's our
list so you can see it lists our file
here and we realize that this is under
uh user cloudera and so i can now go
user cloudera my new file and the minus
cat and we'll be able to read the file
in here and you can see right here this
is the file that was in the linux system
is now copied into the cloudera system
and it's one three four five that i
entered in there and if we go back to
the linux and do list you'll still see
it in here my new file and we can also
do something like this in our hdfs
minus mv i will do my new file and we're
going to change it to my new new file
and if we do that underneath our hadoop
file system the minus mv will rename it
so if i go back here to our hadoop file
system ls you'll now see instead of my
new file it has my new new file coming
up and there it is my new new files
we've renamed it we can also go in here
and
delete this so i can now come in here so
in our hdfs dfs we can also do a remove
and this will remove the file and so if
we come in here we run this we'll see
that when i come back and do the list
the file is gone and now we just have
another empty
folder with our hadoop file system and
just like any file system we can take
this and we can go ahead and make
directory create a new directory so mk
for make directory we'll call this my
dir so we're going to make a directory
in my dir it'll take it just a second
and of course if we do
the list command you'll see that we now
have uh the directory in there give it
just a second there it comes mydr and
just like we did before i can go in here
and we're going to put the file and if
you remember correctly from our files in
the
setup i called it my new file so this is
coming from the linux system and we're
going to put that into my dir that's the
target in my hadoop setup and so if i
hit enter on there i can now do
the hadoop list and that's not going to
show the file because remember i put it
in a sub folder so if i should do the
kajuk just this will show my directory
and i can do list and then i can do my
dur for my directory and you'll see
underneath the my directory in the
hadoop file system it now has my new
file put in there and with any good
operating system we need a minus help so
just like you can type in help in your
linux you can now come in here and type
in hdfs help and it shows you a lot of
the commands in there underneath the
hadoop file system most of them should
be very similar to the linux on here and
we can also do something like this a
hadoop version and the hadoop version
shows up that we're in hadoop 2.60
cdh is it we're cloudera 5 and compiled
by jenkins and it has a date and all the
different information on our hadoop file
system so this is some basics in the
terminal window let me go ahead and
close this out because if you're going
to play with this you should really come
in here let me just maximize the cloud
data it opens up in a browser window and
so once we're in here again this is a
browser window which you could access
might look like any access for a hadoop
file system one of the fun things to do
when you're first starting is to go
under hue you'll see it up here at the
top has cloudera hue hadoop your hbase
your impala your spark these are
standard installs now and hue is
basically an overview of the file system
and so come up here and you can see
where you can do queries as far as if
you have a hbase or a hive
the hive database we go over here to the
top where it says file browser and if we
go under file browser now this is a
hadoop file system we're looking at and
once we open up the file browser you can
now see there's my directory which we
created and if i click on my directory
there's my new file which is in here and
if i click on my new file it actually
opens it up and you can see from our
hadoop file system this is in the hadoop
file system the file that we created so
we covered the terminal window you can
see here's a terminal window up here it
might be if you were in a web browser
it'll look a little different because it
actually opens up as a web browser
terminal window and we've looked a
little bit at hue which is one of the
most basic components of hadoop one of
the original components for going
through and looking at your data and
your databases of course now they're up
to the hue four it's gone through a
number of changes and you can see
there's a lot of different choices in
here for other different tools in the
hadoop file system and i'll go ahead and
just close out of this and one of the
cool things with the virtual
box i can either save the machine state
send the shutdown signal or power off
the machine i'll go and just power off
the machine completely now suppose you
have a library that has a collection of
huge number of books on each floor and
you want to count the total number of
books present on each floor what would
be your approach you could say i will do
it myself but then don't you think that
will take a lot of time and that's
obviously not an efficient way of
counting the number of books in this
huge collection on every floor by
yourself now there could be a different
approach or an alternative to that you
could think of asking three of your
friends or three of your colleagues and
you could then say if each friend could
count the books on every floor then
obviously that would make your work
faster and easier to count the books on
every floor now this is what we mean by
parallel processing so when you say
parallel processing in technical terms
you are talking about using multiple
machines and each machine would be
contributing its ram and cpu cores for
processing and your data would be
processed on multiple machines at the
same time now this type of process
involves parallel processing in our case
or in our library example where you
would have person 1 who would be taking
care of books on floor 1 and counting
them person 2 on floor 2 then you have
someone on floor 3 and someone on floor
4. so every individual would be counting
the books on every floor in parallel so
that reduces the time consumed for this
activity and then there should be some
mechanism where all these counts from
every floor can be aggregated so what is
each person doing here each person is
mapping the data of of a particular
floor or you can say each person is
doing a kind of activity or basically a
task on every floor and the task is
counting the books on every floor now
then you could have some aggregation
mechanism that could basically reduce or
summarize this total count and in terms
of map reduce we would say that's the
work of reducer so when you talk about
hadoop mapreduce it processes data on
different node machines now this is the
whole concept of hadoop framework right
that you not only have your data stored
across machines but you would also want
to process the data locally so instead
of transferring the data from one
machine to other machine or bringing all
the data together into some central
processing unit and then processing it
you would rather have the data processed
on the machines wherever that is stored
so we know in case of hadoop cluster we
would have our data stored on multiple
data nodes on their multiple disks and
that is the data which needs to be
processed but the requirement is that we
want to process this data as fast as
possible and that could be achieved by
using parallel processing now in case of
mapreduce we basically have the first
phase which is your mapping phase so in
case of mapreduce programming model you
basically have two phases one is mapping
and one is reducing now who takes care
of things in mapping phase it is a
mapper class and this mapper class has
the function which is provided by the
developer which takes care of these
individual map tasks which will work on
multiple nodes in parallel your reducer
class belongs to the reducing phase so a
reducing phase basically uses a reducer
class which provides a function that
will aggregate and reduce the output of
different data nodes to generate the
final output now that's how your
mapreduce works using mapping and then
obviously reducing now you could have
some other kind of jobs which are map
only jobs wherein there is no reducing
required but we are not talking about
those we are talking about our
requirement where we would want to
process the data using mapping and
reducing especially when data is huge
when data is stored across multiple
machines and you would want to process
the data in parallel so when you talk
about mapreduce you could say it's a
programming model you could say
internally it's a processing engine of
hadoop that allows you to process and
compute huge volumes of data and when we
say huge volumes of data we can talk
about terabytes we can talk about
petabytes exabytes and that amount of
data which needs to be processed on a
huge cluster we could also use mapreduce
programming model and run a mapreduce
algorithm in a local mode but what does
that mean if you would go for a local
mode it basically means it would do all
the mapping and reducing on the same
node using the processing capacity that
is ram and cpu cores on the same machine
which is not really efficient in fact we
would want to have our map reduce work
on multiple nodes which would obviously
have mapping phase followed by a
reducing phase and intermittently there
would be data generated there would be
different other phases which help this
whole processing so when you talk about
hadoop map reduce you are mainly talking
about two main components or two main
phases that is mapping and reducing
mapping taking care of map tasks
reducing taking care of reduced tasks so
you would have your data which would be
stored on multiple machines now when we
talk about data data could be in
different formats we could or the
developer could specify what is the
format which needs to be used to
understand the data which is coming in
that data then goes through the mapping
internally there would be some shuffling
sorting and then reducing which gives
you your final output so the way we
access data from sdfs or the way our
data is getting stored on sdfs we have
our input data which would have one or
multiple files in one or multiple
directories and your final output is
also stored on sdfs to be accessed to be
looked into and to see if the processing
was done correctly so this is how it
looks so you have the input data which
would then be worked upon by multiple
map tasks now how many map tasks that
basically depends on the file that
depends on the input format so normally
we know that in a hadoop cluster you
would have a file which is broken down
into blocks depending on its size so the
default block size is 128 mb which can
then still be customized based on your
average size of data which is getting
stored on the cluster so if i have
really huge files which are getting
stored on the cluster i would certainly
set a higher block size so that my every
file does not have huge number of blocks
creating a load on name notes ram
because that's tracking the number of
elements in your cluster or number of
objects in your cluster so depending on
your file size your file would be split
into multiple chunks and for every chunk
we would have a map task running now
what is this map task doing that is
specified within the mapper class so
within the mapper class you have the
mapper function which basically says
what each of these map tasks has to do
on each of the chunks which has to be
processed this data intermittently is
written to sdfs where it is sorted and
shuffled and then you have internal
phases such as partitioner which decides
how many reduced tasks would be used or
what data goes to which reducer you
could also have a combiner phase which
is like a mini reducer doing the same
reduce operation before it reaches
reduce then you have your reducing phase
which is taken care by a reducer class
and internally the reducer function
provided by developer which would have
reduced task running on the data which
comes as an output from map tasks
finally your output is then generated
which is stored on sdfs now in case of
hadoop it accepts data in different
formats your data could be in compressed
format your data could be in part k your
data could be in afro text csv psv
binary format and all of these formats
are supported however remember if you
are talking about data being compressed
then you have to also look into what
kind of splitability the compression
mechanism supports otherwise when
mapreduce processing happens it would
take the complete file as one chunk to
be processed so sdfs accepts input data
in different formats this data is stored
in sdfs and that is basically our input
which is then passing through the
mapping phase now what is mapping phase
doing as i said it reads record by
record depending on the input format it
reads the data so we have multiple map
tasks running on multiple chunks once
this data is being read this is broken
down into individual elements and when i
say individual element i could say this
is my list of key value pairs so your
records based on some kind of delimiter
or without delimiter are broken down
into individual elements and thus your
mac creates key value pairs now these
key value pairs are not my final output
these key value pairs are basically a
list of elements which will then be
subjected to further processing so you
would have internally shuffling and
sorting of data so that all the relevant
key value pairs are brought together
which basically benefits the processing
and then you have your reducing which
aggregates the key value pairs into set
of smaller tuples or tuples as you would
say finally your output is getting
stored in the
designated directory as a list of
aggregated key value pairs which gives
you your output so when we talk about
mapreduce one of the key factors here is
the parallel processing which it can
offer so we know that we have a data is
getting stored across multiple data
nodes and you would have huge volume of
data which is split and randomly
distributed across data nodes and this
is the data which needs to be processed
and the best way would be parallel
processing so you could have your data
getting stored on multiple data nodes or
multiple slave nodes in each slave node
would have again one or multiple disks
to process this data basically we have
to go for parallel processing approach
we have to use the mapreduce now let's
look at the mapreduce workflow to
understand how it works so basically you
have your input data stored on sdfs now
this is the data which needs to be
processed it is stored in input files
and the processing which you want can be
done on one single file or it can be
done on a directory which has multiple
files you could also later have multiple
outputs merged which we achieve by using
something called as chaining of mappers
so here you have your data getting
stored on sdfs now input format is
basically something to define the input
specification and how the input files
will be split so there are various input
formats now we can search for that so we
can go to google and we can basically
search for
hadoop map reduce
yahoo tutorial this is one of the good
links and if i look into this link i can
search for different input formats and
output formats so let's search for input
format so when we talk about input
format you basically have something to
define how input files are split so
input files are split up and read based
on what input format is specified so
this is a class that provides following
functionality it selects the files or
other objects that should be used for
input it defines the input split that
break a file into tasks provides a
factory for record reader objects that
read the file so there are different
formats if you look in the table here
and you can see that the text input
format is the default format which reads
lines of a text file and each line is
considered as a record here the key is
the byte offset of the line and the
value is the line content it says you
can have key value input format which
passes lines into key value pairs
everything up to the first tab character
is the key and the remainder is the line
you could also have sequence file input
format which basically works on binary
format so you have input format and in
the same way you can also search for
output format which takes care of how
the data is handled after the processing
is done so the key value pairs provided
to this output collector are then
written to output files the way they are
written is governed by output format so
it functions pretty much like input
format as described in earlier right so
we could set what is the output format
to be followed and again you have text
output sequence file output format null
output format and so on so these are
different classes which take care of how
your data is handled when it is being
read for processing or how is the data
being written when the processing is
done so based on the input format the
file is broken down into splits and this
logically represents the data to be
processed by individual map tasks or you
could say individual mapper functions so
you could have one or multiple splits
which need to be processed depending on
the file size depending on what
properties have been set now once this
is done you have your input splits which
are subjected to mapping phase
internally you have a record reader
which communicates with the input split
and converts the data into key value
pairs suitable to be read by mapper and
what is mapper doing it is basically
working on these key value pairs the map
task giving you an intermittent output
which would then be forwarded for
further processing now once that is done
and we have these key value pairs which
is being worked upon my map your map
tasks as a part of your mapper function
are generating your key value pairs
which are your intermediate outputs to
be processed further now you could have
as i said a combiner face or internally
a mini reducer phase now combiner does
not have its own class so combiner
basically uses the same class as the
reducer class provided by the developer
and its main work is to do the reducing
or its main work is to do some kind of
mini aggregation on the key value pairs
which were generated by map so once the
data is coming in from the combiner then
we have internally a partitioner phase
which decides how outputs from combiners
are sent to the reducers or you could
also say that even if i did not have a
combiner partitioner would decide based
on the keys and values based on the type
of keys how many reducers would be
required or how many reduced tasks would
be required to work on your output which
was generated by map task now once
partitioner has decided that then your
data would be then sorted and shuffled
which is then fed into the reducer so
when you talk about your reducer it
would basically have one or multiple
reduced tasks now that depends on what
or what partitioner decided or
determined for your data to be processed
it can also depend on the configuration
properties which have been set to decide
how many radio stars should be used now
internally all this data is obviously
going through sorting and shuffling so
that your reducing or aggregation
becomes an easier task once we have this
done we basically have the reducer which
is the code for the reducer is provided
by the developer and all the
intermediate data has then to be
aggregated to give you a final output
which would then be stored on sdfs and
who does this you have an internal
record writer which writes these output
key value pairs from reducer to the
output files now this is how your
mapreduce works wherein the final output
data can be not only stored but then
read or access from sdfs or even used as
an input for further mapreduce kind of
processing so this is how it overall
looks so you basically have your data
stored on sdfs based on input format you
have the splits then you have record
reader which gives your data to the
mapping phase which is then taken care
by your mapper function and mapper
function basically means one or multiple
map tasks working on your chunks of data
you could have a combiner phase which is
optional which is not mandatory then you
have a partitioner phase which decides
on how many reduced tasks or how many
reducers would be used to work on your
data internally there is sorting and
shuffling of data happening and then
basically based on your output format
your record reader will write the output
to sdfs directory now internally you
could also remember that data is being
processed locally so you would have the
output of each task which is being
worked upon stored locally however we do
not access the data directly from data
nodes we access it from sdfs so our
output is stored on sdfs so that is your
mapreduce workflow when you talk about
mapreduce architecture now this is how
it would look so you would have
basically a edge node or a client
program or an api which intends to
process some data so it submits the job
to the job tracker or you can say
resource manager in case of hadoop yarn
framework right now before this step we
can also say that an interaction with
name node would have already happened
which would have given information of
data nodes which have the relevant data
stored then your master processor so in
hadoop version 1 we had job tracker and
then the slaves were called task
trackers in hadoop version 2 instead of
job tracker you have resource manager
and of task trackers you have node
managers so basically your resource
manager has to assign the job to the
task trackers or node managers so your
node managers as we discussed in yarn
are basically taking care of processing
which happens on every node so
internally there is all of this work
happening by resource manager node
managers and application master then you
can refer to the yarn based tutorial to
understand more about that so here your
processing master is basically breaking
down the application into tasks what it
does internally is once your application
is submitted your application to be run
on yarn processing framework is handled
by resource manager now forget about the
yarn part as of now i mean who does the
negotiating of resources who allocates
them how does the processing happen on
the nodes right so that's all to do with
how yarn handles the processing request
so you have your data which is stored in
sdfs broken down into one or multiple
splits depending on the input format
which has been specified by the
developer your input splits are to be
worked upon by your one or multiple map
tasks which will be running within the
container on the nodes basically you
have the resources which are being
utilized so for each map task you would
have some amount of ram which will be
utilized and then further the same data
which has to go through reducing phase
that is your reduced task will also be
utilizing some ram and cpu cores now
internally you have these functions
which take care of deciding on number of
reducers doing a mini reduce and
basically reading and processing the
data from multiple data nodes now this
is how your mapreduce programming model
makes parallel processing work or
processes your data which is stored
across multiple machines finally you
have your output which is getting stored
on sdfs
so let's have a quick demo on mapreduce
and see how it works on a hadoop cluster
now we have discussed briefly about
mapreduce which contains mainly two
phases that is your mapping phase and
you're reducing phase and mapping phase
is taken care by your mapper function
and your reducing phase is taken care by
your reducer function now in between we
also have sorting and shuffling and then
you have other phases which is
partitioner and combiner and we will
discuss about all those in detail in
later sessions but let's have a quick
demo on how we can run a mapreduce which
is already existing as a package jar
file within your apache hadoop cluster
or even in your cloudera cluster now we
can build our own mapreduce programs we
can package them as jar transfer them to
the cluster and then run it on a hadoop
cluster on yarn or we could be using
already provided default program so
let's see where they are now these are
my two machines which i have brought up
and basically this would have my apache
hadoop cluster running now we can just
do a simple start hyphen all dot sh now
i know that this script is deprecated
and it says instead use start dfs and
start yarn but then it will still take
care of starting off my cluster on these
two nodes where i would have one single
name node two data nodes one secondary
name node one resource manager and two
node managers now if you have any doubt
in how this cluster came up you can
always look at the previous sessions
where we had a walkthrough in setting up
a cluster on apache and then you could
also have your cluster running using
less than 3gb of your total machine ram
and you could have apache cluster
running on your machine now once this
cluster comes up we will also have a
look at the web ui which is available
for name node and resource manager now
based on the settings what we have given
our uis will show us details of our
cluster but remember the ui is only to
browse now here my cluster has come up i
can just do a jps to look at java
related processes and that will show me
what are the processes which are running
on c1 which is your data node resource
manager node manager and name node and
on my m1 machine which is my second
machine which i have configured here i
can always do a jps and that shows me
the processes running which also means
that my cluster is up with two data
nodes with two node managers and here i
can have a look at my web ui so i can
just do a refresh and the same thing
with this one just do a refresh so i had
already opened the web pages so you can
always access the web ui
using your name notes host name and 570
port it tells me what is my cluster id
what is my blog pool id it gives you
information of what is the space usage
how many live notes you have and you can
even browse your file system so i have
put in a lot of data here i can click on
browse the file system and this
basically shows me multiple directories
and these directories have one or
multiple files which we will use for our
mapreduce example now if you see here
these are my directories which have some
sample files although these files are
very small like 8.7 kilobytes if you
look into this directory if you look
into this i have just pulled in some of
my hadoop logs and i have put it on my
sdfs these are a little bigger files and
then we also have some other data which
we can see here and this is data which
i've downloaded from web now we can
either run a mapreduce on a single file
or in a directory which contains
multiple files let's look at that before
looking at demo and map reduce also
remember mapreduce will create a output
directory and we need to have that
directory created plus we need to have
the permissions to run the mapreduce job
so by default since i'm running it using
admin id i should not have any problem
but then if you intend to run mapreduce
with a different user then obviously you
will have to ask the admin or you will
have to give the user permission to read
and write from sdfs so this is the
directory which i have created which
will contain my output once the
mapreduce job finishes and this is my
cluster file system if you look on this
ui this shows me about my yarn which is
available for taking care of any
processing it as of now shows that i
have total of 8gb memory and i have
eight v cores now that can be depending
on what configuration we have set or how
many nodes are available we can look at
nodes which are available and that shows
me i have two node managers running each
has 8 gb memory and 8 v cores now that's
not true actually but then we have not
set the configurations for node managers
and that's why it takes the default
properties that is 8 gb laminate vcos
now this is my yarn ui we can also look
at scheduler which basically shows me
the different queues if they have been
configured where you will have to run
the jobs we'll discuss about all these
in later in detail now let's go back to
our terminal and let's see where we can
find some sample applications which we
can run on the cluster so once i go to
the terminal i can well submit the
mapreduce job from any terminal now here
i know that my hadoop related
directories here and within hadoop you
have various directories we have
discussed that in binaries you have the
commands which you can run in s bin you
basically have the startup scripts and
here you also notice there is a share
directory in the end if you look in the
shared directory you would find hadoop
and within hadoop you have various sub
directories in which we will look for
map reduce now this mapreduce directory
has some sample jar files which we can
use to run a mapreduce on the cluster
similarly if you are working on a
cloudera cluster you would have to go
into opt cloudera parcel cdh slash lib
and in that you would have directories
for sdfs mapreduce or sdfs yarn where
you can still find the same jars it is
basically a package which contains your
multiple applications now how do we run
a mapreduce we can just type in hadoop
and hit enter and that shows me that i
have an option called jar which can be
used to run a jar file now at any point
of time if you would want to see what
are the different classes which are
available in a particular
jar you could always do a jar minus xvf
for example i could say jar xv f and i
could say user local hadoop share hadoop
mapreduce and then list down your jar
file so i'll say hadoop mapreduce
examples and if i do this this should
basically unpack it to show me what
classes are available within this
particular jar and it has done this it
has created a meta file and it has
created a org directory we can see that
by doing a ls and here if you look in ls
org since i ran the command from your
phone directory i can look into org
patchy hadoop examples which shows me
the classes which i have and those
classes contain which mapper or reducer
classes so it might not be just mapper
and reducer but you can always have a
look so for example i am targeting to
use word count program which does a word
count on files and gives me a list of
words and how many times they occur in a
particular file or in set of files and
this shows me that what are the classes
which belong to word count so we have a
int sum reducer so this is my reducer
class i have tokenizer mapper that is my
mapper class right and basically this is
what is used these classes are used if
you run a word count now there are many
other programs which are part of this
jar file and we can expand and see that
so i can say hadoop jar and give your
path so i'll say hadoop jar user local
hadoop share hadoop mapreduce hadoop
mapreduce examples and if i hit on enter
that will show me what are the inbuilt
classes which are already available now
these are certain things which we can
use now there are other jar files also
for example i can look at hadoop and
here we can look at the jar files which
we have in this particular path so this
is one hadoop mapreduce examples which
you can use you can always look in other
jar files like you can look for
hadoop mapreduce client job client and
then you can look at the test one so
that is also an interesting one so you
can always look into hadoop mapreduce
client job client and then you have
something ending with this so if i would
have tried this one using my hadoop jar
command so in my previous example when
we did this it was showing me all the
classes which are available and that
already has a word count now there are
other good programs which you can try
like teragen to generate dummy data
terasort to check your sorting
performance and so on and terra validate
to validate the results similarly we can
also do a hadoop jar as i said on hadoop
mapreduce i think that was client and
then we have job client and then test
star now this has a lot of other classes
which can be used or programs which can
be used for doing a stress testing or
checking your cluster status and so on
one of them interesting one is test dfs
io but let's not get into all the
details in first instance let's see how
we can run a mapreduce now if i would
want to run a mapreduce i need to give
hadoop jar and then my jar file and if i
hit on enter it would say it needs the
input and output it needs which class
you want to run so for example i would
say word count and again if i hit on
enter it tells me that you need to give
me some input and output to process and
obviously this processing will be
happening on cluster that is our yarn
processing framework unless and until
you would want to run this job in a
local mode so there is a possibility
that you can run the job in a local mode
but let's first try how it runs on the
cluster so how do we do that now here i
can do a hdfs
ls slash command to see what i have on
my sdfs now through my ui i was already
showing you that we have set of files
and directories which we can use to
process now we can take up one single
file so for example if i pick up new
data and i can look into the files here
what we have and we can basically run a
mapreduce on a single file or multiple
files so let's take this file whatever
that contains and i would like to do a
word count so that i get a list of words
and their occurrence in this file so let
me just copy this now i also need my
output to be written and that will be
written here so here if i want to run a
mapreduce i can say hadoop which we can
pull out from history so hadoop jar word
count now i need to give my input so
that will be new data and then i will
give this file which we just copied now
i am going to run the word count only on
a single file and i will basically have
my output which will be stored in this
directory the directory which i have
created already mr output so let's do
this output and this is fair enough now
you can give many other properties you
can specify how many map jobs you want
to run how many reduced jobs you want to
run do you want your output to be
compressed do you want your output to be
merged or many other properties can be
defined when you are specifying word
count and then you can pass in an
argument to pass properties from the
command line which will affect your
output now once i go ahead and submit
this this is basically running a simple
inbuilt mapreduce job on our hadoop
cluster now obviously internally it will
be looking for name node now we have
some issue here and it says the output
already exists what does that mean so it
basically means that hadoop will create
an output for you you just need to give
a name but then you don't need to create
it so let's give let's append the output
with number one and then let's go ahead
and run this so i've submitted this
command now this can also be done in
background if you would want to run
multiple jobs on your cluster at the
same time so it takes total input paths
to processes one so that is there is
only one split on which your job has to
work now it will internally try to
contact your resource manager and
basically this is done so here we can
have a look and we can see some counters
here now what i also see is for some
property which it is missing it has run
the job but it has run in a local mode
it has run in a local mode so although
we have submitted so this might be
related to my yarn settings and we can
check that so if i do a refresh when i
have run my application it has completed
it would have created an output but the
only thing is it did not interact with
your yarn it did not interact with your
resource manager we can check those
properties and here if we look into the
job it basically tells me that it went
for mapping and reducing it would have
created an output it worked on my file
but then it ran in a local mode it ran
in a local mode so mapreduce remember is
a programming model right now if you run
it on yarn you get the facilities of
running it on a cluster where yarn takes
care of resource management if you don't
run it on yarn and run it on a local
mode it will use your machines ram and
cpu cores for processing but then we can
quickly look at the output and then we
can also try running this on yarn so if
i look into my hdfs and if i look into
my output m mr output that's the
directory which was not used actually
let's look into the other directory
which is ending with one and that should
show me the output created by this
mapreduce although it ran in the local
mode it fetched an input file from usdfs
and it would have created output in hdfs
now that's my part file which is created
and if you look at part minus r minus
these zeros if you would have more than
one reducer running then you would have
multiple such files created we can look
into this what does this file contain
which should have my word count and here
i can say cat which basically shows me
what is the output created by my
mapreduce let's have a look into this so
the file which we gave for processing
has been broken down and now we have the
list of words which occur in the file
plus a count of those words so if there
is some word which is in is more then it
shows me the count so this is a list of
my words and the count for that so this
is how we run a sample mapreduce job i
will also show you how we can run it on
yeah now let's run mapreduce on yarn and
initially when we tried running a
mapreduce it did not hit yarn but it ran
in a local mode and that was because
there was a property which had to be
changed in mapreduce hyphen site file so
basically if you look into this file the
error was that i had given a property
which says
mapred.framework.name and that was not
the right property name and it was
ignored and that's why it ran in a local
mode so i changed the property to
mapreduce.framework.name
restarted my cluster and everything
should be fine now and that mapred
hyphen site file has also been copied
across the nodes now to run a mapreduce
on a hadoop cluster so that it uses yarn
and yarn takes care of resource
allocation on one or multiple machines
so i'm just changing the output here and
now i will submit this job which should
first connect to the resource manager
and if it connects to the resource
manager that means our job will be run
using yarn on the cluster rather than in
a local mode so now we have to wait for
this application to internally connect
to resource manager and once it starts
there we can always go back to the web
ui and check if our application has
reached yarn so it shows me that there
is one input part to be processed that's
my job id that's my application id which
you can even monitor status from the
command line now here the job has been
submitted so let's go back here and just
do a refresh on my yarn ui which should
show me the new application which is
submitted it tells me that it is an
accepted state application master has
already started and if you click on this
link it will also give you more details
of how many map and reduced tasks would
run so as of now it says the application
master is running it would be using this
node which is m1 we can always look into
the logs we can see that there is a one
task attempt which is being made and now
if i go back to my terminal i will see
that it is waiting to get some resources
from the cluster and once it gets the
resources it will first start with the
mapping phase where the mapper function
runs it does the map tasks one or
multiple depending on the splits so
right now we have one file and one split
so we will have just one map task
running and once the mapping phase
completes then it will get into reducing
which will finally give me my output so
we can be toggling through these
sessions so here i can just do a refresh
to see what is happening with my
application is it proceeding is it still
waiting for resource manager to allocate
some resources now just couple of
minutes back i tested this application
on yarn and we can see that my first
application completed successfully and
here we will have to give some time so
that yarn can allocate the resources now
if the resources were used by some other
application they will have to be freed
up now internally yan takes care of all
that which we will learn more detail in
yarn or you might have already followed
the yarn based session now here we will
have to just give it some more time and
let's see if my application proceeds
with the resources what yarn can
allocate to it sometimes you can also
see a slowness in what web ui shows up
and that can be related to the amount of
memory you have allocated to your nodes
now for apache we can have less amount
of memory and we can still run the
cluster and as i said the memory which
shows up here 16 gb and 16 cores is not
the true one those are the default
settings right but then my yarn should
be able to facilitate running of this
application let's just give it a couple
of seconds and then let's look into the
output here again i had to make some
changes in the settings because our
application was not getting enough
resources and then basically i restarted
my cluster now let's submit the
application again to the cluster which
first should contact the resource
manager and then basically the map and
reduce process should start so here i've
submitted an application it is
connecting to the resource manager and
then basically it will start internally
in app master that is application master
it is looking for the number of splits
which is one it's getting the
application id and it basically then
starts running the job it also gives you
a tracking url to look at the output and
now we should go back and look at our
yarn ui if our application shows up here
and we will have to give it a couple of
seconds when it can get the final status
change to running and that's where my
application will be getting resources
now if you closely notice here i have
allocated specific amount of memory that
is 1.5 gb for node manager on every node
and i have basically given two cores
each which my machines also have and my
yarn should be utilizing these resources
rather than going for default now the
application has started moving
and we can see the progress bar here
which basically will show what is
happening and if we go back to the
terminal it will show that first it went
in deciding map and reduce it goes for
map once the mapping phase completes
then the reducing phase will come into
existence and here my job has completed
so now it has basically used we can
always look at how many map and reduce
sas were run it shows me that there was
one map and one reduced task now with
the number of map tasks depends on the
number of splits and we had just one
file which is less than 128 mb so that
was one split to be processed and
reduced task is internally decided by
the reducer or depending on what kind of
property has been set in hadoop config
files now it also tells me how many
input records were read which basically
means these were the number of lines in
the file it tells me output records
which gives me the number of total words
in the file now there might be
duplicates and that which is processed
by internal combiner further processing
or forwarding that information to
reducer and basically reducer works on 3
35 records gives us a list of words and
their count now if i do a refresh here
this would obviously show my application
is completed it says succeeded you can
always click on the application to look
for more information it tells me where
it ran now we do not have a history
server running as of now otherwise we
can always access more information so
this leads to history server where all
your applications are stored but i can
click on this attempt tasks and this
will basically show me the history url
or you can always look into the logs so
this is how you can submit a sample
application which is inbuilt which is
available in the jar on your hadoop
cluster and that will utilize your
cluster to run now you could always as i
said when you are running a particular
job remember to change the output
directory and if you would not want it
to be processing is a single individual
file you could also point it to a
directory that basically means it will
have multiple files and depending on the
file sizes there would be multiple
splits and according to that multiple
map tasks will be selected so if i click
on this this would submit my second
application to the cluster which should
first connect to resource manager then
resource manager has to start an
application master now here we are
targeting 10 splits now you have to
sometimes give couple of seconds in your
machines so that the resources which
were used are internally already freed
up so that your cluster can pick it up
and then your yarn can take care of
resources so right now my application is
an undefined status but then as soon as
my yarn provides it the resources we
will have the application running on our
yarn cluster so it has already started
if you see it is going further then it
would launch 10 map tasks and it would
the number of reduced stars would be
decided on either the way your data is
or based on the properties which have
been set at your cluster level let's
just do a quick refresh here on my yarn
ui to show me the progress also take
care that when you are submitting your
application you need to have the output
directory mentioned however do not
create it hadoop will create that for
you now this is how you run a mapreduce
without specifying properties but then
you can specify more properties you can
look into what are the things which can
be changed for your mapper and reducer
or basically having a combiner class
which can do a mini reducing and all
those things can be done so we will
learn about that in the later sessions
now in this tutorial we will have some
demos on running a mapreduce and
processing data to solve some real-time
business problems now i have set up some
code in eclipse which can be either
tested on your windows machine by
running it in a local mode or packaging
your code in jar transferring it to your
cluster and then basically running it on
your cluster nodes so we'll see both of
these examples now let's assume and
let's understand about a problem say for
example we have a telecom based company
which would want to process its data say
it would want to find out the number of
subscribers and the kind of calls they
are making or for example let's imagine
a
online website or a music website where
users listen to various tracks the data
gets collected and then basically it has
to be processed so imagine you have a
company which is
hosting music online and you have users
who either are subscribers or basically
create their accounts listen to
different tracks and then basically use
these services now what if i would want
to process such data for example if i
would want to find out what is the
number of unique listeners or number of
times the track was shared with other
users or number of times the track was
listened to on the radio or in total or
even was skipped on the radio now in
that case i would want to process the
data to find out information so we will
solve this kind of problem using the
mapreduce programming model the
mapreduce approach which as i explained
earlier goes for mapping and then for
goes for reducing and in between it has
different phases that is shuffling and
sorting you have your partitioner face
you have a mini reducer which is your
combiner face although all of these
intermittent phases are taken care by
the framework itself the developer or
the person who is developing the
solution is responsible to work on the
mapper function and the reducer function
now for that we can basically be writing
our code to process this data by giving
a mapper and a reducer function data we
can look into example and say for
example let me pull out some data here
let's look in save some files i have and
for example in this case it would be
this kind of data now that magnitude
could be anything right now here i have
the data which the first column talks as
the user id or the membership id the
second is the track id you have then
your if the track was shared online the
fourth one is number of times the track
was listened to in total and the fifth
one is if a particular track was skipped
now i could have this data in huge
numbers and then i could be processing
it but we will take a simple small
example to understand how mapreduce does
this so this is a file which i have
already uploaded on the cluster and
which will be as my input file now let's
look at the code so what we would need
is for this kind of processing we would
first need to understand the data now
here the first column as i said is user
id and second one is track id which can
then be used to basically process the
data we need to write a mapper class
which would emit the track id from this
data so i have it here and let me also
open up a constant class for this which
is here so as i mentioned we will have
to write a mapper class which would emit
track id from the data and user ids with
some intermediate key value pairs now
that is what your mapping phase does it
works on the input splits it basically
does the mapping and it gives you a list
of data elements which are nothing but
your intermediate key value pairs to
explain it in a simple way i would say
just let's work on this data sequence so
let's create a constant class as shown
here so this is my package now i create
a class called last fm constants and
then i am here declaring some variables
with some constant values for each of
the field which i just showed in the
file you have user id you have track id
you have is scrobbled or shared radio
and is skipped now these are my constant
which will be used while i process then
we will have to work on a mapper class
which could or which would immediate uh
emit intermediate key value pairs that
is your track id and user id now how do
we do that so here is an example so we
basically would have a mapper class as
it's seen here this is my mapper class
which will be used to process or do the
mapping phase now here we have the class
name which is unique listener and unique
listeners mapper which extends the
mapper class that means i would have to
import the relevant packages for my code
which i have done on the top here then i
have variables that is track id user id
which use in try table so hadoop has its
own data types say intricable long
writable boolean writable which are
similar to what you have in java as int
boolean long but these data types which
are used by hadoop are basically an
implementation of writable and writable
comparable interfaces so those are two
interfaces which are then responsible
for these classes which we are using as
data types in our code here we start our
map task which would then consider key
which is an object value as in text and
then you have your data types that is
inclinable text and object we are also
handling exception and then what we do
is we work on the file so we would split
it based on the delimiter now in my case
the delimiter is a pipe then what we do
is we set for the track id using our
constants that is what we have seen here
which is for your user id track id and
so on and we do the same thing we for
our user id we look into the values and
then we basically emit out just the
track id and user id that would be my
intermediate key value pairs now here i
am also using a counter named invalid
record count now that is mainly to count
if there are any invalid records which
do not exist in the file in an expected
format now you know we don't do this
in case of invalid records if we don't
do this what would happen our if we had
invalid records in our file then our
program might fail and that's the reason
i'm using counters.invalidrecord.com
and i'm going to use it for my mapper
once we have our mapper written which
basically will look into the file and
emit the track id and user id then i
would write my reducer class now this is
how my reducer class looks where i am
saying public static class unique
listener reducer which extends reducer
class and then the data types which it
would need so entry table for the values
which it works on so our reduce task
will work on track id and this reducer
class is to aggregate the results so we
cannot directly use some reducer as the
records we are getting are not unique
the records might be duplicates it might
be the same user with the same
membership id listening to a different
track or sharing it and we cannot be
just using a generic reducer so here we
work on the reducer and this is how my
code would look so what my reducer does
it basically would help me in solving
the problem such as basically
aggregating and counting the number of
tracks which were shared or listened to
or overall the number of tracks and then
you have your tracks which were skipped
one of the main task of your reducer
class is on working on the intermediate
data which is created by your mapper or
you can say multiple map tasks which
would be running on multiple splits on
one or multiple nodes and your reducers
work is to aggregate the result based on
the keys here we are using set to
eliminate duplicate user ids now once we
have written our reducer class which
basically works on the user id set it
eliminates the duplicate user ids and
then it basically gives me a count of
the track ids in an aggregated way to
solve my use case once i've done that i
also need a driver class which basically
tells about my overall code so here we
are having a job configuration where i
say my name of the job could be unique
listeners per track i'm setting the jar
by class calling it as unique listeners
that's my class i'm mentioning my mapper
i'm mentioning my reducer now if you
notice i'm not using a combiner class
for this use case we would not need that
so combiner class is a mini reducer
which basically helps in reducing the
data or aggregating the data before it
reaches the reducer class i am also
talking about the key which would be
using in writable and then the value
which would also be interruptable as all
my values are in numeric if i had my key
in something else or if i had names
instead of user id then i could have
used text class i also specify what
would be my input and output path which
will be specified as an argument and
then basically i am printing out number
of invalid records so this is my
mapreduce program to work on solving our
business use case also notice i am using
the relevant packages which are being
used in the code and for these packages
and for my this code to compile we need
to make sure that we have added the
right dependencies now you could have
created your code with pom and using
maven or based on the classes what you
are using you can always add the jars
the relevant jars to the build path so
here we can look at the build path what
i have and we can see what jars have
used so the main ones are your commons i
have hadoop core now you can ignore hive
or json gson which i have here those are
for different applications so the main
is common cli and hadoop core depending
on what you are using within your
application so that has to be added to
your build path also we are having the
java 1.8 now if i wanted to run this
application or test it on my local
machine i could have also set up the
configurations however it is preferred
to run the code on a yarn based cluster
if you would want to try it on windows
then you can always go to the run
configuration you can basically specify
your application which you would want to
run you can then say what is your class
name you can be passing in your
arguments here and in your environment
you can specify hadoop as a local ip
however i suggest package it as jar and
run it on a cluster so what you could do
is you could select your class now my
unique listeners dot java class is also
getting the constants from last fm
constants so both of them belong to the
same project and i'm using that here
for my mapper and for my reducer so in
mapper i refer to last fm constants
where i have given constant values for
all of these fields once you have your
code ready you can always package it as
jar by saying export and select the jar
option in java click on next and then
you can select your project and give it
a name so i have i'm pointing into a
different jar file but i can do a browse
i've already packaged it as jar and you
can see i have a jar here so i can
select this i can say save and that
would be my jar if i'm making some
changes it will anyways overwrite it
once you have your jar ready what you
need to do is place it on your cluster
now i have already done that i have a
cluster here let me bring it up and what
we can do is you can use different ways
you can have a apache cluster you could
have a cloud error cluster wherein you
need to place so let's get into this now
here i'm using a already set up lab
environment you can be doing an ftp you
can upload your code using hue i have
done an ftp from my local machine and
uploaded it to the cluster i could click
on web console which basically gives me
a console to try out things you could as
i said you need the jar and then you
need to push your jar to your cluster
let me login here and once i'm logged in
i am on a edge node which allows me to
connect to a cluster which is clouderas
based and now i can check on my hdfs
path in my user directory i should have
multiple files and directories and in
one of the directories i have placed in
this file so we can look in here which
is sample mr in and that's my directory
where i have the input so i can look in
sample mr in and the same file which i
showed in the beginning i have uploaded
it here which is the listeners file
which we can even check so i can say
listeners dot txt and i can even do a
cat so this is the file which is already
existing here which has the content
which we spoke about although not huge
content but it is more than enough for
us to test our code and obviously we can
upload huge data and then have the same
mapreduce program helping us in
answering our questions we also need the
jar file and the jar file should be here
which i have uploaded so i need to run
this now to run your mapreduce you can
say hadoop jar you will give your jar
name which is this one now i need to
give my package name with my class name
so i'll say org example hadoop codes and
then i need to give my class which is
unique listeners now if i hit enter here
it will ask me to give an input and
output as my code says to pass in the
arguments so we will pass in the
arguments here so i will say my
directory where i have the data now i
could be picking up one file or multiple
files to process this so i will say just
one file which is
here uh and that's my
file which is
sample mr in that is what i want to use
so i'll say
sample mr in and i need to give my file
name so i can say listeners.txt
and then i can give an output which will
get created when you run your mapreduce
so i can say sample mr and then i can
say output 1 and this is the directory
which will get created which will have
my output now you can run this job in
this way you can even run it in a local
mode by specifying arguments on the
command line you can give different kind
of properties if you want your mapreduce
jobs output to be in a compressed format
you can do all that so let's run this
and this should connect to the resource
manager the job is processing one input
file it will start with the mapping
phase first now it looks that the job
has failed due to some reason let's have
a look i just looked into the job and i
realized why it failed the main reason
was i was trying to write an output in
the directory to which i don't have
access i need to have access to write
the output in a directory to which my
user id has permissions for this we will
have to submit the job again with the
right path where it can write the output
so we can do this this is my class i
need input so i'll say and then we can
say sample mr in and i'm looking for
listeners dot txt and i need to give an
output which should be in this path and
then we can say sample mr output 1 and
then submit the job now once i have
submitted the job as i said it has one
input part to process it is working on
one split because the file which we are
trying to work on is smaller than the
block size it goes for the mapping phase
and then it goes for reducing and it's
done so if you carefully look at the map
reduce output here it says the number of
outputs it had to process was just four
so every line by default is considered
as a record and we had totally four
lines the output is basically working on
again giving you four records right
because we are doing a split based on
the delimiter then this would become an
input to combiner if we had a combiner
class but we don't use that so the
output from your map goes to the reduce
which will basically work on the input
records and create output records now we
can have a look at this the output of
this job which is stored in hdfs and i
can either be giving a complete path or
i can just mention the directory which i
used and that should by default take me
to the directory which should have my
output now based on how many reduced
tasks were used you will have number of
part files which show up here so we have
one map and one reduced task that could
have controlled or that would have been
controlled by giving things on the
command line so here i have run it in a
yarn mode where yarn was used to
allocate resources for my applications
and we can always check that on the yarn
ui or also by going to say cloudera
manager if that is available if you're
not using cloudera's cluster then you
can always in apache cluster go to your
yarn and you can go into the ui wherever
your resource manager is running so that
is one option or if you have a cloudera
cluster you can look in applications
which will show all the applications
which were recently run so this was the
thing which failed earlier because of
permissions and this is the one which
succeeded now i have a job id which can
always take me to the yarn ui the
history server where i see how many map
and jobs were run and for further
information you can always go and look
into the map and reduce tasks so this
was a map task which ran within a
container which was allocated by your
yarn and we can also look on the node
and logs what really happened you can
also look into the reduced task you can
also look at the counters which we were
seeing on the command line on how many
map and reduced stars how many bytes
were read what was the garbage
collection time how much cpu time was
spent in milliseconds and you get all
the counters here you can specifically
be looking at counters for map or for
reduce so your yarn ui helps you to look
into for more information now if i go
back to my console and i have the output
file i can basically look into it by
selecting the output file and i can do a
cat which basically will show me what is
my output so this is my mapreduce and
basically what it has done has it has
aggregated and pulled out the
information for your different listeners
based on the data what we have provided
let's look at one more example of using
mapreduce programming model to solve a
real-time business case or a problem now
the problem in hand is that we have some
data collected from a telecom giant and
basically we have some sample data here
which lists the list of subscribers
which are using the services now if i
look into the file i have call data
records which basically gives me
information about the data collected by
a telecom company so this telecom
company keeps records of its subscribers
and it calls this particular file as
call data records now what does this
call data records contain it basically
has a from phone number as the first
field it has the two phone number that
is call being made to a particular
number then we have the call start time
following a timestamp you have a call
end time and then we have finally if
this call was a distance call or what we
call as std call now what we need to do
is we need to use our knowledge of
mapreduce we need to use the mapreduce
programming model and we need to come up
with a code to find out all the phone
numbers for example who were making more
than 60 minutes of std calls now here
the flag 1 basically means it was an std
call and 0 means it was a local call how
do we do that using mapreduce so this is
again a problem where you would want to
count through the data and you would
want to aggregate the values to come up
with result so let's look at a sample
code for this one so here i have my
eclipse and again like a previous
example we are having a class which
declares some constants for the fields
so you have phone number with zero phone
number with one call start time call n
time and an std flag so these are the
constants which i would be using in my
code and here is my main class which
will use the mapreduce basically to
solve this problem now i'm importing the
packages and as i explained earlier
these packages are mainly to make sure
that we can use the classes in our code
in the right way so here now the order
of your driver class or your mapper and
reducer does not matter right the first
thing what we need is we need a mapper
which will do the map task so here i am
creating a mapper which is tokenizer
mapper and that extends your mapper
class it accepts the data types that is
object text and long writable as
explained earlier these are your data
types which are hadoop specific and data
types like entry table long writable
boolean writable and many others depend
on the writable and writable comparable
interfaces now here we start with taking
up our phone number we basically also
take duration in minutes so these are
the variables and i'm using the
appropriate data type for those then i
start writing my map task now what does
my map task do it basically works on the
string which we have and it breaks it
into individual elements based on a
delimiter once that is done then we are
also checking if that particular string
which we are looking for has a std flag
because we would want to find out how
many customers or how many of them were
making phone calls which were more than
60 minutes and if these calls were std
calls then basically i work on the phone
number and i set it using the cdr
constants for which we have already
created a class using the phone number
call end time call start time and i also
compute or calculate the long duration
because we need to find out the calls
which were more than 60 minutes finally
we extract the phone numbers and the
duration of the call made by a
particular phone number so this would be
my mapper giving an intermediate output
which would then have to be sorted and
shuffled and then handed over to reducer
what does my reducer do it uses the
right data types it basically starts
with is sum as 0 it will look into all
the keys and values and wherever it
would find keys which are repeating and
the duration is more than 60 it would
give me an aggregated result this is my
reducer and finally we have a driver as
i explained earlier which has job
configuration your mapper reducer and
also we are using just as an example a
combiner class which does not have a
class of its own but it is basically
using the same reducer class once your
code is ready check if it compiles check
if you have all the dependencies met and
package it as jar transfer it to the
cluster and run it with or on top of
yarn so what we can do is i have already
moved it here and we can look into this
machine i already have my jar file which
basically also needs a input which i
have already pushed to my cluster so we
can look in for the file which should be
existing in sample mr in directory which
is within my user and my name directory
and i have the call data records which
basically shows the data which i was
showing in the notepad file now i can
say hadoop jar and point it to my jar
which is std subscribers jar we need to
use the package so i'll say ord example
hadoop codes that's my package and my
class name my class name is
std subscribers so i will say std
subscribers
dot and then you need to give your input
so we will say sample m r in and i will
given a particular file which is call
data records dot txt and then we can
point it to an output directory which
will get created automatically so i will
say output 2 and that should have my
result and like we ran our first example
now i am again running it on one simple
file you can imagine this as you can
replace one single file with a directory
which has multiple files where it might
be the telecom company was already
collecting data for couple of months and
they would like to analyze this and you
can run it in this way so once this is
done we have our output which can be
seen by going into the directory saying
sample m r out port 2 and again this
would have gone for one single reducer
so we can look at whatever we gave as an
output so it was sample mr output 2 and
that is
my directory so since this is a
directory my cat command does not work
on it you need to give the file so the
command is by giving the specific file
not by giving the directory so it is cat
sample mr output to slash part minus r
and then you can give five zeros and
that should be my out which would give
me an information of which were the
users or which were the phone numbers
which made calls greater than 16 minutes
and if these calls were std calls and
what was the duration of the call so
this is how you can use mapreduce
programming model to solve your
real-time business cases always remember
you have to code and create your mapper
and reducer function and rest will be
done by the framework hadoop version 1
or mapreduce version one well that's
outdated now and nobody is using hadoop
version one but it would be good to
understand what was in hadoop version
one and what were the limitations of
hadoop version one which brought in the
thought for the future processing layer
that is yarn now when we talk about
hadoop we already know that hadoop is a
framework and hadoop has two layers one
is your storage layer that is your sdfs
hadoop distributed file system which
allows for distributed storage and
processing which allows fault tolerance
by inbuilt replication and which
basically allows you to store huge
amount of data across multiple commodity
machines when we talk about processing
we know that mapreduce is the oldest and
the most mature processing programming
model which basically takes care of your
data processing on your distributed file
system so in hadoop version 1 mapreduce
performed both data processing and
resource management and that's how it
was problematic in mapreduce we had
basically when we talked about the
processing layer we had the master which
was called job tracker and then you had
the slaves which were the task records
so your job tracker was taking care of
allocating resources it was performing
scheduling and even monitoring the jobs
it basically was taking care of
assigning map and reduced tasks to the
jobs running on task trackers and task
trackers which were co-located with data
nodes were responsible for processing
the jobs so task trackers were the
slaves for the processing layer which
reported their progress to the job
tracker so this is what was happening in
hadoop version 1. now when we talk about
hadoop version 1 we would have say
client machines or an api or an
application which basically submits the
job to the master that is job tracker
now obviously we cannot forget that
there would already be an involvement
from name node which basically tells
which are the machines or which are the
data nodes where the data is already
stored now once the job submission
happens to the job tracker job tracker
being the master demon for taking care
of your processing request and also
resource management job scheduling would
then be interacting with your multiple
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines so each machine would
have a task tracker running and that
task tracker which is a processing slave
would be co-located with the data nodes
now we know that in case of hadoop you
have the concept of moving the
processing to wherever the data is
stored rather than moving the data to
the processing layer so we would have
task trackers which would be running on
multiple machines and these task
trackers would be responsible for
handling the tasks what are these tasks
these are the application which is
broken down into smaller tasks which
would work on the data which is
respectively stored on that particular
node now these were your slave demons
right so your job tracker was not only
tracking the resources so your task
trackers were sending heartbeats they
were sending in packets and information
to the job tracker which would then be
knowing how many resources and when we
talk about resources we are talking
about the cpu cores we are talking about
the ram which would be available on
every node so task trackers would be
sending in their resource information to
job tracker and your job tracker would
be already aware of what amount of
resources are available on a particular
node how loaded a particular node is
what kind of work could be given to the
task tracker so job tracker was taking
care of resource management and it was
also breaking the application into tasks
and doing the job scheduling part assign
different tasks to these slave demons
that is your task trackers so job
tracker was eventually overburdened
right because it was managing jobs it
was tracking the resources from multiple
task trackers and basically it was
taking care of job scheduling so job
tracker would be overburdened and in a
case if job tracker would fail then it
would affect the overall processing so
if the master is skilled if the master
demon dies then the processing cannot
proceed now this was one of the
limitations of hadoop version one so
when you talk about scalability that is
the capability to scale due to a single
job tracker scalability would be hitting
a bottleneck you cannot have a cluster
size of more than 4000 nodes and cannot
run more than 40 000 concurrent tasks
now that's just a number we could always
look into the individual resources which
each machine was having and then we can
come up with an appropriate number
however with a single job tracker there
was no horizontal scalability for the
processing layer because we had single
processing master now when we talk about
availability job tracker as i mentioned
would be a single point of failure now
any failure kills all the queued and
running jobs and jobs would have to be
resubmitted now why would we want that
in a distributed platform in a cluster
which has hundreds and thousands of
machines we would want a processing
layer which can handle huge amount of
processing which could be more scalable
which could be more available and could
handle different kind of workloads when
it comes to resource utilization now if
you would have a predefined number of
map and reduce slots for each task
tracker you would have issues which
would relate to resource utilization and
that again is putting a burden on the
master which is tracking these resources
which has to assign jobs which can run
on multiple machines in parallel so
limitations in running non-map reduce
applications now that was one more
limitation of hadoop version 1 and
mapreduce that the only kind of
processing you could do is mapreduce and
map reduce programming model although it
is good it is oldest it has matured over
a period of time but then it is very
rigid you will have to go for mapping
and reducing approach and that was the
only kind of processing which could be
done in hadoop version one so when it
comes to doing a real time analysis or
doing ad hoc query or doing a graph
based processing or massive parallel
processing there were limitations
because that could not be done in hadoop
version 1 which was having mapreduce
version 1 as the processing component
now that brings us to the need for yarn
so yarn it stands for yet another
resource negotiator so as i mentioned
before yarn in hadoop version one well
you could have applications which could
be written in different programming
languages but then the only kind of
processing which was possible was
mapreduce we had the storage layer we
had the processing but then kind of
limited processing which could be done
now this was one thing which brought in
a thought that why shouldn't we have a
processing layer which can handle
different kind of workloads as i
mentioned might be graph processing
might be real-time processing might be
massive parallel processing or any other
kind of processing which would be a
requirement of an organization now
designed to run map-reduce jobs only and
having issues in scalability resource
utilization job tracking etc that led to
the need of something what we call as
yarn now from hadoop version 2 onwards
we have the two main layers have changed
a little bit you have the storage layer
which is intact that is your hdfs and
then you have the processing layer which
is called yarn yet another resource
negotiator now we will understand how
yarn works but then yarn is taking care
of your processing layer it does support
mapreduce so mapreduce processing can
still be done but then now you can have
a support to other processing frameworks
yarn can be used to solve the issues
which hadoop version 1 was posing
something like resource management
something like different kind of
workload processing something like
scalability resource utilization all
that is now taken care by yarn now when
we talk about yarn we can have now a
cluster size of more than 10 000 nodes
and can run more than 100 000 concurrent
tasks that's just to take care of your
scalability when you talk about
compatibility applications which were
developed for hadoop version 1 which
were primarily map reduce kind of
processing can run on yarn without any
disruption or availability issues when
you talk about resource utilization
there is a mechanism which takes care of
dynamic allocation of cluster resources
and this basically improves the resource
utilization when we talk about
multi-tenancy so basically now the
cluster can handle different kind of
workloads so you can use open source and
proprietary data access engines you can
perform real-time analysis you can be
doing graph processing you can be doing
ad hoc querying and this can be
supported for multiple workloads which
can run in parallel so this is what yarn
offers so what is yan as i mentioned
yarn stands for yet another resource
negotiator so it is the cluster resource
management layer for your apache hadoop
ecosystem which takes care of scheduling
jobs and assigning resources now just
imagine when you would want to run a
particular application you would
basically be telling the cluster that i
would want resources to run my
applications that application might be a
mapreduce application that might be a
hive query which is triggering a
mapreduce that might be a big script
which is triggering a mapreduce that
could be hive with days as an execution
engine that could be a spark application
that could be a graph processing
application in any of these cases you
would still you as in in sense client or
basically an api or the application
would be requesting for resources yan
would take care of that so yan would
provide the desired resources now when
we talk about resources we are mainly
talking about the network related
resources we are talking about the cpu
cores or as in terms of yarn we say
virtual cpu course we will talk about
ram that is in gb or mb or in terabytes
which would be offered from multiple
machines and yarn would take care of
this so with yarn you could basically
handle different workloads now these are
some of the workloads which are showing
up here you have the traditional
mapreduce which is
mainly batch oriented you could have an
interactive execution engine something
as space you could have hbase which is a
column oriented or a four dimensional
database and that would be not only
storing data on sdfs but would also need
some kind of processing you could have
streaming functionalities which would be
from storm or kafka or spark you could
have graph processing you could have
in-memory processing such as spark and
its components and you could have many
others so these are different frameworks
which could now run and which can run on
top of yarn so how does the aunt do that
now when we talk about
yarn this is how a overall yarn
architecture looks so at one end you
have the client now client could be
basically your edge node where you have
some applications which are running it
could be an api which would want to
interact with your cluster it could be a
user triggered application which wants
to run some jobs which are doing some
processing so this client would submit a
job request now what is resource manager
doing resource manager is the master of
your processing layer in hadoop version
1 we basically had job tracker and then
we had task trackers which were running
on individual nodes so your task
trackers were sending your heart beats
to the job tracker your task trackers
were sending it their resource
information and job tracker was the one
which was tracking the resources and it
was doing the job scheduling and that's
how as i mentioned earlier job tracker
was overburdened so job tracker is now
replaced by your resource manager which
is the master for your processing layer
your task trackers are replaced by node
managers which would be then running on
every node and we have a temporary demon
which you see here in blue and that's
your app master so this is what we
mentioned when we say yet another
resource negotiator so appmaster would
be existing in a hadoop version 2. now
when we talk about your resource manager
resource manager is the master for
processing layer so it would already be
receiving heartbeats and you can say
resource information from multiple node
managers which would be running on one
or multiple machines and these node
managers are not only updating their
status but they are also giving an
information of the amount of resources
they have now when we talk about
resources we should understand that if
i'm talking about this node manager then
this has been allocated some amount of
ram for processing and some amount of
cpu cores and that is just a portion of
what the complete node has so if my node
has say imagine my node has around 100
gb ram and i have saved 60 cores all of
that cannot be allocated to node manager
so node manager is just one of the
components of hadoop eco system it is
the slave of the processing layer so we
could say keeping in all the aspects
such as different services which are
running might be cloudera or hortonworks
related services running system
processes running on a particular node
some portion of this would be assigned
to node manager for processing so we
could say for example say 60 gb ram per
node and say 40 cpu cores so this is
what is allocated for the node manager
on every machine similarly we would have
here similarly we would have here so
node manager is constantly giving an
update to resource manager about the
resources what it has probably there
might be some other applications running
and node manager is already occupied so
it gives an update now we also have a
concept of containers which is basically
we will we will talk about which is
about these resources being broken down
into smaller parts so resource manager
is keeping a track of the resources
which every node manager has and it is
also responsible for taking care of the
job request how do these things happen
now as we see here resource manager at a
higher level you can always say this is
the processing master which does
everything but in reality it is not the
resource manager which is doing it but
it has internally different services or
components which are helping it to do
what it is supposed to do now let's look
further now as i mentioned your resource
manager has these
services or components which basically
helps it to do the things it is
basically a an architecture where
multiple components are working together
to achieve what yarn allows so resource
manager has mainly two components that
is your scheduler and applications
manager and these are at high level four
main components here so we talk about
resource manager which is the processing
master you have node managers which are
the processing slaves which are running
on every nodes you have the concept of
container and you have the concept of
application master how do all these
things work now let's look at yarn
components so resource manager basically
has two main components you can say
which assist resource manager in doing
what it is capable of so you have
scheduler and applications manager now
there is when you talk about
resources there is always a requirement
for the applications which need to run
on cluster of resources so your
application which has to run which was
submitted by client needs resources and
these resources are coming in from
multiple machines wherever the relevant
data is stored and a node manager
is running so we always know that node
manager is co-located with data nodes
now what does the scheduler do so we
have different kind of schedulers here
we have basically a capacity scheduler
we have a fair scheduler or we could
have a fifo scheduler so there are
different schedulers which take care of
resource allocation so your scheduler is
responsible for allocating resources to
various running applications now imagine
a particular environment where you have
different teams or different departments
which are working on the same cluster so
we would call the cluster as a
multi-tenant cluster and on the
multi-tenant cluster you would have
different applications which would want
to run simultaneously accessing the
resources of the cluster how is that
managed so there has to be some
component which has a concept of pooling
or queuing so that different departments
or different users can get dedicated
resources or can share resources on the
cluster so scheduler is responsible for
allocating resources to various running
applications now it does not perform
monitoring or tracking of the status of
applications that's not the part of
scheduler it does not offer any
guarantee about restarting the failed
tasks due to hardware or network or any
other failures scheduler is mainly
responsible for allocating resources now
as i mentioned you could have different
kind of schedulers you could have a fifo
scheduler which was mainly in older
version of hadoop which stands for first
in first out you could have a fair
scheduler which basically means
multiple applications could be running
in the cluster and they would have a
fair share of the resources you could
have a capacity scheduler which would
basically have dedicated or fixed amount
of resources across the cluster now
whichever scheduler is being used
scheduler is mainly responsible for
allocating resources then it's your
applications manager now this is
responsible for accepting job
submissions now as i said at higher
level we could always say resource
manager state doing everything it is
allocating the resources it is
negotiating the resources it is also
taking care of listening to the clients
and taking care of job submissions but
who is doing it in real it is these
components so you have applications
manager which is responsible for
accepting job submissions it negotiates
the first container for executing the
application specific application master
it provides the service for restarting
the application master now how does this
work how do these things happen in
coordination now as i said your node
manager is the slave process which would
be running on every machine slave is
tracking the resources what it has it is
tracking the processes it is taking care
of running the jobs and basically it is
tracking each container resource
utilization so let's understand what is
this container so normally when you talk
about a application request which comes
from a client so let's say this is my
client which is requesting or which is
coming up with an application which
needs to run on the cluster now this
application could be anything it first
contacts your master that's your
resource manager which is the master for
your processing layer now as i mentioned
and as we already know that your name
node which is the master of your cluster
has the metadata in its ram which is
aware of the data being split into
blocks the blocks when stored on
multiple machines and other information
so obviously there was a interaction
with the master which has given this
information of the relevant nodes where
the data exists now for the processing
need your client basically the
application which needs to run on the
cluster so your resource manager which
basically has the scheduler which takes
care of allocating resources and
resource manager has mainly these two
components which are helping it to do
its work now for a particular
application which might be needing data
from multiple machines now we know that
we would have multiple machines where we
would have node manager running we would
have a data node running and data nodes
are responsible for storing the data on
disk so your resource manager has to
negotiate the resources now when i say
negotiating the resources it could
basically ask each of these node
managers for some amount of resources
for example it would be saying can i
have 1 gb of ram and one cpu core from
you because there is some data residing
on your machine and that needs to be
processed as part of my application can
i again have one gb and one cpu core
from you and this is again because some
relevant data is stored and this request
which resource manager makes of holding
the resources of total resources which
the node manager has your resource
manager is negotiating or is asking for
resources from the processing slave so
this request of holding resources can be
considered as a container so resource
manager now we know it is not actually
the resource manager but it is the
application manager which is negotiating
the resources so it negotiates the
resources which
are called container so this request of
holding resource can be considered as a
container so basically a container can
be of different sizes we will talk about
that so resource manager negotiates the
resources with node manager now node
manager which is already giving an
update of the resources it has what
amount of resources it holds how much
busy it is can basically approve or deny
this request so node manager would
basically approve in saying yes i could
hold these resources i could give you
this container of this particular size
now once the container has been approved
or allocated or you can say granted by
your node manager resource manager now
knows that resources to process the
application are available and guaranteed
by the node manager so resource manager
starts a temporary demon called
appmaster so this is a piece of code
which would also be running in one of
the containers it would be running in
one of the containers which would then
take care of execution of tasks in other
containers so your application master is
per application so if i would have 10
different applications coming in from
the client then we would have 10 app
masters one app master being responsible
for per application now what does this
app master do it basically is a piece of
code which is responsible for execution
of the application so your app master
would run in one of the containers and
then it would use the other containers
which node manager is guaranteed that it
will give when the request application
request comes to it and using these
containers the app master will run the
processing tasks within these designated
resources so it is mainly the
responsibility of application master to
get the execution done and then
communicate it to the master so resource
manager is tracking the resources it is
negotiating the resources and once the
resources have been negotiated it
basically gives the control to
application master application master is
then running within one of the
containers on one of the nodes and using
the other containers to take care of
execution this is how it looks so
basically container as i said is a
collection of resources like cpu memory
your disk which would be used or which
already has the data and network so your
node manager is basically looking into
the request from application master and
it basically is granting this request or
basically is allocating these containers
now again we could have different sizing
of the containers let's take an example
here so as i mentioned from the total
resources which are available for a
particular node some portion of
resources are allocated to the node
manager so let's imagine this is my node
where node manager as a processing slave
is running so from the total resources
which the node has some portion of ram
and cpu cores is basically allocated to
the node manager so i could say out of
total 100 gb ram we can say around
60 cores which the particular node has
so this is my ram which the node has and
these are the cpu cores which the node
has some portion of it right so we can
say might be
70 or 60 percent of the total resources
so we could say around 60 gb ram and
then we could say around 40 v cores have
been allocated to node manager so there
are these settings which are given in
the yarn hyphen site file now apart from
this allocation that is 60 gb ram and
for tv cores we also have some
properties which say what will be the
container sizes so for example we could
have a small container setting which
could say my every container could have
2gb ram and say one virtual cpu core so
this is my smallest container so based
on the total resources
you could calculate how many such small
containers could be running so if i say
2gb ram then i could have around 30
containers but then i am talking about
one virtual cpu core so totally i could
have around 30
small containers which could be running
in parallel on a particular node and as
of that calculation you would say 10 cpu
cores are not being utilized you could
have a bigger container size which could
say i would go for 2 cpu cores and 3gb
ram
so 3gb ram and 2 cpu cores so that would
give me around 20 containers of bigger
size so this is the container sizing
which is again defined in the yarn
hyphen site file so what we know is on a
particular node which has this kind of
allocation either we could have 30 small
containers running or we could have 20
big containers running and same would
apply to multiple nodes so node manager
based on the request from application
master can allocate these containers now
remember it is within this one of these
containers you would have an application
master running and other containers
could be used for your processing
requirement application master which is
per application it is the one which uses
these resources it basically manages or
uses these resources for individual
application so remember if we have 10
applications running on yarn then it
would be 10 application masters one
responsible for each application your
application master is the one which also
interacts with the scheduler to
basically know how much amount of
resources could be allocated for one
application and your application master
is the one which uses these resources
but it can never negotiate
for more resources to node manager
application master cannot do that
application master has to always go back
to resource manager if it needs more
resources so it is always the resource
manager an internally resource manager
component that is application manager
which negotiates the resources at any
point of time due to some node failures
or due to any other requirements if
application master needs
more resources on one or multiple nodes
it will always be contacting the
resource manager internally the
applications manager for more containers
now this is how it looks so your client
submits the job request to resource
manager now we know that resource
manager internally has scheduler an
applications manager node managers which
are running on multiple machines are the
ones which are tracking their resources
giving this information to the source
manager so that resource manager or i
would say its component applications
manager could request resources from
multiple node managers when i say
request resources it is these containers
so your resource manager basically will
request for the resources on one or
multiple nodes node manager is the one
which approves these containers and once
the container has been approved your
resource manager triggers a piece of
code that is application master which
obviously needs some resources so it
would run in one of the containers and
will use other containers to do the
execution so your client submits an
application to resource manager resource
manager allocates a container or i would
say this is at a high level right
resource manager is negotiating the
resources and internally who is
negotiating the resources it is your
applications manager who is granting
this request it is node manager and
that's how we can say resource manager
locates a container application master
basically contacts the related node
manager because it needs to use the
containers node manager is the one which
launches the container or basically
gives those resources within which an
application can run an application
master itself will then accommodate
itself in one of the containers and then
use other containers for the processing
and it is within these containers the
actual execution happens now that could
be a map task that could be a reduced
task that could be a spark executor
taking care of spark tasks and many
other processing
so before we look into the demo on how
yarn works i would suggest looking into
one of the blogs from cloudera so you
can just look for yarn untangling and
this is really a good blog which
basically talks about the overall
functionality which i explained just now
so as we mentioned here so you basically
have the master process you have the
worker process which basically takes
care of your processing your resource
manager being the master and node
manager being the slave this also talks
about the resources which each node
manager has
it talks about the yarn configuration
file where you give all these properties
it basically shows you node manager
which reports the amount of resources it
has to resource manager now remember if
worker node shows 18 to 8 cpu cores and
128 gb ram and if your node manager says
64 v cores and ram 128 gb then that's
not the total capacity of your node it
is some portion of your node which is
allocated to node manager now once your
node manager reports that your resource
manager is requesting for containers
based on the application what is a
container it is basically a logical name
given to a combination of vcore and
ram
it is within this container where you
would have basically the process running
so once your application starts and once
node manager is guaranteed these
containers your application or your
resource manager has basically already
started an application master within the
container and what does that application
master do it uses the other containers
where the tasks would run so this is a
very good blog which you can refer to
and this also talks about mapreduce if
you have already followed the mapreduce
tutorials in past then you would know
about the different kind of tasks that
is map and reduce and these map and
reduce tasks could be running within the
container in one or multiple as i said
it could be map task it could be reduced
task it could be a spark based task
which would be running within the
container now once the task finishes
basically that resources can be freed up
so the container is released and the
resources are given back to yarn so that
it can take care of further processing
if you'll further look in this blog you
can also look into the part two of it
where you talk mainly about
configuration settings you can always
look into this which talks about why and
how much resources are allocated to the
node manager it basically talks about
your operating system overhead it talks
about other services it talks about
clouded our hotend works related
services running and other processes
which might be running and based on that
some portion of ram and cpu cores would
be allocated to node manager so that's
how it would be done in the yarn hyphen
site file and this basically shows you
what is the total amount of memory and
cpu cores which is allocated to node
manager then within every machine where
you have a node manager running on every
machine in the yarn hyphen site file you
would have such properties which would
say what is the minimum container size
what is the maximum container size in
terms of ram what is the minimum for cpu
cores what is the maximum for cpu cores
and what is the incremental size in
where ram and cpu cores can increment so
these are some of the properties which
define how containers are allocated for
your application request so have a look
at this and this could be a good
information which talks about different
properties now you can look further
which talks about scheduling if you look
in this particular blog which also talks
about scheduling where it talks about
scheduling in yarn which talks about
fair scheduler or you basically having
different cues in which allocations can
be done you also have different ways in
which queues can be managed and
different schedulers can be used so you
can always look at this series of blog
you can also be checking for yarn
schedulers and then search for
hadoop
definitive
guide and that could give you some
information on how it looks when you
look for hadoop definitive guide so if
you look into this book which talks
about the different resources as i
mentioned so you could have a fee for
scheduler that is first in first out
which basically means if a long running
application is submitted to the cluster
all other small running applications
will have to wait there is no other way
but that would not be a preferred option
if you look in fifo scheduler if you
look for capacity scheduler it basically
means that you could have different
queues created and those queues would
have resources allocated so then you
could have a production queue where
production jobs are running in a
particular queue which has fixed amount
of resources allocated you could have a
development queue where development jobs
are running and both of them are running
in parallel you could then also look
into fair scheduler which basically
means again multiple applications could
be running on the cluster however they
would have a fair share so when i say
fair share in brief what it means is
if i had given 50 percent of resources
to a queue for production and 50 percent
of resources for a queue of development
and if both of them are running in
parallel then they would have access to
50 percent of cluster resources however
if one of the queue is unutilized then
second queue can utilize all cluster
resources so look into the fair
scheduling part it also shows you about
how allocations can be given and you can
learn more about schedulers and how cues
can be used for managing multiple
applications now we will spend some time
in looking into few ways or few quick
ways in interacting with yarn in the
form of a demo to understand and learn
on how yarn works we can look into a
particular cluster now here we have a
designated cluster which can be used you
could be using the similar kind of
commands on your apache based cluster or
a cloudera quick start vm if you already
have or if you have a cloud error or a
hortonworks cluster running there are
different ways in which we can interact
with yarn and we can look at the
information one is basically looking
into the admin console so if i would
look into cloudera manager which is
basically an admin console for a cloud
errors distribution of hadoop similarly
you could have a hortonworks cluster
than access to the admin console so if
you have even read access for your
cluster and if you have the admin
console then you can search for yarn as
a service which is running you can click
on yarn as a service and that gives you
different tabs so you have the instances
which tells basically what are the
different roles for your yarn service
running so we have here multiple node
managers now some of them show in stop
status but that's nothing to worry so we
have three and six node managers we have
resource manager which is one but then
that can also be in a high availability
where you can have active and standby
you also have a job history server which
would show you the applications once
they have completed now you can look at
the yarn configurations and as i was
explaining you can always look for the
properties which are related to the
allocation so you can here search for
course and that should show you the
properties which talk about the
allocations so here if we see we can be
looking for
yarn app mapreduce application master
resource cpu course what is the cpu
course allocated for map reduce map task
reduce task you can be looking at yarn
node manager resource cpu course which
basically says every node manager on
every node would be allocated with six
cpu cores and the container sizing is
with minimum allocation of one cpu core
and the maximum could be two cpu cores
similarly you could also be searching
for memory allocation and here you could
then scroll down to see what kind of
memory allocation has been done for the
node manager so if we look further it
should give me information of node
manager which basically says here that
the container minimum allocation is 2 gb
the maximum is 3 gb and we can look at
node manager which has been given 25 gb
per node so it's a combination of this
memory and cpu cores which is the total
amount of resources which have been
allocated to every node manager now we
can always look into applications tab
that would show us different
applications which are submitted on yarn
for example right now we see there is a
spark application running which is
basically a user who is using spark
shell which has triggered a application
on spark and that is running on yarn you
can look at different applications
workload information you can always do a
search based on the number of days how
many applications have run and so on you
can always go to the web ui and you can
be searching for the resource manager
web ui and if you have access to that it
will give you overall information of
your cluster so this basically says that
here we have 100 gb memory allocated so
that could be say 25 gb per node and if
we have four node managers running and
we have 24 cores which is six cores per
node if we look further here into nodes
i could get more information so this
tells me that i have four node managers
running and node managers basically have
25 gb memory allocated per node and six
scores out of which some portion is
being utilized we can always look at the
scheduler here which can give us
information what kind of scheduler has
been allocated so we basically see that
there is just a root cue and within root
you have default queue and you have
basically user skew based on different
users we can always scroll here and that
can give us information if it is a fair
share so here we see that my root dot
default has 50 of resources and the
other queue also has 50 percent of
resources which also gives me an idea
that a fair scheduler is being used we
can always confirm that if we are using
a fair scheduler or a capacity scheduler
which takes care of a location so search
for scheduler
and that should give you some
understanding of what kind of scheduler
is being used and what are the
allocations given for that particular
scheduler so here we have fair scheduler
it shows me you have under root you have
the root q which has been given hundred
percent capacity and then you have
within that default which also takes
hundred percent so this is how you can
understand about yarn by looking into
the yarn web ui you can be looking into
the configurations you can look at
applications you can always look at
different actions now since we do not
have admin access the only information
we have is to download the client
configuration we can always look at the
history server which can give us
information of all the applications
which have successfully completed now
this is from your yarn ui what i can
also do is i can be going into hue which
is the web interface and your web
interface also basically allows you to
look into the jobs so you can click on
hue web ui and if you have access to
that it should show up or you should
have a way to get to your hue which is a
graphical user interface mainly comes
with your cloud era you can also
configure that with apache hortonworks
has a different way of giving you the
web ui access you can click and get into
hue and that is also one way where you
can look at yarn you can look at the
jobs which are running if there are some
issues with it and these these are your
web interfaces so either you look from
yarn web ui or here in hue you have
something called as job browser which
can also give you information of your
different applications which might have
run so here i can just remove this one
which will basically give me a list of
all the different kind of jobs or
workflows which were run so either it
was a spark based application or it was
a map reduce or it was coming from hive
so here i have list of all the
applications and it says this was a
mapreduce this was a spark something was
killed something was successful and this
was basically a probably a hive query
which triggered a mapreduce job you can
click on the application and that tells
you how many tasks were run for it so
there was a map task which ran for it
you can get into the metadata
information which you can obviously you
can also look from the yarn ui to look
into your applications which can give
you a detailed information of if it was
a map reduce how many map and reduced
tasks were run what were the different
counters if it was a spark application
it can let you follow through spark
history server or job history server so
you can always use the web ui to look
into the jobs you can be finding in lot
of useful information here you can also
be looking at how many resources were
used and what happened to the job was it
successful did it fail and what was the
job status now apart from
web ui which always you might not have
access to so in a particular cluster in
a production cluster there might be
restrictions and the organization might
not have
access given to all the users to
graphical user interface like you or
might be you would not have access to
the cloud era manager or admin console
because probably organization is
managing multiple clusters using this
admin console so the one way which you
would have access is your web console or
basically your edge node or client
machine from where you can connect to
the cluster and then you can be working
so let's log in here and now here we can
give different commands so this is the
command line from where you can have
access to different details you can
always check by just typing in map red
which gives you different options where
you can look at the map reduce related
jobs you can look at different queues if
there are queues configured you can look
at the history server or you can also be
doing some admin stuff provided you have
access so for example if i just say map
red and q here this basically gives me
an option says what would you want to do
would you want to list all the queues do
you want information on a particular
queue so let's try a list
and that should give you different
queues which were being used now here we
know that per user a queue dynamically
gets created which is under root dot
users and that gives me what is the
status of the queue what is the capacity
has there been any kind of maximum
capacity or capping done so we get to
see a huge list of queues which
dynamically get configured in this
environment and then you also look at
your root dot default i could have also
picked up one particular queue and i
could have said show me the jobs so i
could do that now here we can
also give a yarn command so let me just
clear the screen and i will say yarn and
that shows me different options so apart
from your web interface
something like web ui apart from your
yarn's web ui you could also be looking
for information using yarn commands here
so these are some list of commands which
we can check now you can just type in
yarn and version if you would want to
see the version which basically gives
you information of what is the hadoop
version being used and what is the
vendor-specific distribution version so
here we see we are working on cloudera's
distribution 5.14 which is internally
using hadoop 2.6 now similarly you can
be doing a yarn application list so if
you give this that could be an
exhaustive list of all the applications
which are running or applications which
have completed so here we don't see any
applications because right now probably
there are no applications which are
running it also shows you you could be
pulling out different status such as
submitted accepted or running now you
could also say i would want to see the
services that have finished running so i
could say yarn application list and app
state says finished so here we could be
using our command so i could say yarn
application
list
and then i would want to see the app
states which gives me the applications
which have finished and we would want to
list all the applications which finished
now there that might be applications
which succeeded right and there is a
huge list of application which is coming
in from the history server which is
basically showing you the huge list of
applications which have completed so
this is one way and then you could also
be searching for one particular
application if you would want to search
a particular application if you have the
application id you could always be doing
a grip that's a simple way i could say
basically let's pick up this one and if
i would want to search for this if i
would want more details on this i could
obviously do that
by calling in my previous command and
you could do a grip if that's what you
want to do and if you would want to
search is there any application which is
in the list of my applications that
shows my application i could pull out
more information about my application so
i could look at the log files for a
particular application by giving the
application id so i could say yarn logs
now that's an option and every time
anytime you have a doubt just hit enter
it will always give you options what you
need to give with a particular command
so i can say yarn logs application
id now we copied an application id and
we could just give it here we could give
other options like app owner or if you
would want to get into the container
details or if you would want to check on
a particular node now here i'm giving
yarn logs and then i'm pointing it to
an application id and it says the log
aggregation has not completed might be
this was might be this was an
application which was triggered based on
a particular interactive shell or based
on a particular query so there is no log
existing for this particular application
you can always look at the status of an
application you can kill an application
so here you can be saying yan yan
application and then what would you want
to do with an application hit and enter
it shows you the different options so we
just tried app states you could always
look at the last one which says status
and then for my status i could be giving
my application id so that tells me what
is the status of this application it
connects to the resource manager it
tells me what's the application id what
kind of application it was who ran it
which was the queue where the job was
running what was the start and end time
what is the progress the status of it if
it is finished or if it has succeeded
and then it basically gives me also an
information of where the application
master was running it gives me the
information where you can find this job
details in history server if you are
interested in looking into it also gives
you a aggregate resource allocation
which tells how much gb memory and how
many c core seconds it used so this is
basically looking out at the application
details now i could kill an application
if the application was already running i
could always do a yarn application
minus skill and then i could be giving
my application now i could try killing
this however it would say the
application is already finished if i had
an application running and if my
application was already given an
application id by resource manager i
could just kill it i can also say yarn
node list which should give me a list of
the node managers now this is what we
were looking from the yarn web ui and we
were pulling out the information so we
can get this and kind of information
from your command line always remember
and always try to be well accustomed
with the command line so you can do
various things from the command line and
then obviously you have the web uis
which can help you with a graphical
interface easily able to access things
now you could be also starting the
resource manager which we would not be
doing here because we are already
running in a cluster so you could give a
yarn resource manager you could get the
logs of resource manager if you would
want by giving yarn demon so we can try
that so you can say yarn and then demon
so it says it does not find the demon so
you can give something like this get
level and here i will have to give the
node and the ip address where you want
to check the logs of resource manager so
you could be giving this for which we
will have to then get into cloud error
manager to look into the nodes and the
ip address you could be giving a command
something like this which basically
gives you the level of the log which you
have and i got this resource manager
address from the web ui now i can be
giving in this command to look into the
demand log and it basically says you
would want to look at the resource
manager related log and you have the log
4j which is being used for logging the
kind of level which has been set as info
which can again be changed in the way
you're logging the information now you
can try any other commands also from
yarn for example looking at the yarn rm
admin so you can always do a yarn rm
admin and this basically gives you a lot
of other informations like refreshing
the queues or refreshing the nodes or
basically looking at the admin acls or
getting groups so you could always get
group names for a particular user now we
could search for a particular user such
as yarn or hdfs itself so i could just
say here i would want get
groups and then i could be searching for
say username hdfs so that tells me sdfs
belongs to a hadoop group similarly you
could search for say map red or you
could search for yarn so these are
service related users which
automatically get created and you can
pull out information related to these
you can always do a refresh nodes kind
of command and that is mainly done
internally this can be useful when
you're doing commissioning
decommissioning but then in case of
cloudera or hortonworks kind of cluster
you would not be manually giving this
command because if you are doing a
commissioning decommissioning from an
admin console and if you are an
administrator then you could just
restart the services which are affected
and that will take care of this but if
you were working in an apache cluster
and if you were doing commissioning
decommissioning then you would be using
in two commands refresh nodes and
basically that's for refreshing the
nodes which
should not be used for processing and
similarly you could have a command
refresh nodes which comes with sdfs so
these are different options which you
can use with your yarn on the command
line you could also be using curl
commands to get more information about
your cluster by giving curl minus x and
then basically pointing out to your
resource manager web ui address now here
i would like to print out the cluster
related metrics and i could just simply
do this which basically gives me a high
level information of how many
applications were submitted how many are
pending what is the reserved resources
what is the available amount of memory
or cpu cores and all the information
similarly you can be using the same curl
commands to get more information like
scheduler information so you would just
replace the metrics with scheduler and
you could get the information of the
different queues now that's a huge list
we can cancel this and that would give
me a list of all the queues which are
allocated and what are the resources
allocated for each queue you could also
get cluster information on application
ids and status running of applications
running in yarn so you would have to
replace the last bit of it and you would
say i would want to look at the
applications and that gives me a huge
list of applications then you can do a
grip and you can be filtering out
specific application related information
similarly you can be looking at the
nodes so you can always be looking at
node specific information which gives
you how many nodes you have but this
could be mainly used when you have an
application which wants to or a web
application which wants to use a curl
command and would want to get
information about your cluster from an
http interface now when it comes to
application we can basically try running
a simple or a sample map reduced job
which could then be triggered on yarn
and it would use the resources now i can
look at my application here and i can be
looking into my specific directory which
is this one which should have a lot of
files and directories which we have here
now i could pick up one of these and i
could be using a simple example to do
some processing let's take up this file
so there is a file and i could run a
simple word count or i could be running
a hive query which triggers a mapreduce
job i could even run a spark application
which would then show that the
application is running on the cluster so
for example if i would say spark to
shell now i know that this is an
interactive way of working with spark
but this internally triggers a spark
submit and this runs an application so
here when you do a spark to shell by
default it will contact yarn so it gets
an application id it is running on yarn
with the master being yarn and now i
have access to the interactive way of
working with spark now if i go and look
into applications i should be able to
see my application which has been
started here and it shows up here so
this is my application 3827
which has been started on yarn and as of
now we can also look into the yarn ui
and that shows me the application which
has been started which basically has one
running container which has one cpu core
allocated 2gb ram and it's in progress
although we are not doing anything there
so we can always look at our application
from the yarn ui or as i mentioned from
your applications tab within yarn
services which gives us the information
and you can even click on this
application to follow and see more
information but you should be given
access to that now this is just a simple
application which i triggered using
spark shell similarly i can basically be
running a mapreduce now to run a
mapreduce i can say hadoop jar and that
basically needs a class so we can look
for the default path which is opt cloud
error parcels cdh
lib hadoop mapreduce hadoop mapreduce
examples and then we can look at this
particular jar file and if i hit on
enter it shows me the different classes
which are part of this jar and here i
would like to use word count so i could
just give this i could say word count
now remember i could run the job in a
particular queue by giving in an
argument here so i could say minus d map
red dot job dot q
dot name and then i can point my job to
a particular queue i can even give
different arguments in saying i would
want my mapreduce output to be
compressed or i want it to be stored in
a particular directory and so on so here
i have the word count and then basically
what i can be doing is i can be pointing
it to a particular input path
and then i can have my output which can
be getting stored here again a directory
which we need to choose and i will say
output
new and i can submit my job now once i
have submitted my job it connects to
resource manager it basically gets a job
id it gets an application id it shows
you from where you can track your
application you can always go to the
yarn ui and you can be looking at your
application and the resources it is
using so my application was not a big
one and it has already completed it
triggered one map task it launched one
reduced task it was working on around 12
466 records where you have then the
output of map which is these many number
of output records which was then taken
by a combiner and finally by a reducer
which basically gives you the output so
this is my on application which has
completed now i could be looking into
the yarn ui and if my job has completed
you might not see your application here
so as of now it shows up here the word
count which i ran it also shows me my
previous spark shell job it shows me my
application is completed and if you
would want further information on this
you can click and go to the history
server if you have been given access to
it or directly go to the history server
web ui where your application shows up
it shows how many map and reduce tasks
it was running you can click on this
particular application which basically
gives you information of your map and
reduce tasks you can look at different
counters for your application right you
can always look at map specific tasks
you can always look into one particular
task what it did on which node it was
running or you can be looking at the
complete application log so you can
always click on the logs and here you
have click here for full log which gives
you the information and you can always
look for your application which can give
you information of app master being
launched or you could have
search for the word container so you
could see a job which needs one or
multiple containers and then you could
say container is being requested then
you could see container is being
allocated then you can see what is the
container size and then basically your
task moves from initializing to running
in the container and finally you can
even search for release which will tell
you that the container was released so
you can always look into the log for
more information so this is how you can
interact with yarn this is how you can
interact with your command line to look
for more information or using your yarn
web ui or you can also be looking into
your hue for more information we're
going to start getting into the tools
because you had all those pictures of
all those cool tools we have so we're
going to look at the first two of those
tools and in the tools we have scoop and
flume and this is for your data
collection and ingestion so where does
the need for scoop come in in our big
data hadoop file system processing huge
volumes of data requires loading data
from diverse sources into hadoop cluster
you can see here we have our data
processing and this process of loading
data from the heterogeneous sources
comes with a set of challenges so what
are the challenges maintaining data
consistency ensuring efficient
utilization of resources especially when
you're talking about big data we can
certainly use up the resources when
importing terabytes and petabytes of
data over the course of time loading
bulk data to hadoop was not possible
it's one of the big challenges that came
up when they first had the hadoop file
system going and loading data using
script was very slow in other words
you'd write a script in whatever
language you're in and then it would
very slowly load each piece and parse it
in so the solution scoop scooped helped
in overcoming all the challenges to
traditional approach and could lead bulk
data from rdbms to hadoop very easily so
thank your enterprise server you want to
take the from mysql or sql and you want
to bring that data into your hadoop
warehouse your data filing system and
that's where scoop comes in so what
exactly is scoop scoop is a tool used to
transfer bulk of data between hadoop and
external data stores such as relational
databases and my sql server or the
microsoft sql server or mysql server so
scoop equals sql plus hadoop and you can
see here we have our rdbms all the data
we have stored on there and then your
scoop is the middle ground and brings
the import into the hadoop file system
it also is one of the features that goes
out and grabs the data from hadoop and
exports it back out into an rdbms let's
take a look at scoop features scoop
features has parallel import and export
it has import results of sql query
connectors for all major rdbms databases
kerberos security integration provides
full and incremental load so we look at
parallel import and export scoop uses
yarn yet another resource negotiator
framework to import and export data this
provides fault tolerance on a top of
parallelism scoop allows us to import
the result returned from an sql carry
into the hadoop file system or the hdfs
and you can see here where the import
results of sql query come in scoop
provides connectors for multiple
relational database management system
rdbms databases such as mysql and
microsoft sql server and has connectors
for all major rdbms databases scoop
supports kerberos computer network
authentication protocol that allows
nodes communicating over a non-secure
network to prove their identity to one
another in a secure manner scoop can
load the whole table or parts of the
table by a single command hence it
supports full and incremental load let's
dig a little deeper into the scoop
architecture we have our client in this
case a hooded wizard behind his laptop
you never know who's going to be
accessing the hadoop cluster and the
client comes in and sends their command
which goes into scoop the client submits
the import export command to import or
export data data from different
databases is fetched by scoop and so we
have
enterprise data warehouse document based
systems you have connect connector for
your data warehouse a connector for
document based systems which reaches out
to those two entities and we have our
connector for the rdbms so connectors
help in working with a range of popular
databases multiple mappers perform map
tasks to load the data onto hdfs the
hadoop file system and you can see here
we have the map task if you remember
from hadoop hadoop
is based on map reduce because we're not
reducing the data we're just mapping it
over it only accesses the mappers and it
opens up multiple mappers to do parallel
processing and you can see here the hdfs
hbase high is where the target is for
this particular one similarly multiple
map tests will export the data from hdfs
onto rdbms using scoop export command so
just like you can import it you can now
export it using the multiple map
routines scoop import so here we have
our dbms datastore and we have the
folders on there so maybe it's your
company's database maybe it's an archive
at google with all the searches going on
whatever it is usually you think with
scoop you think sql you think my sql
server or microsoft sql server that kind
of setup so it gathers the metadata and
you see the scoop import so introspect
database together metadata primary key
information and then it submits uh so
you can see submits map only job
remember we talked about map reduce it
only needs the map side of it because
we're not reducing the data we're just
mapping it over scoop divides the input
data set into splits and uses individual
map tests to push the splits into hdfs
so right into the hadoop file system and
you can see down on the right is kind of
a small depiction of a hadoop cluster
and then you have scoop export so we're
going to go the other direction and with
the other direction you have your hadoop
file system storage which is your hadoop
cluster you have your scoop job and each
one of those clusters then gets a map
mapper comes out to each one of the
computers that has data on it
so the first step is you've got to
gather the metadata so step one you
gather the metadata step two submits map
only job introspect database together
metadata primary key information scoop
divides the input data set into splits
and uses individual map tests to push
the splits to rdbms scoop will export
hadoop files back to rdms tables you can
think of this in a number of different
manners one of them would be if you're
restoring a backup from the hadoop file
system into your enterprise machines
there's certainly many others as far as
exploring data and data science so as we
dig a little deeper into scoop input we
have our connect our jdbc and our url so
specified the jdbc connect string
connecting manager we specify the
connection manager class to use you can
see here driver with the class name
manually specify the jdbc driver class
to use hadoop mapreduce home directory
override hadoop mapped home username set
authentication username and of course
help print uses instructions and with
the export you'll see that we can
specify the jdbc connect string specify
the connection manager class to use
manually specify jdbc driver class to
use you do have to let it know to
override the hadoop map reduce home and
that's true on both of these and set
authentication username and finally you
can print out all your help setup so you
can see the format for scoop is pretty
straightforward both import and export
so let's uh continue on our path and
look at scoop processing and what the
computer goes through for that and we
talk about scoop processing first scoop
runs in the hadoop cluster it imports
data from the rdbms the nosql database
to the hadoop file system so remember we
might not be importing the data from a
rdbms it might actually be coming from
an osql and there's many out there it
uses mappers to slice the incoming data
into multiple formats and load the data
into hdfs it exports data back into an
rdbms while making sure that the schema
of the data in the database is
maintained so now we've looked at the
basic commands in our scope in the scope
processing or at least the basics as far
as
theory is concerned let's just jump in
and take a look at a demo on scoop
for this demo i'm going to use our
cloudera quick start if you've been
watching our other demos we've done
you'll see that we've been using that
pretty consistently certainly this will
work in any of your
your horton sandbox which is also a
single node testing machine cloudera is
one of um there's a docker version
instead of virtualbox and you can also
set up your own hadoop cluster plan a
little extra time if you're not an admin
it's actually a pretty uh significant
endeavor for an admin if you've been
admitting linux machines for a very long
time and you know a lot of the commands
i find for most admins it takes about
two to four hours the first time they go
in and create a virtual machine and set
up their own hadoop in this case though
when you're just learning and getting
set up best to start with cloudera
cloudera also includes an install
version of mysql that way you don't have
to install the the sql version for
importing data from into once you're in
the cloudera quick start you'll see it
opens a nice centos linux interface and
it has the desktop setup on there this
is really nice for learning so you're
not just looking at command lines and
from in here it should open up by
default to hue if not you can click on
hue here's a kind of a fun little
web-based interface under hue i can go
under query i can pick an editor and
we'll go right down to scoop
so now i'm just going to load the scoop
editor inner hue now i'm going to switch
over and do this all in command line i
just want to show that you can actually
do this in a hue through the web-based
interface the reason i like to do the
command line is specifically on my
computer it runs much quicker or if i do
the command line here and i run it it
tends to have an extra lag or an added
layer in it so for this we're going to
go ahead and open our command line the
second reason i do this is we're going
to need to go ahead and edit our
mysql so we have something to scoop in
otherwise i don't have anything going in
there and of course we zoom in we'll
zoom in this and increase the size of
our screen so for this demo our hands-on
i'm going to use oracle virtualbox
manager and the cloudera quick start if
you're not familiar with this we do have
another tutorial we put out and you can
send a note in the youtube video below
and let our team know and they'll send
you a link or come visit
www.simplylearn.com now this creates a
linux box on my windows computer so
we're going to be in linux and it'll be
the cloudera version
with scoop and we'll also be using mysql
my sql server once inside the cloudera
virtual box we'll go under the hue
editor now we're going to do everything
in terminal window but i just want you
to be aware that under the hue editor
you can go under query editor and you'll
see as we come down here here's our
scoop on this so you can run your scoop
from in here now before we do this we
have to do a little exploration in my
sql and my sql server that way we know
what data is coming in so let me go
ahead and open up a terminal window in
cloudera you have a terminal window at
the top here that you can just click on
and open it up and let me just go ahead
and zoom in on here go view and zoom in
now to get into my sql server you simply
type in mysql and this part will depend
on your setup now the cloudera
quickstart comes up that the username is
root and the password is cloudera kind
of a strange quirk is that you can put a
space between the minus u and the root
but not between the minus p and the
cloudera usually you put in a minus
capital p and then it prompts you for
your password on here for this demo i
don't worry too much about you knowing
the password on that so we'll just go
right into my sql server since this is
the standard password for this quick
start and you can see we're now into
mysql and we're going to do just a
couple of quick
commands in here there's show databases
and you followed by the semicolon that's
standard in most of these shell commands
so it knows it's the end of your shell
command and you'll see in here in the
quick start cloudera quickstart the
mysql comes with a standard set of
databases these are just some of these
have to do like with the uzi which is
the uzi part of hadoop where others of
these like customers and employees and
stuff like that those are just for demo
purposes they come as a standard setup
in there so that people going in for the
first time have a database to play with
which is really good for us so we don't
have to recreate those databases and you
will see in the list here we have a
retail underscore db
and then we can simply do
use
retail underscore db this will set that
as a default in mysql and then we want
to go ahead and show the tables and if
we show the tables you can see under the
database the retail db database we have
categories customers departments order
items orders products so there's a
number of tables in here and we're going
to go ahead and just use a standard
sql command and if you did our hive
language you'll note remember it's the
same for hql also on this we're just
going to select star everything from
departments
so there's our departments table and
we're going to list everything on the
departments table and you'll see we have
about six lines in here and it has a
department id and a department name
two for fitness 3 for footwear so on and
so forth now at this point i can just go
ahead and exit but it's kind of nice to
have this data up here so we can look at
it and flip back and forth between the
screens so i'm going to open up another
terminal window and we'll go ahead and
zoom in on this also and it isn't too
important for this particular setup but
it's always kind of fine fun to know
what your setup you're working with what
is your host name and so we'll go ahead
and just type that in this is a linux
command and it's a
name minus f and you see we're on quick
start cloudera no surprise there now
this next command is going to be a
little bit longer because we're going to
be doing our first scoop command and i'm
going to do two of them we're going to
list databases and list tables it's
going to take just a moment to get
through this
because there's a bunch of stuff going
on here so we have scoop we have list
databases we have connect and under the
connect command we need to let it know
how we're connecting we're going to use
the jdbc this is a very standard one uh
jdbc mysql so you'll see that if you're
doing an sql database that's how you
started off with and then the next part
this is where you have to go look it up
it's however it was created so if your
admin created a mysql server with a
certain setup that's what you have to go
by and you'll see that usually they list
this as localhost so you'll see
something like localhost sometimes
there's a lot of different formats but
the most common is either local host or
the actual connection so in this case we
want to go ahead and do quick start
3306 and so quick start use the name of
the localhost database and how it's
hosted on here and when you set up the
quick start for um for hadoop under
cloudera it's port 3306 is where that's
coming in so that's where all that's
coming from uh and so there's our path
for that and then we have to put in our
password we typically type password if
you look it up password on the cloudera
quickstart is cloudera and we have to
also let it know the username and again
if you're doing this you'd probably put
in a minus capital you can actually just
do it for a prompt
for the password so if you leave that
out it'll prompt you but for this
doesn't really matter i don't care if
you see my password it's the default one
for cloudera quickstart and then the
username on here is simply root and then
we're going to put our semicolon at the
end and so we have here our full setup
and we go ahead and list the databases
and you'll see you might get some
warnings on here i haven't run the
updates on the quick start i suggest
you're not running the updates either if
you're doing this for the first time
because it'll do some reformatting on
there and it quickly pass up and you can
see here's all of our the tables we went
in there and if we go back to
on the previous window we should see
that these tables match so here we come
in and here we have our databases and
you can see back up here we had the cm
customers employees and so on so the
databases match and then we want to go
ahead and list the
tables for a specific database so let's
go ahead and do that i'm a very lazy
typist so i'll put the up arrow in and
you can see here scoop list databases
we're just going to go back and change
this from databases to list tables so we
want to list the tables in here same
connection so most the connection is the
same except we need to know which tables
we're listing an interesting fact is you
can create a table without being under a
database so if you left this blank it
will show the open tables that aren't
connected directly to a database or
under a database but what we want to do
is right past this last slash on the
3306 we want to put that retail
underscore
db because that's the database we're
going to be working with and this will
go in there and show the tables listed
under that database and here we go we
got categories customers departments
order items and products if we flip back
here real quick there it is the same
thing we had we had categories customers
departments order items and so on and so
let's go ahead and run our first import
command and again i'm that lazy typer so
we're going to do scoop and instead of
list tables we want to go ahead and
import so there's our import command and
so once we have our import command in
there then we need to tell it exactly
what we're going to import so everything
else is the same we're importing from
the retail db so we keep that and then
at the very end we're going to tag on
dash dash table that tells us we can
tell what table we're importing from and
we're going to import departments
there we go so this is pretty
straightforward because it what's nice
about this is you can see the commands
are the same i got the same connection
i change it for the whatever database
i'm in
then i come in here our password and the
username are going to be the same that's
all under the mysql server setup and
then we let it know what table we're
entering in we run this and this is
going to actually go through the mapper
process in hadoop so this is a mapping
process it takes the data and it maps it
up to different parts in the setup in
hadoop on there and then saves that data
into the hadoop file system and it does
take it a moment to zip through which i
kind of skipped over for you since it is
running a you know it's designed to run
across the cluster not on a single node
so when you're running on a single node
it's going to run slow even if you
dedicate a couple cores to it i think i
put dedicated four cores to this one uh
and so you can see right down here we
get to the end it's now mapped in that
information and then we can go in here
we can go under
can flip back to our hue and under hue
on the top i have there's databases and
the second icon over is your hadoop file
system and we can go in here and look at
the hadoop file system and you'll see it
show up underneath our documents there
it is departments cloudera departments
and you can see there's always a delay
when i'm working in hue which i don't
like and that's the quick start issue
that's not necessarily running on a
server when i'm running it on a server
you pretty much have to run through some
kind of server interface i still prefer
the terminal window it still runs a lot
quicker but we'll flip back on over here
to the command line and we can do the
hadoop
type in the hadoop fs and then list
minus ls and if we run this you'll see
underneath our hadoop file system there
is our departments which has been added
in and we can also do
hadoop fs and this is kind of
interesting for those who've gone
through the hadoop file system
everything you'll you'll recognize this
on here i'm going to list that the
contents of departments and you'll see
underneath departments we have part part
m0001002003
and so this is interesting because this
is how hadoop saves these files and this
is in the file system this is not in
hive so we didn't directly import this
into hive we put this in the hadoop file
system depending on what you're doing
you would then write the schema for hive
to look at the hadoop file system
certainly visit our hive tutorial for
more information on hive specific
so you can see in here are different
files that it forms that are part of
departments and we can do something like
this we can look at the contents of one
of these files fs minus ls or a number
of the files and we'll simply do the
full path which is user cloudera and
then we already know the next one is
departments
and then after departments we're going
to put slash part star so this is going
to say anything that has part in it
so we have part dash m 0 0 0 and so on
uh we can go ahead and cat use that ket
command or that list command to bring
those up and then we can use the cat
command to actually display the contents
and that's a linux command hadoop linux
command the cat catenate not to be
confused with catatonic catastrophic
there's a lot of cat got your tongue and
we see here fitness footwear apparel
that should look really familiar because
that's what we had in our my sequel
server when we went in here we did a
select all on here there it is fitness
footwear apparel golf outdoors and fan
shop and then of course it's really
important let's look back on over here
to be able to tell it where to put the
data uh so we go back to our import
command so here's our scoop import we
have our connect we have the db
underneath our connection our mysql
server we have our password our username
the table going where it's going to i
mean the table where it's coming from uh
and then we can add a target on here we
can put in a target
dash
directory and you do have to put the
full path that's a hadoop thing it's a
good practice to be in and we're going
to add it to department we'll just do
department one and so here we now add a
target directory in here and user
cloudera department one and this will
take just a moment before so i'll go
ahead and skip over the process since
it's going to run very slowly it's only
running on like i said a couple cores
and it's also on a single node and now
we can do the uh hadoop let's just do
the up arrow file system list we want
just straight list and when we do the
hadoop file system minus ls or list
you'll see that we now have department
one and we can of course do list
department one and you can see we have
the files inside department one and they
mirrored what we saw before with the
same files in there and the part m o 0 0
and so on if we want to look at them
it'd be the same thing we did before
with the cat so except instead of
departments uh we'd be department one
there we go something that's going to
come up with the same data we had before
now one of the important things when
you're importing data and it's always a
question to ask is do you filter the
data before it comes in do we want to
filter this data as it comes in so we're
not storing everything in our file
system you would think hadoop big data
put it all in there i know from
experience that putting it all in there
can turn a couple hundred terabytes into
a petabyte very rapidly and suddenly
you're having to really add on to that
data store and you're storing duplicate
data sometimes so you really need to be
able to filter your data out and so
let's go ahead and use our up arrow to
go to our last import uh since it's
still a lot the same stuff so we have
all of our commands under import we have
the target we're going to change this to
department 2 so we're going to create a
new directory for this one and then
after departments uh there's another
command that we didn't really slide in
here and that's our mapping and i'll
show you what this looks like in a
minute but we're going to put m3 in
there that doesn't have nothing to do
with the filtering i'll show you that in
a second though what that's for and we
just want to put in where uh so where
and what is the where in this case we
want to know where department
id and if you wanna know where that came
from we can flip back on over here we
have department underscore ids this is
where that's coming from that's just the
name of the column on here so we come in
here to department id
is greater than four simple
logic there you can see where you'd use
that for maybe creating buckets for ages
uh you know age from 10 to 15 20 to 30.
you might be looking for i mean there's
all kinds of reasons why you could use
the where command on here and filter
information out maybe you're doing word
counting and you want to know words that
are used less than a hundred times you
want to get rid of the and is and and
and all the stuff that's used over and
over again uh so we'll go ahead and put
the where and then department id is
greater than four we'll go ahead and hit
enter on here and this will create our
department two setup on this and i'll go
ahead and skip over some of the runtime
again it runs really slow on a single
node real quick page through our
commands
let's see here we go
our list and we should see underneath
the list the department two on here now
and there it is department two uh and
then i can go ahead and do list
department two you'll see the contents
in here uh and you'll see that there is
only three maps and it could be that the
data created three maps but remember i
set it up to only use three mappers uh
so there's zero one and two and we can
go ahead and do a cat on there remember
this is department two so we wanna look
at all the contents of these three
different files and there it is it's
greater than four so we have golf is
five outdoor six uh fan shop is seven so
we've effectively filtered out our data
and just storing the data we want on our
file system so if you're going to store
data on here the next stage is to export
the data uh remember a lot of times you
have my sequel server and we're
continually dumping that data into our
long term storage and access the hadoop
file system but what happens when you
need to pull that data out and
restore a database or
maybe you have you just merged with a
new company a favorite topic merging
companies emerging databases
that's listed under nightmare and how
many different names for company can you
have so you can see where being able to
export is also equally important and
let's go ahead and do that and i'm going
to flip back over to my sql server here
and we'll need to go ahead and create
our database we're going to export into
now i'm not going to go too much in
detail on this command we're simply
creating a table and the table is going
to have
it's pretty much the same table we
already have in here from departments
but in this case we're going to create a
table called dept
so it's the same setup but it's it's
just going to we're just giving a
different name a different schema and so
we've done that and we'll go ahead and
do a select star from dept
there we go and it's empty that's what
we expect a new database a new data
table and it's empty in there so now we
need to go ahead and export our data
that we just filtered out into there so
let's flip back on over here to our
scoop setup which is just our linux
terminal window and let's go back up to
one of our commands here's scoop import
in this case instead of import we're
going to take the scoop and we're going
to export so we're going to just change
that export
and the connection is going to remain
the same so same connect same database
we're also we're still doing the retail
db we have the same password so none of
that changes uh the big change here is
going to be the table instead of
departments uh remember we changed it
and gave it a new name and so we want to
change it here also d-e-p-t so
department we're not going to worry
about the mapper count and the where was
part of our import there we go and then
finally it needs to know where to export
from so instead of target directory we
have an export directory that's where
it's coming from uh still user cloudera
and we'll keep it as department 2. uh
just so you can see how that data is
coming back with that we filtered in and
let's go ahead and run this it'll take
it just a moment to go through with
steps and again because it's low i'm
just going to go and skip this so you
don't have to sit through it and once
we've wrapped up our export we'll flip
back on over here to mysql use the up
arrow and this time we're going to
select star from department and we can
see that there it is it exported the
golf outdoors and fan shop and you can
imagine also that you might have to use
the where command in your export also so
there's a lot of mixing the command line
for scoop is pretty straightforward
you're changing the different variables
in there whether you're creating a table
listing a table listing databases very
powerful tool for bringing your data
into the hadoop file system and
exporting it so now that we've wrapped
up our demo on scoop and gone through a
lot of basic commands now flume is a
distributed service for collecting
aggregating and moving large amounts of
log data so kind of focused a little bit
on a slightly different set of data
although you'll find these overlap a lot
you can certainly use flume to do a lot
of things you can do in scoop and vice
versa flume ingests the data so we're
looking at like say a json call to a
website xml documents unstructured and
semi-structured data is most commonly
digested by flume best example i saw was
a twitter account pulling twitter feeds
into a hadoop system so it ingests
online streaming data from social media
twitter log files so we want to know
what's going on with error codes on your
servers and all those log files web
server what's going on in your web
server we can bring all this stuff in
and just dump it into the hadoop data
file system to be looked at and
processed later and it's a web server
cloud social media data again all those
different sources it can be it's kind of
endless you know it just depends on what
your company needs versatility of hadoop
is what makes it such a powerful source
to add into a company and so it comes in
there you have your source it goes
through the channels it then goes
through kind of a sync feature to make
sure everything is in sync and then it
dumps it into the hadoop file system so
we've covered in the hadoop file system
the first two things let's look at some
of the scripting languages they have and
so we have the two here and you can also
think of these it actually says
scripting and sql queries a lot of times
they're both referred to as queries so
you have both the pig and the hive so
the history of hive begins with facebook
facebook began using hadoop as a
solution to handle the growing big data
and we're not talking about a data that
fits on one or two or even five
computers uh we're talking due to the
fits on if you've looked at any of our
other hadoop tutorials you'll know we're
talking about very big data and data
pools and facebook certainly has a lot
of data it tracks as we know the hadoop
uses mapreduce for processing data
mapreduce required users to write long
codes and so you'd have these really
extensive java codes very complicated
for the average person to use not all
users were versed in java and other
coding languages this proved to be a
disadvantage for them users were
comfortable with writing queries in sql
sql has been around for a long time the
standard
sql query language hive was developed
with the vision to incorporate the
concepts of tables columns just like sql
so why hive well the problem was for
processing and analyzing data users
found it difficult to code as not all of
them were well-versed with the coding
languages you have your processing you
have your analyzing and so the solution
was
required a language similar to sql which
was well known to all the users and thus
the hive or hql language evolved what is
hive hive is a data warehouse system
which is used for querying and analyzing
large data sets stored in the hdfs or
the hadoop file system hive uses a query
language that we call hive ql or hql
which is similar to sql so if we take
our user the user sends out their hive
queries and then that is converted into
a mapreduce tasks and then accesses the
hadoop mapreduce system let's take a
look at the architecture of hive
architecture of hive we have the hive
client
so that could be the programmer or maybe
it's a manager who knows enough sql to
do a basic query to look up the data
they need the hive client supports
different types of client applications
in different languages prefer for
performing queries and so we have our
thrift application in the hive thrift
client thrift is a software framework
hive server is based on thrift so it can
serve the request from all programming
language that support thrift and then we
have our jdbc application and the hive
jdbc driver jdbc java database
connectivity jdbc application is
connected through the jdbc driver and
then you have the odbc application or
the hive odbc driver the odbc or open
database connectivity the odbc
application is connected through the
odbc driver with the growing development
of all of our different scripting
languages python c plus plus
java you can find just about any
connection in any of the main scripting
languages and so we have our hive
services as we look at deeper into the
architecture hive supports various
services
so you have your hive server basically
your thrift application or your hive
thrift client or your jdbc or your hive
jdbc driver your odbc application or
your hive odbc driver they all connect
into the hive server and you have your
hive web interface you also have your
cli now the hive web interface is a gui
is provided to execute hive queries and
we'll actually be using that later on
today so you can see kind of what that
looks like and get a feel for what that
means commands are executed directly in
cli and then the cli is a direct
terminal window and i'll also show you
that too so you can see how those two
different interfaces work these then
push the code into the hive driver hive
driver is responsible for all the
queries submitted so everything goes
through that driver let's take a closer
look at the hive driver the hive driver
now performs three steps internally one
is a compiler hive driver passes query
to compiler where it is checked and
analyzed then the optimizer kicks in and
the optimized logical plan in the form
of a graph of mapreduce and hdfs tasks
is obtained and then finally in the
executor in the final step the tasks are
executed we look at the architecture we
also have to note the meta store
metastore is a repository for hive
metadata stores metadata for hive tables
and you can think of this as your schema
and where is it located and it's stored
on the apache derby db processing and
resource management is all handled by
the mapreduce v1 you'll see mapreduce v2
the yarn and the tez these are all
different ways of managing these
resources depending on what version of
hadoop you're in hive uses mapreduce
framework to process queries and then we
have our distributed storage which is
the hdfs and if you looked at our hadoop
tutorials you'll know that these are on
commodity machines and are linearly
scalable that means they're very
affordable a lot of time when you're
talking about big data you're talking
about a tenth of the price of storing it
on enterprise computers and then we look
at the data flow and hive
so in our data flow in hive we have our
hive in the hadoop system and underneath
the user interface or the ui we have our
driver our compiler our execution engine
and our meta store that all goes into
the mapreduce and the hadoop file system
so when we execute a query you see it
coming in here it goes into the driver
step one step two we get a plan what are
we gonna do refers to the query
execution uh then we go to the metadata
it's like well what kind of metadata are
we actually looking at where is this
data located what is the schema on it uh
then this comes back with the metadata
into the compiler then the compiler
takes all that information and the send
plan returns it to the driver the driver
then sends the execute plan to the
execution engine once it's in the
execution engine the execution engine
acts as a bridge between hive and hadoop
to process the query and that's going
into your mapreduce in your hadoop file
system or your hdfs and then we come
back with the metadata operations it
goes back into the metastore to update
or let it know what's going on which
also goes to the between it's a
communication between the execution
engine and the metastore execution
engine communications is
bi-directionally with the metastore to
perform operations like create drop
tables metastore stores information
about tables and columns so again we're
talking about the schema of your
database and once we have that we have a
bi-directional send results
communication back into the driver and
then we have the fetch results which
goes back to the client so let's take a
little bit look at the hive data
modeling hive data modeling so you have
your high data modeling you have your
tables you have your partitions and you
have buckets the tables in hive are
created the same way it is done in rdbms
so when you're looking at your
traditional sql server or mysql server
where you might have enterprise
equipment and a lot of people pulling
and removing stuff off of there the
tables are gonna look very similar and
this makes it very easy to take that
information and let's say you need to
keep current information but you need to
store all of your years of transactions
back into the hadoop hive so you match
those those all kind of look the same
the tables are the same your databases
look very similar and you can easily
import them back you can easily store
them into the hive system partitions
here tables are organized into
partitions for grouping same type of
data based on partition key this can
become very important for speeding up
the process of doing queries so if
you're looking at dates as far as like
your employment dates of employees if
that's what you're tracking you might
add a partition there because that might
be one of the key things that you're
always looking up as far as employees
are concerned and finally we have
buckets uh data present in partitions
can be further divided into buckets for
efficient querying again there's that
efficiency uh at this level a lot of
times you're taught you're working with
the programmer and the admin of your
hadoop file system to maximize the
efficiency of that file system so it's
usually a two-person job and we're
talking about hive data modeling you
want to make sure that they work
together and you're maximizing your
resources hive data types so we're
talking about hive data types we have
our primitive data types and our complex
data types a lot of this will look
familiar because it mirrors a lot of
stuff in sql in our primitive data types
we have the numerical data types string
data type date time data type and
miscellaneous data type and these should
be very they're kind of self-explanatory
but just in case numerical data is your
floats your integers your short integers
all of that numerical data comes in as a
number a string of course is characters
and numbers and then you have your date
time stamp and then we have kind of a
general way of pulling your own created
data types in there that's your
miscellaneous data type and we have
complex data types so you can store
arrays you can store maps you can store
structures
and even units in there as we dig into
hive data types
and we have the primitive data types and
the complex data types so we look at
primitive data types and we're looking
at numeric data types data types like an
integer a float a decimal those are all
stored as numbers in the hive data
system a string data type data types
like characters and strings you store
the name of the person you're working
with you know john doe the city
memphis the state tennessee maybe it's
boulder colorado usa or maybe it's hyper
bad
india
that's all going to be string and stored
as a string character and of course we
have our date time data type data types
like timestamp date interval
those are very common as far as tracking
sales anything like that you just think
if you can type a stamp of time on it or
maybe you're dealing with a race and you
want to know the interval how long did
the person take to complete whatever
task it was all that is date time data
type and then we talk miscellaneous data
type these are like boolean and binary
and when you get into boolean and binary
you can actually almost create anything
in there but your yes knows zero one now
let's take a look at complex data types
a little closer uh we have arrays so
your syntax is of data type and it's an
array and you can just think of an array
as a collection of same
entities one two three four if they're
all numbers and you have maps this is a
collection of key value pairs
so understanding maps is so central to
hadoop
so we store maps you have a key which is
a set you only have one key per mapped
value and so you in hadoop of course you
collect the same keys and you can add
them all up or do something with all the
contents of the same key but this is our
map as a primitive type data type in our
collection of key value pairs and then
collection of complex data with comment
so we can have a structure we have a
column name data type comment call a
column comment so you can get very
complicated structures in here with your
collection of data and your commented
setup and then we have units and this is
a collection of heterogeneous data types
so the syntax for this is union type
data type data type and so on so it's
all going to be the same a little bit
different than the arrays where you can
actually mix and match different modes
of hive hive operates in two modes
depending on the number and size of data
nodes we have our local mode and our map
reduce mode when we talk about the local
mode it is used when hadoop is having
one data node and the data is small
processing will be very fast on the
smaller data sets which are present in
local machine and this might be that you
have a local file stuff you're uploading
into the hive and you need to do some
processes in there you can go ahead and
run those high processes and queries on
it usually you don't see much in the way
of a single node hadoop system if you're
going to do that you might as well just
use like an sql database or even a java
sqlite or something python is sqlite so
you don't really see a lot of single
node hadoop databases but you do see the
local mode in hive where you're working
with a small amount of data that's going
to be integrated into the larger
database and then we have the map reduce
mode this is used when hadoop is having
multiple data nodes and the data is
spread across various data nodes
processing large datasets can be more
efficient using this mode and this you
can think of instead of it being one two
three or even five computers we're
usually talking with the hadoop file
system we're looking at 10 computers 15
100 where this data is spread across all
those different hadoop nodes difference
between hive and
rdbms remember rdbms stands for the
relational database management system
let's take a look at the difference
between hive and the rdbms with hive
hive enforces schema on read and it's
very important that whatever is coming
in that's when hive's looking at it and
making sure that it fits the model the
rdbms enforces a schema when it actually
writes the data into the database so
it's read the data and then once it
starts to write it that's where it's
going to give you the error tell you
something's incorrect about your scheme
hive data size is in petabytes that is
hard to imagine you know we're looking
at your personal computer on your desk
maybe you have 10 terabytes if it's a
high-end computer we're talking
petabytes so that's hundreds of
computers grouped together when rdbms
data size is in terabytes very rarely do
you see an rdbms system that's spread
over more than five computers and
there's a lot of reasons for that with
the rdbms it actually has a high end
amount of writes to the hard drive
there's a lot more going on there you're
writing and pulling stuff so you really
don't want to get too big with an rd bms
or you're going to run into a lot of
problems with hive you can take it as
big as you want hive is based on the
notion of write once and read many times
this is so important and they call it
worm which is write w
read are many times m they refer to it
as worm and that's true of any of a lot
of your hadoop setup it's it's altered a
little bit but in general we're looking
at archiving data that you want to do
data analysis on we're looking at
pulling all that stuff off your rd bms
from years and years and years of
business or whatever your company does
or scientific research and putting that
into a huge data pool so that you can
now do queries on it and get that
information out of it with the rdbms
it's based on the notion of read and
write many times so you're continually
updating this database you're
continually bringing up new stuff new
sales
the account changes because they have a
different licensing now whatever
software you're selling all that kind of
stuff where the data is continually
fluctuating and then hive resembles a
traditional database by supporting sql
but it is not a database it is a data
warehouse this is very important it goes
with all the other stuff we've talked
about that we're not looking at a
database but a data warehouse to store
the data and still have fast and easy
access to it for doing queries you can
think of
twitter and facebook they have so many
posts that are archived back
historically those posts aren't going to
change they made the post they're posted
they're there and they're in their
database but they have to store it in a
warehouse in case they want to pull it
back up with the rdbms it's a type of
database management system which is
based on the relational model of data
and then with hive easily scalable at a
low cost again we're talking maybe a
thousand dollars per terabyte um the
rdbms is not scalable at a low cost when
you first start on the lower end you're
talking about 10 000 per terabyte of
data including all the backup on the
models and all the added necessities to
support it as you scale it up you have
to scale those computers and hardware up
so you might start off with a basic
server and then you upgrade to a sun
computer to run it and you spend you
know tens of thousands of dollars for
that hardware upgrade with hive you just
put another computer into your hadoop
file system so let's look at some of the
features of hive
when we're looking at the features of
hive we're talking about the use of sql
like language called hive ql a lot of
times you'll see that as hql which is
easier than long codes this is nice if
you're working with your shareholders
you come to them and you say hey you can
do a basic sql query on here and pull up
the information you need this way you
don't have to take off have your
programmers jump in every time they want
to look up something in the database
they actually now can easily do that if
they're not
skilled in programming and script
writing tables are used which are
similar to the rdbms hints easier to
understand and one of the things i like
about this is when i'm bringing tables
in from a mysql server or sql server
there's almost a direct reflection
between the two so when you're looking
at one which is the data which is
connelly changing and then you're going
into the archive database it's not this
huge jump where you have to learn a
whole new language
you mirror that same schema into the
hdfs into the hive making it very easy
to go between the two and then using
hive ql multiple users can
simultaneously query data so again you
have multiple clients in there and they
send in their query that's also true
with the rdbms which kind of queues them
up because it's running so fast you
don't notice the lag time well you get
that also with the hql as you add more
computers in the query can go very
quickly depending on how many computers
and how much resources each machine has
to pull the information and hive
supports a variety of data types
so with hive it's designed to be on the
hadoop system which you can put almost
anything into the hadoop file system so
with all that let's take a look at a
demo on hive ql or hql before i dive
into the hands-on demo let's take a look
at the website
hive.apache.org that's the main website
since apache it's an apache open source
uh software this is the main software
for the main site for the build and if
you go in here you'll see that they're
slowly migrating hive into beehive and
so if you see beehive versus hive note
the beehive as the new release is coming
out that's all it is it reflects a lot
of the same functionality of hive it's
the same thing and then we like to pull
up some kind of documentation on
commands and for this i'm actually going
to go to hortonworks hive cheat sheet
and that's because hortonworks and
cloudera are two of the most common used
builds for hadoop and for which include
hive and all the different tools in
there and so hortonworks has a pretty
good pdf you can download cheat sheet on
there i believe cloudera does too but
we'll go ahead and just look at the
horton one because it's the one that
comes up really good and you can see
when we look at the query language it
compares my sql server to hive ql or hql
and you can see the basic select we
select from columns
from table where conditions exist you
know most basic command on there and
they have different things you can do
with it just like you do with your
sql and if you scroll down you'll see
data types so here's your integer your
flow your binary double string timestamp
and all the different data types you can
use some different semantics different
keys features functions for running a
hive query command line setup and of
course a hive shell
set up in here so you can see right here
if we loop through it it has a lot of
your basic stuff it is we're basically
looking at sql across a horton database
we're going to go ahead and run our
hadoop cluster hive demo and i'm going
to go ahead and use the cloudera quick
start this is in the virtual box so
again we have an oracle virtual box
which is open source and then we have
our cloudera quick start which is the
hadoop setup on a single node now
obviously hadoop and hive are designed
to run across a cluster of computers so
we talk about a single node is for
education testing that kind of thing and
if you have a chance you can always go
back and look at our demo we had on
setting up a hadoop system in a single
cluster just set a note down below in
the youtube video and our team will get
in contact with you and send you that
link if you don't already have it or you
can contact us at the
www.simplylearn.com now in here it's
always important to note that you do
need um on your computer if you're
running on windows because i'm on a
windows machine you're going to need
probably about 12 gigabytes to actually
run this it used to be you could buy
with a lot less but as things have
evolved they take up more and more
resources and you need the professional
version if you have the home version i
was able to get that to run but boy did
it take a lot of extra work to get the
home version to let me use the virtual
setup on there and we'll simply click on
the cloudera quick start and i'm going
to go and just start that up and this is
starting up our linux so we have our
windows 10 which is a computer i'm on
and then i have the virtual box which is
going to have a linux operating system
in it and we'll skip ahead so you don't
have to watch the whole install
something interesting to know about the
cloudera is that it's running on
linuxcentos and for whatever reason i've
always had to click on it and hit the
escape button for it to spin up and then
you'll see the dos come in here now that
our cloudera spun up on our virtual
machine with the linux on we can see
here we have our it uses the
thunderbird browser on here by default
and automatically opens up a number of
different tabs for us and a quick note
because i mentioned like the
restrictions on getting set up on your
own computer if you have a home edition
computer and you're worried about
setting it up on there you can also go
in there and spin up a one month free
service on amazon web service to play
with this so there's other options
you're not stuck with just doing it on
the quick start menu you can spin this
up in many other ways now the first
thing we want to note is that we've come
in here into cloudera and i'm going to
access this in two ways
the first one is we're going to use hue
and i'm going to open up hue and i'll
take it a moment to load from
the setup on here and hue is nice if i
go in and use hue as an editor into hive
or into the hadoop setup usually i'm
doing it as a
from an admin side because it has a lot
more information a lot of visuals less
to do with you know actually diving in
there and just executing code and you
can also write this code into files and
scripts and there's other things you can
other ways you can upload it into hive
but today we're going to look at the
command lines and we'll upload it into
hue and then we'll go into and actually
do our work in a terminal window under
the hive shell now in the hue browser
window if you go under query and click
on the pull down menu and then you go
under editor and you'll see hive there
we go there's our hive setup i go and
click on hive and this will open up our
query down here and now it has a nice
little b that shows our hive going and
we can go something very simple down
here like show
databases and we follow it with the
semicolon and that's the standard in
hive as you always add our
punctuation at the end there and i'll go
ahead and run this and the query will
show up underneath and you'll see down
here since this is a new quick start i
just put on here you'll see it has the
default down here for the databases
that's the database name i haven't
actually created any databases on here
and then there's a lot of other like
assistant function tables
your databases up here there's all kinds
of things you can research you can look
at through hue as far as a bigger
picture the downside of this is it
always seems to lag for me whenever i'm
doing this i always seem to run slow so
if you're in cloudera you can open up a
terminal window they actually have an
icon at the top you can also go under
applications and under applications
system tools and terminal either one
will work it's just a regular terminal
window and this terminal window is now
running underneath our linux so this is
a linux terminal window or on our
virtual machine which is resting on our
regular windows 10 machine and we'll go
ahead and zoom this in so you can see
the text better on your own video i
simply just clicked on view and zoom in
and then all we have to do is type in
hive and this will open up the shell on
here and it takes it just a moment to
load when starting up hive i also want
to note that depending on your rights on
the computer you're on interaction you
might have to do pseudo-hive and put in
your password and username most
computers are usually set up with the
hive login again it just depends on how
you're accessing the linux system and
the hive shell once we're in here we can
go ahead and do a simple uh hql command
show databases and if we do that we'll
see here that we don't have any
databases so we can go ahead and create
a database and we'll just call it office
for today for this moment now if i do
show we'll just do the up arrow up arrow
is a hotkey that works in both linux and
in hive so i can go back and paste
through all the commands i've typed in
and we can see now that i have my
there's of course a default database and
then there's the office database so now
we've created a database it's pretty
quick and easy and we go ahead and drop
the database we can do drop database
office now this will work on this
database because it's empty if your
database was not empty you would have to
do cascade and that drops all the tables
in the database and the database itself
now if we do show database and we'll go
ahead and recreate our database because
we're going to use the office database
for the rest of this hands-on demo a
really handy command now set with the
sql or hql is to use office and what
that does is that sets office as a
default database so instead of having to
reference the database every time we
work with a table it now automatically
assumes that's the database being used
whatever tables we're working on the
difference is you put the database name
period table and i'll show you in just a
minute what that looks like and how
that's different if we're going to have
a table and a database we should
probably load some data into it so let
me go ahead and switch gears here and
open up a terminal window you can just
open another terminal window and it'll
open up right on top of the one that you
have hive shell running in and when
we're in this terminal window first
we're going to go ahead and just do a
list which is of course a linux command
you can see all the files i have in here
this is the default load we can change
directory to documents we can list in
documents and we're actually going to be
looking at employee.csv
a linux command is the cat you can use
this actually to combine documents
there's all kinds of things that cat
does but if we want to just display the
contents of our employee.csv
file we can simply do cat employee csv
and when we're looking at this we want
to know a couple things one there's a
line at the top okay so the very first
thing we notice is that we have a header
line the next thing we notice is that
the data is comma separated and in this
particular case you'll see a space here
generally with these you got to be real
careful with spaces there's all kinds of
things you've got to watch out for
because they can cause issues these
bases won't because these are all
strings that the space is connected to
if this was a space next to the integer
you would get a null value that comes
into the database without doing
something extra in there now with most
of hadoop that's important to know that
you're writing the data once reading it
many times and that's true of almost all
your hadoop things coming in so you
really want to process the data before
it gets into the database and for those
who of you have studied uh data
transformation that's the anal where you
extract transfer form and then load the
data so you really want to extract and
transform before putting it into the
hive then you load it into the hive with
the transformed data and of course we
also want to note the schema we have an
integer string string integer integer so
we kept it pretty simple in here as far
as the way the data is set up the last
thing that you're going to want to look
up
is the source since we're doing local
uploads we want to know what the path is
we have the whole path in this case it's
home slash cloudera slash documents and
these are just text documents we're
working with right now we're not doing
anything fancy so we can do a simple get
edit
employee.csv and you'll see it comes up
here it's just a text document so i can
easily remove these added spaces there
we go and then we go and just save it
and so now it has a new setup in there
we've edited it the g edit is usually
one of the default that loads into linux
so any text editor will do back to the
hive shell so let's go ahead and create
a table employee and what i want you to
note here is i did not put the semicolon
on the end here semicolon tells it to
execute that line so this is kind of
nice if you're you can actually just
paste it in if you have it written on
another sheet and you can see right here
where i have create table employee and
it goes into the next line on there so i
can do all of my commands at once now
just so i don't have any typo errors i
went ahead and just pasted the next
three lines in and the next one is our
schema if you remember correctly from
the other side we had the different
values in here which was id name
department year of joining and salary
and the id is an integer name is a
string department string air joining
energy salary an integer and they're in
brackets we put close brackets around
them and you could do this all as one
line and then we have row format
delimited fields terminated by comma and
this is important because the default is
tabs so if i do it now it won't find any
terminated fields so you'll get a bunch
of null values loaded into your table
and then finally our table properties we
want to skip the header line count
equals one now this is a lot of work for
uploading a single file it's kind of
goofy when you're uploading a single
file that you have to put all this in
here but keep in mind hive and hadoop is
designed for writing many files into the
database you write them all in there and
then you can they're saved it's an
archive it's a data warehouse and then
you're able to do all your queries on
them so a lot of times we're not looking
at just the one file coming up we're
loading hundreds of files and you have
your reports coming off of your main
database all those reports are being
loaded and you have your log files you
have i mean all this different data is
being dumped into hadoop and in this
case hive on top of hadoop and so we
need to let it know hey how do i handle
these files coming in and then we have
the semicolon at the end which lets us
know to go ahead and run this line and
so we'll go ahead and run that and now
if we do a show tables
you can see there's our employee on
there we can also describe if we do
describe employee you can see that we
have our id integer name string
department string year of joining
integer and salary integer and then
finally let's just do a select star from
employee very basic sql nhql command
selecting data it's going to come up and
we haven't put anything in it so as we
expect there's no data in it so if we
flip back to our
linux terminal window you can see where
we did the cat employee.csv
and you can see all the data we expect
to come into it and we also did our pwd
and right here you see the path you need
that full path when you are
loading data you know you can do a
browse and if i did it right now with
just the employee.csv as a name it will
work but that is a really bad habit in
general when you're loading data because
it's you don't know what else is going
on in the computer you want to do the
full path almost in all your data loads
so let's go ahead and flip back over
here to our hive shell we're working in
and the command for this is load data so
that says hey we're loading data that's
a hive command hql and we want local
data so you got to put down local in
path so now it needs to know where the
path is now to make this more legible
i'm just going to go ahead and hit enter
then we'll just paste the full path in
there which i have stored over on the
side like a good prepared demo and
you'll see here we have home cloudera
documents employee.csv so it's a whole
path for this text document in here and
we go ahead and hit enter in there and
then we have to let it know where the
data is going so now we have a source
and we need a destination and it's going
to go into the table and we'll just call
it employee we'll just match the table
in there and because i wanted to execute
we put the semicolon on the end it goes
ahead and executes all three lines now
if we go back if you remember we did the
select star from employee just using the
up arrow to page through my different
commands i've already typed in you can
see right here we have as we expect we
have rows sam mike and nick and we have
all their information showing in our
four rows and then let's go ahead and do
uh select
and count let's look at a couple of
these different select options you can
do we're going to count everything from
employee now this is kind of interesting
because the first one just pops up with
the basic select because it doesn't need
to go through the full map reduce phase
but when you start doing a count it does
go through the full map redo setup in
the hive and hadoop and because i'm
doing this demo on a single node
cloudera virtual box on top of a windows
10 all the benefits of running it on a
cluster are gone and instead it's now
going through all those added layers so
it takes longer to run you know like i
said
when you do a single node as i said
earlier it doesn't do any good as an
actual distribution because you're only
running it on one computer and then
you've added all these different layers
to run it and we see it comes up with
four and that's what we expect we have
four rows we expect four at the end and
if you remember from our cheat sheet
which we brought up here from hortons
it's a pretty good one there's all these
different commands we can do we'll look
at one more command where we do the uh
what they call sub queries right down
here because that's really common to do
a lot of sub queries and so we'll do
select
star or all different columns from
employee now if we weren't using the
office database it would look like this
from office dot employee and either one
will work on this particular one because
we have office set as a default on there
so from office employee and then the
command where creates a subset and in
this case we want to know where the
salary is greater than 25
000. there we go and of course we end
with our semicolon and if we run this
query you can see it pops up and there's
our salaries of people top earners we
have rose and i t and mike and hr kudos
to them of course they're fictional i
don't actually we don't actually have a
rows and a mic in those positions or
maybe we do so finally we want to go
ahead and do is we're done with this
table now remember you're dealing with a
data warehouse so you usually don't do a
lot of dropping of tables and
databases but we're going to go ahead
and drop this table here before we drop
it one more quick note is we can change
it so what we're going to do is we're
going to alter table office employee and
we want to go ahead and rename it
there's some other commands you can do
in here but renames pretty common and
we're going to rename it to
and it's going to stay in office and uh
it turns out one of our shareholders
really doesn't like the word employee he
wants employees plural it's a big deal
to him so let's go ahead and change that
name for the table it's that easy
because it's just changing the metadata
on there and now if we do show
tables you'll see we now have employees
not employee and then at this point
maybe we're doing some house cleaning
because this is all practice so we're
going to go ahead and drop table and
we'll drop table employees because we
changed the name in there so if we did
employee just give us an error and now
if we do show tables you'll see all the
tables are gone now the next thing we
want to go and take a look at and we're
going to walk back through the loading
of data uh just real quick because we're
going to load two tables in here and let
me just float back to our terminal
window so we can see what those tables
are that we're loading and so up here we
have customer we have a customer
file and we have an order file we want
to go ahead and put the customers and
the orders into here so those are the
two we're doing and of course it's
always nice to see what you're working
with so let's do our cat
customer.csv we can always do g edit but
we don't really need to edit these we
just want to take a look at the data in
customer and important in here is again
we have a header so we have to skip a
line comma separated
nothing odd with the data we have our
schema which is
integer string integer string integer so
you know you'd want to take that note
that down or flip back and forth when
you're doing it and then let's go ahead
and do cat order dot csv and we can see
we have oid which i'm guessing is the
order id we have a date up something new
we've done integers and strings but we
haven't done date when you're importing
new and you never worked with the date
date's always one of the more trickier
fields to port in when that's true of
just about any scripting language i've
worked with all of them have their own
idea of how date's supposed to be
formatted what the default is this
particular format or it's year and it
has all four
digits dash month two digits dash day is
the standard import for the hive so
you'll have to look up and see what the
different formats are if you're going to
do a different format in there coming in
or you're not able to pre-process the
data but this would be a pre-processing
of the data thing coming in if you
remember correctly from our edel which
is uh e just in case you weren't able to
hear me last time etl which stands for
extract transform then load so you want
to make sure you're transforming this
data before it gets into here and so
we're going to go ahead and bring
both this data in here and really we're
doing this so we can show you the basic
join there is if you remember from our
setup merge join all kinds of different
things you can do but joining different
data sets is so common so it's really
important to know how to do this we need
to go ahead and bring in these two data
sets and you can see where i just
created a table customer here's our
schema the integer name age address
salary here's our delimited by commas
and our table properties where we skip a
line well let's go ahead and load the
data first and then we'll do that with
our order and let's go ahead and put
that in here and i've got it split into
three lines so you can see it easily
we've got load data local in path so we
know we're loading data we know it's
local and we have the path here's the
complete path for um oops this is
supposed to be order csv grab the wrong
one uh of course it's going to give me
errors because you can't recreate the
same table on there and here we go
create table here's our
integer date customer the basic setup
that we had coming in here for our
schema row format commas table
properties skip header line and then
finally let's load the data into
our order table load data local in path
home cloudera documents order.csv into
table order now if we did everything
right we should be able to do select
star from customer and you can see we
have all seven customers and then we can
do select star from order and we have uh
four orders uh so this is just like a
quick frame a lot of times when you have
your customer databases in business you
have thousands of customers from years
and years and some of them you know they
move they close their business they
change names all kinds of things happen
uh so we want to do is we want to go
ahead and find just the information
connected to these orders and who's
connected to them and so let's go ahead
and do it's a select because we're going
to display information so select and
this is kind of interesting we're going
to do c dot id
and i'm going to define c as customer as
a customer table in just a minute then
we're going to do c dot name and again
we're going to define the c c dot age so
this means from the customer we want to
know their id their name their age and
then you know i'd also like to know the
order amount uh so let's do o for dot
amount and then this is where we need to
go ahead and define what we're doing and
i'll go and capitalize from customer so
we're going to take the customer table
in here and we're going to name it c
that's where the c comes from so that's
a customer table c and we want to join
order as o that's where our o comes from
so the o dot amount is what we're
joining in there and then we want to do
this on we gotta tell it how to connect
the two tables c dot id equals o dot
customer underscore id so now we know
how they're joined and remember we have
seven customers in here we have four
orders and as it processes we should get
a return of four different names joined
together and they're joined based on of
course the orders on there and once
we're done we now have the order number
the person who made the order their age
and the amount of the order which came
from the order table so you have your
different information you can see how
the join works here very common use of
tables and hql and sql and let's do one
more thing with our database and then
i'll show you a couple other hive
commands and let's go ahead and do a
drop and we're going to drop database
office
and if you're looking at this and you uh
remember from earlier this will give me
an error and let's see what that looks
like it says fail to execute exception
one or more tables exist so if you
remember from before you can't just drop
a database unless you tell it to cascade
that lets it know i don't care how many
tables are in it let's get rid of it and
in hadoop since it's an our it's a
warehouse a data warehouse usually don't
do a lot of dropping maybe at the
beginning when you're developing the
schemas and you realize you messed up
you might drop some stuff but down the
road you're really just adding commodity
machines to pick up so you can store
more stuff on it so you usually don't do
a lot of database dropping and some
other fun commands to know is you can do
select round 2.3 is round value you can
do a round off in
hive we can do as floor value which is
going to give us a 2 so it turns it into
an integer versus a float it goes down
you know basically truncates it but it
goes down and we can also do ceiling
which is going to round it up so we're
looking for the next integer above
there's a few commands we didn't show in
here because we're on a single node as
as an admin to help spediate the process
you usually add in partitions for the
data and buckets
you can't do that on a single node
because the when you add a partition it
partitions it across separate nodes but
beyond that you can see that it's very
straightforward we have sql coming in
and all your basic queries that are in
sql are very similar to hql what exactly
is pick pig is a scripting platform that
runs on hadoop clusters designed to
process and analyze large data sets and
so you have your pig which uses sql like
queries they're definitely not sql but
some of them resemble sql queries and
then we use that to analyze our data pig
operates on various types of data like
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data let's take a closer
look at mapreduce versus hive versus pig
so we start with a compiled language
your mapreduce and we have hive which is
your sql like query and then we have pig
which is a scripting language it has
some similarities to sql but it has a
lot of its own stuff remember sql like
query which is what hive is based off
looks for structured data and so when
you get into scripting languages like
pig now we're dealing more with
semi-structured and even unstructured
data with a hadoop map reduced we have a
need to write long complex codes with
hive no need to write complex codes you
could just put it in a simple sql query
or hql hive ql and in pig no need to
write complex codes as we have piglet
now remember in the map reduce it can
produce structured semi-structured and
unstructured data and as i mentioned
before hive can process only structured
data think rows and columns where pig
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data you can think of
structured data as rows and columns
semi-structured as your html xml
documents like you have on your web
pages and unstructured could be anything
from groups of documents and written
format twitter tweets any of those
things come in as very unstructured data
and with our hadoop map reduce we have a
lower level of abstraction with both
hive and pig we have a higher level
abstraction so it's much more easy for
someone to use without having to dive in
deep and write a very lengthy map reduce
code and those map and reduce codes can
take 70 80 lines of code when you can do
the same thing in one or two lines with
high over pig this is the advantage pig
has over hive it can process only
structured data and hive while in pig it
can process structured semi-structured
and unstructured data some other
features to know that separates the
different query languages is we look at
map and reduce mapreduce supports
partitioning features as does hive pig
no concept of partitioning in picks it
doesn't support your partitioning
feature your partitioning features allow
you to partition the data in such a way
that it can be queried quicker you're
not able to do that in pig mapreduce
uses java and python while hive uses an
sql like query language known as hive ql
or hql pig latin is used which is a
procedural data flow language mapreduce
is used by programmers pretty much as
straightforward on java hive is used by
data analysts pig is used by researchers
and programmers certainly there's a lot
of mix between all three programmers
have been known to go in and use a hive
for quick query and anybody's been able
to use pig for quick query or research
under map and reduce code performance is
really good under hive code performance
is lesser than map and reduce in pig
under pig code performance is lesser
than mapreduce but better than hive so
if we're going to look at speed and time
the map reduce is going to be the
fastest performance on all of those
where pig will have second and high
follows in the back let's look at
components of pig pig has two main
components we have pig latin pig latin
is the procedural data flow language
used in pig to analyze data it is easy
to program using pig latin it is similar
to sql and then we have the runtime
engine runtime engine represents the
execution environment created to run pig
latin programs it is also a compiler
that produces mapreduce programs uses
hdfs or your hadoop file system for
storing and retrieving data and as we
dig deeper into the pig architecture
we'll see that we have pig latin scripts
programmers write a script in piglet to
analyze data using pig then you have the
grunt shell and it actually says grunt
when we start it up and we'll show you
that here in a little bit which goes
into the pig server and this is where we
have our parser parser checks the syntax
of the pig script after checking the
output will be a dag directed acylic
graph and then we have an optimizer
which optimizes after your dag your
logical plan is passed to the logical
optimizer where an optimization takes
place finally the compiler converts the
dag into map reduce jobs and then that
is executed on the map reduce under the
execution engine the results are
displayed using dump statement and
stored in hdfs using store statement and
again we'll show you that um the kind of
end you always want to execute
everything once you've created it and so
dump is kind of our execution statement
and you can see right here as we were
talking about earlier once we get to the
execution engine and it's coded into
mapreduce then the map reduce processes
it onto the hdfs
working of pig pig latin script is
written by the users so you have low
data and write pig script and pig
operations so we look at the working of
pig pig latin script is written by the
users there's step one we load data and
write pig script and step two in this
step all the pig operations are
performed by parser optimizer and
compiler so we go into the pig
operations and then we get to step three
execution of the plan in this stage the
results are shown on the screen
otherwise stored in the hdfs as per the
code so it might be of a small amount of
data you're reducing it to and you want
to put that on the screen or you might
be converting a huge amount of data
which you want to put back into the
hadoop file system for other use let's
take a look at the pig latin data model
the data model of pig latin helps pig to
handle various types of data for example
we have atom rob or 50. atom represents
any single value of primitive data type
in pig latin like integer float string
it is stored as a string tuple so we go
from our atom which are most basic
things so if you look at just rob or
just 50 that's an atom that's our most
basic object we have in pig latin then
you have a tuple tuple represents
sequence of fields that can be of any
data type it is the same as a row in
rdbms for example a set of data from a
single row and you can see here we have
rob comma five and you can imagine with
many of our other examples we've used
you might have the id number the name
where they live their age their date of
starting the job that would all be one
row and stored as a tuple and then we
create a bag a bag is a collection of
tuples it is the same as a table in
rdbms and is represented by brackets and
you can see here we have our table with
rob5 mic 10 and we also have a map a map
is a set of key value pairs key is of
character array type and a value can be
of any type it is represented by the
brackets and so we have name and age
where the key value is mic in 10. pig
latin is a fully nestable data model
that means one data type can be nested
within another here's a diagram
representation of pig latin data model
and in this particular example we have
basically an id number a name and age
and a place and we break this apart we
look at this model from pig latin
perspective we start with our field and
if you remember a field contains
basically an atom it is one
particular data type and the atom is
stored as a string which then converts
it into either an integer or number or
character string next we have our tuple
and in this case you can see that it
represents a row so our tuple would be
three comma joe comma 29 comma
california and finally we have our bag
which contains three rows in it in this
particular example let's take a quick
look at pig execution modes pig works in
two execution modes depending on where
the data is reciting and where the pig
script is going to run we have local
mode here the pig engine takes input
from the linux file system and the
output is stored in the same file system
local mold local mode is useful in
analyzing small data sets using pig and
we have the map reduced mode here the
pig engine directly interacts and
executes in hdfs and mapreduce in the
map reduce mode queries written in pig
latin are translated into mapreduce jobs
and are run on a hadoop cluster by
default pig runs in this mode there are
three modes in pig depending on how a
pig latin code can be written we have
our interactive mode batch mode and
embedded mode the interactive mode means
coding and executing the script line by
line when we do our example we'll be in
the interactive mode in badge mode all
scripts are coded in a file with the
extension.pig and the file is directly
executed and then there's embedded mode
pig lets its users define their own
functions udfss in a programming
language such as java so let's take a
look and see how this works in a use
case in this case use case twitter users
on twitter generate about 500 million
tweets on a daily basis the hadoop
mapreduce was used to process and
analyze this data analyzing the number
of tweets created by a user in the tweet
table was done using mapreduce and java
programming language and you can see the
problem it was difficult to perform
mapreduce operations as users were not
well versed with written complex java
codes so twitter used apache pig to
overcome these problems and let's see
how let's start with the problem
statement analyze the user table and
tweet table and find out how many tweets
are created by a person and here you can
see we have a user table we have alice
tim and john with their id numbers one
two three and we have a tweet table in
the tweet table you have your the id of
the user and then what they tweeted uh
google was a good whatever it was tennis
dot dot spacecraft olympics politics
whatever they're tweeting about the
following operations were performed for
analyzing given data first the twitter
data is loaded into the pig storage
using load command and you can see here
we have our data coming in and then
that's going into pig storage and this
data is probably on an enterprise
computer so this is actually active
twitter's going on and then it goes into
hadoop file system remember the hadoop
file system is a data warehouse for
storing data and so the first step is we
want to go ahead and load it into the
pig storage into our data storage system
the remaining operations performed are
shown below in join and group operation
the tweet and user tables are joined and
grouped using co-group command and you
can see here where we add a whole column
when we go from usernames and tweet to
the id link directly to the name so
alice was user 1 10 was 2 and john 3.
and so now they're listed with their
actual tweet the next operation is the
aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count so it's very straightforward we
just want to count how many tweets each
user is doing and finally the result
after the count operation is joined with
the user table to find out the username
and you can see here where alice had
three tim two and john one pig reduces
the complexity of the operations which
would have been lengthy using mapreduce
in joining group operation the tweet and
user tables are joined and grouped using
co-group command the next operation is
the aggregation the tweets are counted
according to the names the command used
is count the result after the count
operation is joined with the user table
to find out the username and you can see
we're talking about three lines of
script versus a mapreduce code of about
80 lines finally we could find out the
number of tweets created by a user in a
simple way so let's go quickly over some
of the features of pig that we already
went through most of these
first ease of programming as pig latin
is similar to sql lesser lines of code
need to be written short development
time as the code is simpler so we can
get our queries out rather quickly
instead of having to have a programmer
spend hours on it handles all kinds of
data like structured semi-structured and
unstructured pig lets us create
user-defined functions pig offers a
large set of operators such as join
filter and so on it allows for multiple
queries to process on parallel and
optimization and compilation is easy as
it is done automatically and internally
so enough theory let's dive in and show
you a quick demo on some of the commands
you can do in pick today's setup will
continue as we have in the last three
demos to go and use cloudera quick start
and we'll be doing this in virtualbox we
do have a tutorial in setting that up
you can send a note to our simply learn
team and then get that linked to you
once your cloudera quick start has spun
up and remember this is virtualbox we've
created a virtual machine and this
virtual machine is centos linux once
it's spun up you'll be in a full linux
system here and as you can see we have
thunderbird browser which opens up to
the hadoop basic system browser and we
can go underneath the hue where it comes
up by default if you click on the pull
down menu and go under editor you can
see there's our impala our hive
pig along with a bunch of other query
languages you can use and we're going
under pig and then once you're in pig we
can go ahead and use our command line
here and just click that little blue
button to start it up and running we
will actually be working in terminal
window and so if you're in the cloudera
quick start you can open up the terminal
window up top or if you're in your own
setup and you're logged in you can
easily use all of your commands here in
terminal window and we'll zoom in that
way you get a nice view of what's going
on there we go now for our first command
we're going to do a hadoop command and
import some data into the hadoop system
in this case a pig input and let's take
a look at this we have uh hadoop now
let's say no it's going to be a hadoop
command dfs there's actually four
variations of dfs so if you have hdfs or
whatever that's fine all four of them
point used to be different setups
underneath different things and now they
all do the same thing and we want to put
this file which in this case is under
home cloudera documents and sample and
we just want to take that and put it
into the pig input now let's take a look
at that file if i go under my document
browsers and open this up you'll see
it's got a simple id name profession and
age we have one jack engineer 25 and
that was in one of our earlier things we
had in there and so let's go ahead and
hit enter and execute this and now we've
uploaded that data and it's gone into
our pig input and then a lot of the
hadoop commands mimic the linux commands
and so you'll see we have cat as one of
our commands or we has a hyphen before
it so we execute that with hadoop dfs
hyphen cat slash pig input because
that's what we called it that's where we
put our sample csv at and we execute
this you can see from our hadoop system
it's going to go in and pull that up and
sure enough it pulls out the data file
we just put in there and then we can
simply enter the pig latin or pig editor
mode by typing in pig and we can see
here by our grunt i told you that's how
it was going to tell you were in pig
latin there's our grunt command line so
we are now in the pig shell and then
we'll go ahead and put our load command
in here and the way this works is i'm
going to have office equals load and
here's my load in this case it's going
to be pig input we have that in single
brackets you remember that's where the
data is in the hadoop file system where
we dumped it into there we're going to
using pig storage our data was separated
as with a comma so there's our comma
separator and then we have as in this
case we have an id character array name
character array profession character a
and age character ray and we're just
going to do them all as character arrays
just to keep this simple for this one
and then when i hit put this all in here
you can see that's our full command line
going in and we have our semicolon at
the end so when i hit enter it's now set
office up but it hasn't actually done
anything yet it doesn't do anything
until we do dump office so there's our
command to execute whatever we've loaded
or whatever setup we have in here and we
run that you can see it go through the
different languages and this is going
through the map reduce remember we're
not doing this locally we're doing this
on the hadoop setup and once we finished
our dump you can see we have id name
profession age and all the information
that we just dumped into our pick oh we
can now do let's say oh let's say we
have a request just for we'll keep it
simple in here but just for the name and
age and so we can go office we'll call
it each as our variable underscore each
and we'll say for each office generate
name comma h and for each means that
we're going to do this for each row and
if you're thinking map reduce you know
that this is a map function uh because
it's mapping each row and generating
name and age on here and of course we
want to go ahead and close it with a
semicolon and then once we've created
our query or the command line in here
let's go ahead and dump office
underscore each in with our semicolon
and this will go through our mapreduce
setup on here and if we were on a large
cluster the same processing time would
happen in fact it's really slow because
i have multiple things on this computer
and this particular virtual box is only
using a quarter of my processor it's
only dedicated to this and you can see
here there it is name and age and it
also included the top row since we
didn't delete that out of there or tell
it not to and that's fine for this
example but you need to be aware of
those things when you're processing a
significantly large amount of data or
any data and we can also do office and
we'll call this dsc for descending so
maybe the boss comes to you and says hey
can we order office by id descending and
of course your boss you've taught him
how to uh your shareholder it sounds a
little dragonatory we say boss you've
talked to the shareholder and you said
and you've taught them a little bit of
pig latin and they know that they can
now create office description and we can
order office by id description and of
course once we do that we have to dump
office underscore description so that
it'll actually execute and there goes
into our mapreduce it'll take just a
moment for it to come up because again
i'm running on only a quarter of my
processor and you can see we now have
our ids in descending order returned
let's also look at and this is so
important with anytime you're dealing
with big data let's create office with a
limit and you could of course do any of
this instead of with office we could do
this with office descending so you get
just the top two ids on there we're
gonna limit just to two and of course to
execute that we have to dump office
underscore limit and you can just think
of dumping your garbage into the pig pen
for the pig to eat there we go dump
office limit two and that's gonna just
limit our office to the top too and for
our output we get our first row which
had our id name profession and age and
our second row which is jack who's an
engineer let's do an filter we'll call
it office underscore filter you guessed
it equals filter office by profession
equals and keep note this is similar to
how python does it with the double equal
signs for equal for doing a true false
statement so for your logic statement
remember to use two equal signs in pig
and we're going to say it equals doctor
so we want to find out how many doctors
do we have on our list and we'll go
ahead and do our dump we're dumping all
our garbage into the pig pen and we're
letting pig take over and see what it
can find out and see who's a doctor on
our list and we find
employee id number two bob is a doctor
30 years old for this next section we're
going to cover something we see a lot
nowadays in data analysis and that's
word counting tokenization that is one
of the next big steps as we move forward
in our data analysis where we go from
say stock market analysis of highs and
lows and all the numbers to what are
people saying about companies on twitter
what are they saying on the web pages
and on facebook suddenly you need to
start counting words and finding out how
many words are totaled how many are in
the first part of the document and so on
we're going to cover a very basic word
count
example and in this case i've created a
document called wordrose.txt
and you can see here we have simplylearn
is a company supporting online learning
simply learn helps people attain their
certifications simplylearn is an online
community i love simply learn i love
programming i love data analysis and i
went and saved this into my documents
folder so we could use it and let me go
ahead and open up a new terminal window
for our word count let me go and close
the old one so we're going to go in here
and instead of doing this as pig we're
going to do pig minus x local and what
i'm doing is i'm telling the pig to
start the pig shell but we're going to
be looking at files local to our virtual
box or this centos machine and let me go
ahead and hit enter on there just
maximize this up there we go and it will
load pig up and it's going to look just
the same as the pig we were doing which
was defaulted to hot to our hadoop
system to our hdfs this is now defaulted
to the local system now we're going to
create lines we're going to load it
straight from the file remember last
time we took the hdfs and loaded it into
there and then loaded it into pig since
we're going to local we're just going to
run a local script we have lines equals
load home the actual full path home
cloudera documents and i called it
wordrose.txt
and as line as a character array so each
line and i've actually you can change
this to read each document i certainly
have done a lot of document analysis and
then you go through and do word counts
and different kind of counts in there so
once we go ahead and create our line
instead of doing the dump we're going to
go ahead and start entering all of our
different setups or each of our steps we
want to go through and let's just take a
look at this next one because the load
is straightforward we're loading from
this particular file since we're locals
loading it directly from here instead of
going into the hadoop file system and it
says as and then each line is read as a
character array now we're going to do
words equal for each of the lines
generate flat tokenize line space as
word now there's a lot of ways to do
this this is if you're a programmer
you're just splitting the line up by
spaces there's actual ways to tokenize
it you gotta look for periods
capitalization there's all kinds of
other things you play with with this but
for the most basic word count we're just
going to separate it by spaces the
flatten takes the line and just creates
a it flattens each of the words out so
this is uh we're just going to generate
a bunch of words for each line and then
each each of those words is as a word a
little confusing in there but if you
really think about it we're just going
down each line separating it out and
we're generating a list of words one
thing to note is the default for
tokenize you can just do tokenized line
without the space in there if you do
that it'll automatically tokenize it by
space you can do either one and then
we're going to do group we're going to
group it by words so we're going to
group words by word so when we we split
it up each token is a word and it's a
list of words and so we're going to
group equals group words by word so
we're going to group all the same words
together and if we're going to group
them then we want to go ahead and count
them and so for count we'll go ahead and
create a word count variable and here's
our four each so for each grouped
grouped is our line where we group all
the words in the line that are similar
we're going to generate a group and then
we're going to count the words for each
group so for each line we group the
words together we're going to generate a
group and that's going to count the
words we want to know the word count in
each of those and that comes back in our
word count and finally we want to take
this and we want to go ahead and dump
word count and this is a little bit more
what you see when you start looking at
grunt scripts you'll see right here
these these lines right here we have
each of the steps you take to get there
so we load our file for each of our
lines we're going to generate and
tokenize it into words then we're going
to take the words and we're going to
group them by same words for each group
we're going to generate a group and
we're just going to count the words so
we're going to summarize all the words
in here and let's go ahead and do our
dump word count which executes all this
and it goes through our mapreduce it's
actually a local runner you'll see down
here you start seeing where they still
have mapreduce but as a special runner
we're mapping it that's a part of each
row being counted and grouped and then
when we do the word count that's the
reducer the reducer creates these keys
and you can see i is used three times a
came up once and came up once is to
continue on down here to attain online
people company analysis simply learn
they took the top rating with four
certification so all these things are
encountered in the how many words are
used uh in data analysis this is
probably the very the beginnings of data
analysis where you might look at it and
say oh they mentioned love
three times so whatever's going on in
this post it's about love and uh what do
they love and then you might attach that
to the different objects in here so you
can see that uh pig latin is fairly easy
to use there's nothing really you know
it takes a little bit to learn the
script depending on how good your memory
is as i get older my memory leaks a
little bit more so i don't memorize it
as much but that was pretty
straightforward the script we put in
there and then it goes through the full
map reduce localized run comes out and
like i said it's very easy to use that's
why people like pig latin is because
it's intuitive one of the things i like
about pig latin is when i'm
troubleshooting when we're
troubleshooting a lot of times you're
working with a small amount of data and
you start doing one line at a time and
so i can go lines equal load and there's
my loaded text and maybe i'll just dump
lines and then it's going to run it's
going to show me all the lines that i'm
working on in the small amount of data
and that way i can test that if i got an
error on there that said oh this isn't
working maybe they'll be oh my gosh i'm
in map reduce or i'm in the basic um
grunt shell instead of the local path
grunt uh so maybe it'll generate an
error on there and you can see here it
just shows each of the lines going down
so spark real time data analysis and i
told you spark is its own animal so
we're going to touch very little on
spark as far as how big and robust it is
but we're going to talk a little bit
about spark spark is an open source
distributed computing engine for
processing and analyzing huge volumes of
real-time data so it runs 100 times
faster than map reduce map reduces the
basics of the hadoop system which is
usually set up in a java code in spark
the map reduce instead of running what
happens in map reduces it goes pulls it
into the ram writes it to the hard drive
reads it off the hard drive shuffles it
around writes it back to the hard drive
pulls it off the hard drive does its
processing and you get the impressions
going in and out of ram to the hard
drive and back up again so if you don't
have a lot of ram and you have older
computers and you don't have the ram to
process something then spark and hadoop
are going to run the same speed
otherwise spark goes hey let's keep this
all in the ram and run faster and that's
where we're talking about this provides
in-memory computation of data so it's
fast you can see the guy running through
the door there speedy versus a very slow
hadoop wandering around and it's used to
process and analyze real-time streaming
data such as stock market and baking
data so the spark can have its own stuff
going on and then it can access the
hadoop database it can pull data just
like scoop and flume do so it has all
those features in it and you can even
run spark with its own yarn outside of
hadoop there's also spark on mesos which
is another resource manager although
yarn is most commonly used and currently
spark pretty much becomes installed with
hadoop and so your spark running on top
of hadoop will use the same nodes it has
its own manager and it utilizes the ram
so you'll have both you can have the
spark on top of there and here we go you
have your driver program your spark
context it goes into your cluster
manager your yarn then you have your
worker nodes which are going to be
executing tasks and cash and it's
important to remember when you're
running the spark setup even though
these are commodity machines we're still
usually a lot of them are like 128
gigabytes of ram so that spark can run
these high-end processes certainly if
it's not accessed very much and you're
building a
hadoop cluster you could drop that ram
way down if you're doing just queries
without any kind of processing on there
and you're not doing a lot of queries
but you know generally spark you're
looking at higher end they're still
commodity machines to do your work and
now we get into the hadoop machine
learning and so machine learning is its
own animal i keep saying that these are
all kind of unique things howt is being
phased out i mean people still use it
it's still important if you can write
your basic machine learning that has
most of the tools in there you certainly
can do it in mahout and how it again
writes to the hard drive reads from the
hard drive you can do all that in spark
and it's faster because it's just in
ramp and so spark has its own machine
learning tools in it you can also use pi
spark which then accesses all the
different python tools and there's
there's just so many tools you can dump
into spark the hout is very limited but
it's also very basic which in itself can
be really good sometimes simple is
better so how it is used to create
scalable and distributed machine
learning algorithms so here we have our
major environment it builds a machine
learning application so you're doing
linear regression you're doing
clustering you're doing classification
models it has a library that contains
inbuilt algorithms for all of these and
then it has collaborative filtering and
again there's our classification and
there's our clustering regression so you
have your different machine learning
tools we can easily classify a large
amount of data using the hout so this
brings us to the next set of tools we
have or the next tool which is the
apache ambari a bar is an open source
tool responsible for keeping track of
running applications and their statuses
think of this as like a traffic cop more
like a security guard you can open it up
and see what's going on and so the
apache ambari manages monitors and
provisions hadoop clusters provides a
central management service to start stop
and configure hadoop services so again
it's like a traffic cop hey stop over
there start keep going hey what's going
on over that area in the through lane on
the high speed freeway and you can open
this up and you have a really easy view
of what's going on and so you can see
right here you have the ambari web the
ambari web is what you're looking at
that's your interface that you've logged
into the ambari server this will be
usually on the master node it's usually
if you're going to install a bar you
might as well just install it on the
same node and it connects up to the
database and then it has agents and each
agent takes a look and see what's going
on with its host server if you're going
to have uh two more systems and we
talked about spark streaming there's
also kafka and apache for streaming data
coming in and kafka is distributed
streaming platform to store and process
streams of records and it's written in
scala builds real-time screaming data
pipelines that reliably get data between
applications builds real-time streaming
applications that transforms data into
streams so it kind of goes both ways on
there so kafka uses a messaging system
for transferring data from one
application to another so we have our
sender we have our message queue and
then we have our receiver pretty
straightforward very solid setup on
there with the kafka patchy storm storm
is a processing engine that processes
real-time streeting at a very high speed
and it's written in closure they utilize
the function based programming style of
closure and it's based on lisp to give
it the speed that's why apache storm is
built on there so you could think of
kafka as a slow moving very solid
communication network where storm is
looking at the real-time data and
grabbing that streaming data that's
coming in fast so it has a ability to
process over a million jobs in a
fraction of seconds on a node so it's
massive it can really reach out there
and grab the data and it's integrated
with hadoop to harness higher thorough
puts so this is the two big things about
storm if you are polling i think they
mentioned stock coming in or something
like that where you're looking for the
latest data popping up storm is a really
powerful tool to use for that so we've
looked at a couple more tools for
bringing data in we probably should talk
a little bit about security security has
in hadoop has the apache ranger and
apache knox are the two most popular one
and the ranger the apache ranger ranger
is a framework to enable monitor and
manage data securities across the hadoop
platform so the first thing it does is
it provides centralized security
administration to manage all security
related tasks the second thing it does
is it has a standardized authorization
across all hadoop components and third
it uses enhanced support for different
authorization methods role based access
control attribute based access control
etc so your apache ranger can go in
there and your administrator coming in
there can now very easily monitor who
has what rights and what they can do and
what they can access so there's also
apache knox nox is an application
gateway for interacting with the rest
apis and the uis of hadoop developers
and so we have our application
programmer interfaces our user
interfaces and we talk about rest apis
this means we're pulling this is looking
at the actual data coming in what
applications are going on so if you have
an application where people are pulling
data off of the hadoop system or pushing
data into the dupe system the nox is
going to be on that setup it delivers
three groups of user facing services one
proxy services provides access to hadoop
via proxying the http request
two authentication services
authentication for rest api access and
web sso flow for user interfaces so
there's our rest and finally client
services client development can be done
with the scripting through dsl or using
the knox shell classes so the first one
is if you have a website coming in and
out your http request again your three
different services are what's coming in
and out of the hadoop file system so
there's a couple of the security setups
let's go ahead and take a look at
workflow system the uzi and there's some
other ones out there uzi is the one
that's specific to hadoop there's also
like a zookeeper out there and some
other ones uzi's pretty good uzi is a
workflow scheduler system to manage
hadoop jobs and so you have a workflow
engine and a coordinator engine so it
consists of two parts what's going on
and coordinating what's going on and uh
directed a slick graph dags which
specifies a sequence of actions to be
executed these consist of workflow jobs
triggered by time and data available and
if you're not familiar with directed
acylic graphs or dags or whatever
terminology you want to throw at this
this is basically a flow chart you start
with process a then the next process
would be process b when process a is
done and it might be that process c can
only be done when process d e and f are
done so you want to be able to control
this you don't want it to
process the machine learning script and
then pull the data in that you want to
process it on you want to make sure it's
going in the right order so these
consist of workflow jobs and they're
triggered by time and data availability
so maybe you're pulling stocks in the
middle of the night and once the stock
is all pulled so there's our time
sequence it says hey they've been posted
on the other websites they post them
usually after the stock market closes
the highs and lows and everything then
once that data has been brought in you
know in a time specifics bringing the
data in a certain time once the data is
available then we want to trigger our
machine learning script for what's going
to happen next and so we can see here we
have start our mapreduce program our
action node and it begins and either we
have a success then we notify the client
of success usually an email sent out in
successful completion quick demo on
hbase you can see some hands-on let's
start with an introduction to hbase back
in the days data used to be less and was
mostly structured you see we have
structured data here we usually had it
like in a database where you had
every field was exactly the correct
length so if you had a name filled that
is exactly 32 characters remember the
old access database and microsoft uh the
files are small if we had you know
hundreds of people in one database that
was considered big data this data could
be easily stored in relational database
or rdbms when we talk about relational
database you might think of oracle you
might think of sql microsoft sql mysql
all of these have evolved even from back
then to do a lot more today than they
did but they still fall short in a lot
of ways and they're all examples of an
rdms or relationship database then
internet evolved and huge volumes of
structured and semi-structured data got
generated and you can see here with the
semi-structured data we have email if
you look at my spam folder you know
we're talking about all the html pages
xml which is a lot of time is displayed
on our html and help desk pages json all
of this really has just even in the last
each year it almost doubles from the
year before how much of this is
generated so storing and processing this
data on an rdbms has become a major
problem and so the solution is we use
apache age base apache hbase was the
solution for this let's take a look at
the history the hbase history and we
look at the hbase history we're going to
start back in 2006 november google
released a paper on big table and then
in 2017 just a few months later hbase
prototype was created as a hadoop
contribution later on in the year 2007
in october first usable hbase along with
the hadoop .15 was released and then in
january of 2008 hbase became the
subproject of hadoop and later on that
year in october all the way into
september the next year hbase was
released the 0.81 version the 0.19
version and 0.20 and finally in may of
2010 hbase became apache top level
project and so you can see in the course
of about four years hbase started off as
just an idea on paper and has evolved
all the way till
2010 as a solid project under the apache
and since 2010 has continued to evolve
and grow as a major source for storing
data in semi-structured data so what is
hbase hbase is a column oriented
database management system derived from
google's nosql database bigtable that
runs on top of the hadoop file system or
the hdfs it's an open source project
that is horizontally scalable and that's
very important to understand that you
don't have to buy a bunch of huge
expensive computers you're expanding it
by continually adding commodity machines
and so it's a linear cost expansion as
opposed to being exponential no sql
database written in java which permits
faster querying so java is the back end
for the hbase setup and it's well suited
for sparse data sets so it can contain
missing or n a values and this doesn't
boggle it down like it would another
database
companies using hbase so let's take a
look and see who is using this uh nosql
database for their servers and for
storing their data and we have
hortonworks which isn't a surprise
because they're one of the like cloudera
hortonworks they are behind hadoop and
one of the big developments and backing
of it and of course apache hbase is the
open source behind it and we have
capital one as banks you also see bank
of america where they're collecting
information on people and tracking it so
their information might be very sparse
they might have one bank way back when
they collected information as far as the
person's family and what their income
for the whole family is and their
personal income and maybe another one
doesn't collect the family income as you
start seeing where you have data that is
uh very difficult to store where it's
missing a bunch of data hubspot's using
it facebook
certainly all of your facebook twitter
most of your social medias are using it
and then of course there's jpmorgan
chase and company another bank that uses
the hbase as their data warehouse for
nosql let's take a look at an hbase use
case so we can dig a little bit more
into it to see how it functions
telecommunication company that provides
mobile voice and multimedia services
across china the china mobile and china
mobile they generate billions of call
detailed records or cdr and so these
cdrs and all these records are these
calls and how long they are and
different aspects of the call maybe the
tower they're broadcasted from all that
is being recorded so they can track it a
traditional database systems were unable
to scale up to the vast volumes of data
and provide a cost-effective solution no
good so storing and real-time analysis
of billions of call records was a major
problem for this company solution apache
hbase hbase stores billions of rows of
detailed call records hbc performs fast
processing of records using sql queries
so you can mix your sql and nosql
queries and usually just say no sql
queries because of the way the query
works applications of hbase one of them
would be in the medical industry hbase
is used for storing genome sequences
storing disease history of people of an
area and you can imagine how sparse that
is as far as both of those a genome
sequence might be only have pieces to it
that each person is unique or is unique
to different people and the same thing
with disease you really don't need a
column for every possible disease a
person could get you just want to know
what those diseases those people have
had to deal with in that area e-commerce
hbase is used for storing logs about
customer search history performs
analytics and target advertisement for
better business insights sports hba
stores match details in the history of
each match uses this data for better
prediction so when we look at hbase we
all want to know what's the difference
between hbase versus rdbms that is a
relational database management system
hbase versus rdbms so the hbase does not
have a fixed schema it's schema-less
defines only column families and we'll
show you what that means later on rdbms
has a fixed schema which describes the
structure of the tables and you can
think of this as you have a row and you
have columns and each column is a very
specific structure how much data can go
in there and what it does with the hbase
it works well with structured and
semi-structured data with the rdbms it
works only well with structured data
with the age base it can have
denormalized data it can contain missing
or no values with the rdbms it can store
only normalized data now you can still
store a null value in the rdbms but it
still takes up the same space as if
you're storing a regular value in many
cases and it also for the hbase is built
for y tables it can be scaled
horizontally for instance if you were
doing a tokenizer of words and word
clusters you might have 1.4 million
different words that you're pulling up
and combinations of words so with an
rdbms it's built for thin tables that
are hard to scale you don't want to
store 1.4 million columns in your sql
it's going to crash and it's going to be
very hard to do searches with the age
base it only stores that data which is
part of whatever row you're working on
let's look at some of the features of
the hbase it's scalable data can be
scaled across various nodes as it is
stored in the hdfs and i always think
about this it's a linear add-on for each
terabyte of data i'm adding on roughly a
thousand dollars in commodity computing
with an enterprise machine we're looking
at about 10 000 at the lower end for
each terabyte of data and that includes
all your backup and redundancy so it's a
big difference it's like a tenth of the
cost to store it across the hbase it has
automatic failure support right ahead
log across clusters which provides
automatic support against failure
consistent read and write hbase provides
consistent read and write of the data
it's a java api for client access
provides easy to use java api for
clients block cache and bloom filters so
the hbase supports block caching and
bloom filters for high volume query
optimization let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase storage hbase column
oriented storage and i told you we're
going to look into this to see how it
stores the data and here you can see you
have a row key this is really one of the
important references is each row has to
have its own key or your row id and then
you have your column family and in here
you can see we have column family one
column family two column family three
and you have your column qualifiers so
you can have in column family one you
can have three columns in there and
there might not be any data in that so
when you go into column family one and
do a query for every column that
contains a certain thing that row might
not have anything in there and not be
queried where in column family two maybe
you have column one filled out and
column three filled out and so on and so
forth and then each cell is connected to
the row where the data is actually
stored let's take a look at this at what
it looks like when you fill the data in
so in here we have a row key with a row
id and we have our employee id one two
three that's pretty straightforward you
probably would even have that on an sql
server and then you have your column
family this is where it starts really
separating out your column family might
have personal data and under personal
data you would have name city age you
might have a lot more than just that you
might have number of children you might
have degree all those kinds of different
things that go into personal data and
some of them might be missing you might
only have the name and the age of an
employee you might only have the name
the city and how many children and not
the age and so you can see with the
personal data you can now collect a
large variety of data and stored in the
hbase very easily and then maybe you
have a family of professional data your
designation your salary all the stuff
that the employee is doing for you in
that company let's dig a little deeper
into the hbase architecture and so you
can see here what looks to be a
complicated chart it's not as
complicated as you think from the apache
a space we have the zookeeper which is
used for monitoring what's going on and
you have your h master this is the hbase
master assigns regions and load
balancing and then underneath the region
or the hbase master then under the h
master or hbase master you have your
reader server serves data for read and
write and the region server which is all
your different computers you have in
your hadoop cluster you'll have a region
an h log you'll have a store memory
store and then you have your different
files for h file that are stored on
there and those are separated across the
different computers and that's all part
of the hdfs storage system so we look at
the architectural components or regions
and we're looking at we're drilling down
a little bit hbase tables are divided
horizontally by row so you have a key
range into regions so each of those ids
you might have ids 1 to 20. 21 to 50 or
whatever they are regions are assigned
to the nodes in the cluster called
region servers a region contains all
rows in the table between the regions
start key and the end key again 1 to 10
11 to 20 and so forth these servers
serve data for read and write and you
can see here we have the client and the
get and the git sends it out and it
finds out where that start if it's
between which start keys and n keys and
then it pulls the data from that
different region server and so the
region sign data definition language
operation create delete are handled by
the h-master so the h-master is telling
it what are we doing with this data
what's going out there assigning and
reassigning regions for recovery or load
balancing and monitoring all servers so
that's also part of it so you know if
your ids if you have 500 ids across
three servers you're not going to put
400 ids on server 1 and 100 on the
server 2 and leaves region 3 and region
4 empty you're going to split that up
and that's all handled by the h-master
and you can see here monitors region
servers assigns regions to region
servers assigns regions to reason
servers and so forth and so forth hbase
has a distributed environment where
h-master alone is not sufficient to
manage everything hence zookeeper was
introduced it works with h-master so you
have an active h-master which sends a
heartbeat signal to zookeeper indicating
that it's active and the zookeeper also
has a heartbeat to the region servers so
the region servers send their status to
zoo keeper indicating they are ready for
read and write operation inactive server
acts as a backup if the active hmaster
fails it'll come to the rescue active h
master and region servers connect with a
session two zookeeper so you see your
activate master selection your region
server session they're all looking at
the zookeeper keeping that pulse an
active hmas region server connects with
a session to the zookeeper and you can
see here where we have ephemeral nodes
for active sessions via heartbeats to
indicate that the region servers are up
and running so let's take a look at
hbase read or write going on there's a
special hbase catalog table called the
meta table which holds the location of
the regions in the cluster here's what
happens the first time a client reads or
writes data to hbase the client gets the
region server the host the meta table
from zookeeper and you can see right
here the client has a request for your
region server and goes hey zookeeper can
you handle this the zookeeper takes a
look at it and goes ah metal location is
stored in zookeeper so it looks at his
metadata on there and then the metadata
table location is sent back to the
client the client will query the meta
server to get the region server
corresponding to the row key if it wants
to access the client caches this
information along with the meta table
location and you can see here the client
going back and forth to the region
server with the information and it might
be going across multiple region servers
depending on what you're querying so we
get the region server for row key from
the meta table that's where that row key
comes in and says hey this is where
we're going with this and so once it
gets a row key from the corresponding
region server we can now put row or get
row from that region server let's take a
look at the hbase meta table special
hbase catalog table that maintains a
list of all the region servers in the
hbase storage system so you see here we
have the meta table we have a row key
and a value table key region region
server so the meta table is used to find
the region for the given table key and
you can see down here you know meta
table comes in is going to fire out
where it's going with the region server
and we look a little closer at the right
mechanism in hbase we have right ahead
log or wall as you abbreviate it kind of
a way to remember wall is right ahead
log is a file used to store new data
that is yet to be put on permanent
storage it is used for recovery in the
case of failure so you can see here
where the client comes in and it
literally puts the new data coming in
into this kind of temporary storage or
the wall on there once it's gone into
the wall then the memory store memstor
is the right cache that stores a new
data that has not yet been written to
disk there is one mem store per column
family per region and once we've done
that we have three ack once the data is
placed in mems store the client then
receives the acknowledgement when the
mems store reaches the threshold it
dumps or commits the data into h file as
you can see right here we've taken our
our gun into the wall the wall then
source it into the different memory
stores uh and then the memory stores it
says hey we've reached we're ready to
dump that into our h files and then it
moves it into the h files h files store
the rows as data as stored key value on
disk so here we've done a lot of theory
let's dive in and just take a look and
see what some of these commands look
like and what happens in our age base
when we're manipulating a nosql setup
[Music]
so if you're learning a new setup it's
always good to start with where is this
coming from it's open source by apache
and you can go to
hbase.apache.org and you'll see that it
has a lot of information you can
actually download the hbase separate
from the hadoop although most people
just install the hadoop because it's
bundled with it and if you go in here
you'll find a reference guide and you
can go through the apache reference
guide and there's a number of things to
look at but we're going to be going
through apache hbase shell that's what
we're going to be working with and
there's a lot of other interfaces on the
setup and you can look up a lot of the
different commands on here so we go into
the apache hbase reference guide we go
down to read hbase shell commands from a
command file you can see here where it
gives you different options of formats
for putting the data in and listing the
data certainly can also create files and
scripts to do this too but we're going
to look at the basics we're going to go
through this on a basic hbase shell and
one last thing to look at is of course
if you continue down the setup you can
see here where they have more detail as
far as how to create and how to get to
your data on your hbase now i will be
working in a virtual box and this is by
oracle you can download the oracle
virtual box you can put a note in below
for the youtube as we did have a
previous session on setting up virtual
setup to run your hadoop system in there
i'm using the cloudera quick start
installed in here there's hortons you
can also use the amazon web service
there's a number of options for trying
this out in this case we have cloudera
on the oracle virtualbox the virtual box
has linux centos installed on it and
then the hadoop has all the different
hadoop flavors including hbase and i
bring this up because my computer is a
windows 10 the operating system of the
virtualbox is linux and we're looking at
the hbase data warehouse and so we have
three very different entities all
running on my computer and that can be
confusing if it's the first time in and
working with this kind of setup now
you'll notice in our cloudera setup they
actually have some hbase monitoring so i
can go underneath here and click on
hbase and master and it'll tell me
what's going on with my region servers
it'll tell me what's going on with our
backup tables right now i don't have any
user tables because we haven't created
any and this is only a single node and a
single hbase tour so you're not going to
expect anything too extensive in here
since this is for practice and education
and perhaps testing out package you're
working on it's not for really you can
deploy cloudera of course but when you
talk about a quick start or a single
node setup that's what it's really for
so we can go through all the different
hbase and you'll see all kinds of
different information with zookeeper if
you saw it flash by down here what
version we're working in since zookeeper
is part of the hbase setup where we want
to go is we want to open up a terminal
window and in cloudera it happens to be
up at the top and when you click on here
you'll see your cloudera terminal window
open and let me just expand this so we
have a nice full screen and then i'm
also going to zoom in that way i have a
nice big picture and you can see what
i'm typing what's going on and to open
up your hbase shell simply type hbase
shell to get in and hit enter and you'll
see it takes just a moment to load and
we'll be in our age based shell for
doing hbase commands once we've gotten
into our hbase shell you'll see it'll
have the hbase prompt information ahead
of it we can do something simple like
list this is going to list whatever
tables we have and it so happens that
there's a base table that comes with
hbase now we can go ahead and create and
i'm going to type in just create what's
nice about this is it's going to throw
me kind of a it's going to say hey
there's no just straight create but it
does come up and tell me all these
different formats we can use for create
so we can create our table and one of
our families you can add splits names
versions all kinds of things you can do
with this let's just start with a very
basic one on here and let's go ahead and
create and we'll call it new
table now let's just call it new tbl for
table new table and then we also want to
do let's do knowledge so let's take a
look at this i'm creating a new table
and it's going to have a family of
knowledge in it and let me hit enter
it's going to come up it's going to take
it a second to go ahead and create it
now we have our new table in here so if
i go list you'll now see table and new
table so you can now see that we have
the new table and of course the default
table that's set up in here and we can
do something like uh describe we can
describe and then we're going to do new
tbl and when we describe it's going to
come up it's going to say hey name i
have knowledge data block encoding none
bloom filter row or replication scope
version all the different information
you need new minimum version 0 forever
deleted cells false block size in memory
you can look this stuff up on apache.org
to really track it down one of the
things that's important to note is
versions so you have your different
versions of the data that's stored and
that's always important to understand
that we might talk about that a little
bit later on and then we have to
describe it we can also do a status the
status says i have one active master
going on that's our hbase as a whole we
can do status
summary it should do the same thing as
status so we got the same thing coming
up and now that we've created let's go
ahead and put something in it so we're
going to put new tbl and then we want
row one you know what before i even do
this let's just type in put and you can
see when i type in put it gives us like
a lot of different options of how it
works and different ways of formatting
our data as it goes in and all of them
usually begin with the new table new tbl
then we have in this case we'll call it
row one and then we'll have knowledge
remember we created knowledge already
and we'll do knowledge sports and then
in knowledge and sports we're going to
set that equal to cricket so we're going
to put underneath this uh our knowledge
setup that we have a thing called sports
in there and we'll see what this looks
like in just a second let's go ahead and
put in we'll do a couple of these let's
see let's do another row one and this
time set of sports let's do
science you know this person not only
you know we have row one which is both
knowledgeable and cricket and also in
chemistry so it's a chemist who plays
cricket in row one and uh let's see if
we have let's do another row one just to
keep it going and we'll do science in
this case let's do physics not only in
chemistry but also a physicist i have
quite a joy in physics myself so here we
go we have row one there we go and then
let's do uh row two let's see what that
looks like when you start putting in row
two and in row two this person is has
knowledge in economics this is a master
of business and how or maybe it's global
economics maybe it's just for the
business and how it fits in with the
country's economics and we call it macro
economics so i guess it is for the whole
country there so we have knowledge
economics macroeconomics and then let's
just do one more we'll keep it as row
two and this time our economist is also
a musician so we'll put music and they
happen to have knowledge and they enjoy
oh let's do pop music they're into the
current pop music going on so we've
loaded our database and you'll see we
have two rows row one and row two in
here and we can do is we can list the
contents of our database by simply doing
scan scan and then let's just do scan by
itself so you can see how that looks you
can always just type in there and it
tells you all the different setups you
can do with scan and how it works in
this case we want to do scan new tbl and
in our scan new tbl we have row one row
one row two row two and you'll see row
one has a column called knowledge
science time step value crickets value
physics so it has information as when it
was created when the time stamp is row
one also has knowledge sports and a
value of cricket so we have sports and
science and this is interesting because
if you remember up here we also gave it
originally we told it to come in here
and have chemistry we had science
chemistry and science physics and we
come down here i don't see the chemistry
why because we've now replaced chemistry
with physics so the new value is physics
on here let me go ahead and clear down a
little bit and in this we're going to
ask the question is enabled new
table when i hit enter in here you can
see it comes out true and then we'll go
ahead and disable it let's go ahead and
disable new table make sure i have our
quotes around it and now that we've
disabled it what happens when we do the
scan when we do the scan new table and
hit enter you're going to see that we
get an error coming up so once it's
disabled you can't do anything with it
until we re-enable it now before we
enable the table let's do an alteration
on it and here's our new table and this
should look a little familiar because
it's very similar to create we'll call
this test info we'll hit enter in there
it'll take just a moment for updating
and then we want to go ahead and enable
it so let's go ahead and enable our new
table so it's back up and running and
then we want to describe describe
new table and we come in here you'll now
see we have name knowledge and under
there we have our data encoding and all
the information under knowledge and then
we also have down below test info so now
we have the name test info and all the
information concerning the test info on
here and we'll simply enable it new
table so now it's enabled oops already
did that i guess we'll enable it twice
and so let's start looking at well we
had scan new table and you can see here
where it brings up the information like
this what if we want to go ahead and get
a row so we'll do r1 and when we do
hbase r1 you can see we have knowledge
science and it has a timestamp value
physics and we have knowledge sports and
it has a timestamp on it and value
cricket and then let's see what happens
we put into our
new
table and in here we want row one and if
you can guess from earlier because we
did something similar we're going to do
knowledge economics and then it's going
to be instead of i think it was what
macroeconomics is now market economics
and we'll go back and do our get command
and now see what it looks like and we
can see here where we have knowledge
economics it has a timestamp value
market economics physics and cricket and
this is because we have economic science
and sports those are the three different
columns that we have and then each one
has different information in it and so
if you managed to go through all these
commands and look at basics on here
you'll now have the ability to create a
very basic hbase setup nosql setup based
on your columns and your rows and just
for fun we'll go back to the cloudera
thanks guys i hope you guys found this
informative with this we've come to the
end of our detailed look into the hadoop
ecosystem
now we have shruti who will explain big
data analytics and some applications of
big data let us now understand why big
data analytics is required with an
example so all of you listen to music
online isn't it here we will take an
example of spotify which is a swedish
audio streaming platform and see how big
data analytics is used here spotify has
nearly 96 plus million users and all
these users generate a tremendous amount
of data data like the songs which are
played repeatedly the numerous likes
shares and the user search history all
these data can be termed as big data
here with respect to spotify have you
ever wondered what spotify does with all
this big data well spotify analyzes this
big data for suggesting songs to its
users i'm sure all of you might have
come across the recommendation list
which is made available to each one of
you by spotify each one of you will have
a totally different recommendation list
this is based on your likes your past
history like the songs you like
listening to and your playlists this
works on something known as the
recommendation system recommendation
systems are nothing but data filtering
tools they collect all the data and then
filter them using various algorithms
this system has the ability to
accurately predict what a user would
like to listen to next with the help of
big data analytics this prediction helps
the users stay on the page for a longer
time and by doing so spotify engages all
its users the users don't have the need
to go on searching for different songs
this is because spotify readily provides
them with a variety of songs according
to their taste well this is how big data
analytics is used by spotify now that we
have understood by big data analytics is
required let us move on to our next
topic that is what is big data analytics
but before that there is another term we
need to understand that is big data we
all hear the term big data many a times
but do you know what exactly big data
means well we will understand the term
big data clearly right now big data is a
term for data sets that cannot be
handled by traditional computers or
tools due to their value volume velocity
and veracity it is defined as massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
processed and analyzed using various
traditional methods do you know how much
data is being generated every day every
second even as i talk right now there
are millions of data sources which
generate data at a very rapid rate these
data sources are present across the
world as you know social media sites
generate a lot of data let's take an
example of facebook facebook generates
over 500 plus terabytes of data every
day this data is mainly generated in
terms of your photographs videos
messages etc big data also contains data
of different formats like structured
data semi-structured data and
unstructured data data like your excel
sheets all fall under structured data
this data has a definite format your
emails fall under semi-structured and
your pictures and videos all fall under
unstructured data all these data
together make up for big data it is very
tough to store process and analyze big
data using rtbms if you have looked into
our previous videos you would know that
hadoop is the solution to this hadoop is
a framework that stores and processes
big data it stores big data using the
distributed storage system and it
processes big data using the parallel
processing method hence storing and
processing big data is no more a problem
using hadoop big data in its raw form is
of no use to us we must try to derive
meaningful information from it in order
to benefit from this big data do you
know amazon uses big data to monitor its
items that are in its fulfillment
centers across the globe how do you
think amazon does this well it is done
by analyzing big data which is known as
big data analytics what is big data
analytics in simple terms big data
analytics is defined as the process
which is used to extract meaningful
information from big data this
information could be your hidden
patterns unknown correlations market
trends and so on by using big data
analytics there are many advantages it
can be used for better decision making
to prevent fraudulent activities and
many others we will look into four of
them step by step i will first start off
with big data analytics which is used
for risk management
bdo which is a philippine banking
company uses big data analytics for risk
management risk management is an
important aspect for any organization
especially in the field of banking risk
management analysis comprises a series
of measures which are employed to
prevent any sort of unauthorized
activities identifying fraudulent
activities was a main concern for bdo it
was difficult for the bank to identify
the fraudster from a long list of
suspects bdo adopted big data analytics
which held the bank to narrow down the
entire list of suspects thus the
organization was able to identify the
fraudster in a very short time this is
how big data analytics is used in the
field of banking for risk management let
us now see how big data analytics is
used for product development and
innovations with an example all of you
are aware of rolls-royce cars right do
you also know that they manufacture jet
engines which are used across the world
what is more interesting is that they
use big data analytics for developing
and innovating this engine a new product
is always developed by trial and error
method big data analytics is used here
to analyze if an engine design is good
or bad it is also used to analyze if
there can be more scope for improvement
based on the previous models and on the
future demands this way big data
analytics is used in designing a product
which is of higher quality using big
data analytics the company can save a
lot of time if the team is struggling to
arrive at the right conclusion big data
can be used to zero in on the right data
which have to be studied and thus the
time spent on the product development is
less big data analytics helps in quicker
and better decision making in
organizations the process of selecting a
course of action from various other
alternatives is known as decision making
a lot of organizations take important
decisions based on the data that they
have data driven business decisions can
make or break a company hence it is
important to analyze all the
possibilities thoroughly and quickly
before making important decisions let us
now try to understand this with an use
case starbucks uses big data analytics
for making important decisions they
decide the location of their new outlet
using big data analytics choosing the
right location is an important factor
for any organization the wrong location
will not be able to attract the required
amount of customers positioning of a new
outlet a few miles here or there can
always make a huge difference for an
outlet especially a one like starbucks
various factors are involved in choosing
the right location for a new outlet for
example parking adequacy has to be taken
into consideration it would be
inconvenient for people to go to a store
which has no parking facility similarly
the other factors that have to be
considered are the visibility of the
location the accessibility the economic
factors the population of that
particular location and also we would
have to look into the competition in the
vicinity all these factors have to be
thoroughly analyzed before making a
decision as to where the new outlet must
be started without analyzing these
factors it would be impossible for us to
make a wise decision using big data
analytics we can consider all these
factors and analyze them quickly and
thoroughly thus starbucks makes use of
big data analytics to understand if
their new location would be fruitful or
not finally we will look into how big
data analytics is used to improve
customer experience using an example
delta an american airline uses big data
analytics to improve its customer
experiences with the increase in global
air travel it is necessary that an
airline does everything they can in
order to provide good service and
experience to its customers delta
airlines improves its customer
experience by making use of big data
analytics this is done by monitoring
tweets which will give them an idea as
to how their customers journey was if
the airline comes across a negative
tweet and if it is found to be the
airline's fault the airline goes ahead
and upgrades that particular customer's
ticket when this happens the customer is
able to trust the airlines and without a
doubt the customer will choose delta for
their next journey by doing so the
customer is happy and the airlines will
be able to build a good brand
recognition thus we see here that by
using analysis delta airlines was able
to improve its customer experience
moving on to our next topic that is
lifecycle of big data analytics here we
will look into the various stages as to
how data is analyzed from scratch the
first stage is the business case
evaluation stage here the motive behind
the analysis is identified we need to
understand why we are analyzing so that
we know how to do it and what are the
different parameters that have to be
looked into once this is done it is
clear for us and it becomes much easier
for us to proceed with the rest after
which we will look into the various data
sources from where we can gather all the
data which will be required for analysis
once we get the required data we will
have to see if the data that we received
is fit for analysis or not not all the
data that we receive will have
meaningful information summer fit will
surely just be corrupt data to remove
this corrupt data we will pass this
entire data through a filtering stage in
this stage all the corrupt data will be
removed now we have the data minus the
corrupt data do you think our data is
now fit for analysis well it is not we
still have to figure out which data will
be compatible with the tool that we will
be using for analysis if we find data
which is incompatible we first extract
it and then transform it to a compatible
form depending on the tool that we use
in the next stage all the data with the
same fields will be integrated this is
known as the data aggregation stage the
next stage which is the analysis stage
is a very important stage in the life
cycle of big data analytics right here
in this step the entire process of
evaluating your data using various
analytical and statistical tools to
discover meaningful information is done
like we have discussed before the entire
process of deriving meaningful
information from data which is known as
analysis is done here in this stage the
result of the data analysis stage is
then graphically communicated using
tools like tableau power bi click view
this analysis result will then be made
available to different business
stakeholders for various decision making
this was the entire life cycle of big
data analytics we just saw how data is
analyzed from scratch now we will move
on to a very important topic that is the
different types of big data analytics
well we have four different types of big
data analytics as you see here these are
the types and below this are the
questions that each type tries to answer
we have descriptive analytics which asks
the question what has happened then we
have diagnostic analytics which asks why
did it happen predictive analytics
asking what will happen and prescriptive
analytics which questions by asking what
is the solution we will look into all
these four one by one with an use case
for each we will first start off with
descriptive analytics as mentioned
earlier descriptive analytics asks the
question what has happened it can be
defined as the type that summarizes past
data into a form that can be understood
by humans in this type we will look into
the past data and arrive at various
conclusions for example an organization
can review its performance using
descriptive analytics that is it
analyzes its pass data such as revenue
over the years and arrives at a
conclusion with the profit by looking at
this graph we can understand if the
company is running at a profit or not
thus descriptive analytics helps us
understand this easily we can simply say
that descriptive analytics is used for
creating various reports for companies
and also for tabulating various social
media metrics like facebook likes tweets
etc now that we have seen what is
descriptive analytics let us look into
and use case of descriptive analytics
the dow chemical company analyzed all
its past data using descriptive
analytics and by doing so they were able
to identify the underutilized space in
their facility descriptive analytics
helped them in this space consolidation
on the whole the company was able to
save nearly four million dollars
annually so we now see here that
descriptive analytics not only helps us
derive meaningful information from the
past data but it can also help companies
in cost reduction if it is used wisely
let us now move on to our next type that
is diagnostic analytics diagnostic
analytics asks the question why a
particular problem has occurred as you
can see it will always ask the question
why did it happen it will look into the
root cause of a problem and try to
understand why it has occurred
diagnostic analytics makes use of
various techniques such as data mining
data discovery and drill down companies
benefit from this type of analytics
because it helps them look into the root
cause of a problem by doing so the next
time the same problem will not arise as
the company already knows why it has
happened and they will arrive at a
particular solution for it initsoft's bi
query tool is an example of diagnostic
analytics we can use query tool for
diagnostic analytics now that you know
why diagnostic analytics is required and
what diagnostic analytics is i will run
you through an example which shows where
diagnostic analytics can be used all of
us shop on e-commerce sites right have
you ever added items to your cart but
ended up not buying it yes all of us
might have done that at some point an
organization tries to understand why its
customers don't end up buying their
products although it has been added to
their cuts and this understanding is
done with the help of diagnostic
analytics an e-commerce site wonders why
they have made few online sales although
they have had a very good marketing
strategy there could have been various
factors as to why this has happened
factors like the shipping fee which was
too high or the page that didn't load
correctly not enough payment options
available and so on all these factors
are analyzed using diagnostic analytics
and the company comes to a conclusion as
to why this has happened thus we see
here that the root cause is identified
so that in future the same problem
doesn't occur again let us now move on
to the third type that is predictive
analytics as the name suggests
predictive analytics makes predictions
of the future it analyzes the current
and historical facts to make predictions
about future it always asks the question
what will happen next predictive
analytics is used with the help of
artificial intelligence machine learning
data mining to analyze the data it can
be used for predicting customer trends
market trends customer behavior etc it
solely works on probability it always
tries to understand what can happen next
with the help of all the past and
current information a company like
paypal which has 260 plus million
accounts always has the need to ensure
that their online fraudulent and
unauthorized activities are brought down
to nil fear of constant fraudulent
activities have always been a major
concern for paypal when a fraudulent
activity occurs people lose trust in the
company and this brings in a very bad
name for the brand it is inevitable that
fraudulent activities will happen in a
company like paypal which is one of the
largest online payment processors in the
world but paypal uses analytics wisely
here to prevent such fraudulent
activities and to minimize them it uses
predictive analytics to do so the
organization is able to analyze past
data which includes a customer's
historical payment data a customer's
behavior trend and then it builds an
algorithm which works on predicting what
is likely to happen next with respect to
their transaction with the use of big
data and algorithms the system can gauge
which of the transactions are valid and
which could be potentially a fraudulent
activity by doing so paypal is always
ready with precautions that they have to
take to protect all their clients
against fraudulent transactions we will
now move on to our last type that is
prescriptive analytics prescriptive
analytics as the name suggests always
prescribes a solution to a particular
problem the problem can be something
which is happening currently hence it
can be termed as the type that always
asks the question what is the solution
prescriptive analytics is related to
both predictive and descriptive
analytics as we saw earlier descriptive
analytics always asks the question what
has happened and predictive analytics
helps you understand what can happen
next with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
prescriptive analytics helps you arrive
at the best solution for a particular
problem various business rules
algorithms and computational modeling
procedures are used in prescriptive
analytics let us now have a look at how
and where prescriptive analytics is used
with an example here we will understand
how prescriptive analytics is used by an
airline for its profit do you know that
when you book a flight ticket the price
of it depends on various factors both
internal and external factors apart from
taxes seed selection there are other
factors like oil prices customer demand
which are all taken into consideration
before the flight sphere is displayed
prices change due to availability and
demand holiday seasons are a time when
the rates are much higher than the
normal days seasons like christmas and
school vacations also weekends the rates
will be much higher than weekdays
another factor which determines a
flight's fair is your destination
depending on the place where you are
traveling to the flight fair will be
adjusted accordingly this is because
there are quite a few places where the
air traffic is less and in such places
the flight sphere will also be less so
prescriptive analytics analyzes all
these factors that are discussed and it
builds an algorithm which will
automatically adjust a flight sphere by
doing so the airline is able to maximize
its profit these were the four types of
analytics now let us understand how we
achieve these with the use of big data
tools our next topic will be the various
tools used in big data analytics these
are few of the tools that i will be
talking about today we have hadoop
mongodb talindi kafka cassandra spark
and storm we will look into each one of
them one by one we will first start off
with hadoop when you speak of big data
the first framework that comes into
everyone's mind is hadoop isn't it as i
mentioned earlier apache hadoop is used
to store and process big data in a
distributed and parallel fashion it
allows us to process data very fast
hadoop uses mapreduce big and high for
analyzing this big data hadoop is easily
one of the most famous big data tools
now let us move on to the next one that
is mongodb mongodb is across platform
document oriented database it has the
ability to deal with large amount of
unstructured data processing of data
which is unstructured and processing of
data sets that change very frequently is
done using mongodb talendi provides
software and services for data
integration data management and cloud
storage it specializes in big data
integration talandi open studio is a
free open source tool for processing
data easily on a big data environment
cassandra is used widely for an
effective management of large amounts of
data it is similar to hadoop in its
feature of fault tolerance where data is
automatically replicated to multiple
nodes cassandra is preferred for
real-time processing spark is another
tool that is used for data processing
this data processing engine is developed
to process data way faster than hadoop
mapreduce this is done in a way because
spark does all the processing in the
main memory of the data nodes and thus
it prevents unnecessary input output
overheads with the disk whereas
mapreduce is disk based and hence spark
proves to be faster than hadoop
mapreduce storm is a free big data
computational system which is done in
real time it is one of the easiest tools
for big data analysis it can be used
with any programming language this
feature makes storm very simple to use
finally we will look into another big
data tool which is known as kafka kafka
is a distributed streaming platform
which was developed by linkedin and
later given to apache software
foundation it is used to provide
real-time analytics result and it is
also used for fault tolerant storage
these were few of the big data analytics
tools the first big data application we
will look into is weather forecast
imagine there is a sudden storm and
you're not even prepared that would be a
terrifying situation isn't it dealing
with any calamities such as hurricane
storms floods would be very inconvenient
if we are caught off guard the solution
is to have a tool that predicts the
weather of the coming days well in
advance this tool needs to be accurate
and to make such a tool big data is used
so how does big data help here well it
allows us to gather all the information
required to predict the weather
information such as the climate change
details wind direction precipitation
previous weather reports and so on after
all this data is collected it becomes
easier for us to spot a trend and
identify what's going to happen next by
analyzing all of this big data a weather
prediction engine works on this analysis
it predicts the weather of every region
across the world for any given time by
using such a tool we can be well
prepared to face any climate change or
any natural calamity let's take an
example of a landslide and try to
understand how big data is used to
tackle such a situation predicting a
landslide is very difficult with just
the basic warning signs lack of this
prediction can cause a huge damage to
life and property this challenge was
studied by the university of melbourne
and they developed a tool which is
capable of predicting a landslide this
tool predicts the boundary where a
landslide is likely to occur two weeks
before this magical tool works on both
big data and applied mathematics an
accurate prediction like this which is
made two weeks before can save lives and
help in relocating people in that
particular region it also gives us an
insight into the magnitude of the
upcoming destruction this is how big
data is used in weather forecast and in
predicting any natural calamities across
the world let us now move on to our next
application that is big data application
in the field of media and entertainment
the media and the entertainment industry
is a massive one leveraging big data
here can produce sky-high results and
boost the revenue for any company let us
see the different ways in which big data
is used in this industry have you ever
noticed that you come across relevant
advertisements in your social media
sites and in your mailboxes well this is
done by analyzing all your data such as
your previous browsing history and your
purchase data publishers then display
what you like in the form of ads which
will in turn catch your interest in
looking into it next up is customer
sentiment analysis customers are very
important for a company the happier the
customer the greater the company's
revenue big data helps in gathering all
the emotions of a customer through their
posts messages conversations etc these
emotions are then analyzed to arrive at
a conclusion regarding the customer
satisfaction if the customer is unhappy
the company strives to do better the
next time and provides their customers a
better experience while purchasing an
item from an e-commerce site or while
watching videos on an entertainment site
you might have noticed a segment which
says most recommended list for you this
list is a personalized list which is
made available to you by analyzing all
the data such as your previous watch
history your subscriptions your likes
and so on recommendation engine is a
tool that filters and analyzes all this
data and provides you with a list that
you would most likely be interested in
by doing so the site is able to retain
and engage its customer for a longer
time next is customer churn analysis in
simple words customer churn happens when
a customer stops a subscription with a
service predicting and preventing this
is of paramount importance to any
organization by analyzing the behavioral
patterns of previously churned customers
an organization can identify which of
their current customers are likely to
churn by analyzing all of this data the
organization can then implement
effective programs for customer
retention let us now look into an use
case of starbucks big data is
effectively used by the starbucks app 17
million users use this app and you can
imagine how much data they generate data
in the form of their coffee buying
habits the store they visit and to the
time they purchase all of this data is
fed into the app so when a customer
enters a new starbucks location the
system analyzes all their data and they
are provided with their preferred order
this app also suggests new products to
the customer in addition to this they
also provide personalized offer and
discounts on special occasions moving on
to our next sector which is healthcare
it is one of the most important sectors
big data is widely used here to save
lives with all the available big data
medical researchers are done very
effectively they are performed
accurately by analyzing all the previous
medical histories and new treatments and
medicines are discovered cure can be
found out even for few of the incurable
diseases there are cases when one
medication need not be effective for
every patient hence personal care is
very important personal care is provided
to each patient depending on their past
medical history an individual's medical
history along with their body parameters
are analyzed and personal attention is
given to each of them as we all know
medical treatments are not very pocket
friendly every time a medical treatment
is taken the amount increases this can
be reduced if readmissions are brought
down analyzing all the data precisely
will deliver a long-term efficient
result which will in turn prevent a
patient's readmission frequently with
globalization came an increase in the
ease for infectious diseases to spread
widely based on geography and
demographics big data helps in
predicting where an outbreak of epidemic
viruses are most likely to occur an
american health care company united
health care uses big data to detect any
online medical fraud activities such as
payment of unauthorized benefits
intentional misrepresentation of data
and so on the healthcare company runs
disease management programs the success
rates of these programs are predicted
using big data depending on how patients
respond to it the next sector we will
look into is logistics logistics looks
into the process of transportation and
storage of goods the movement of a
product from its supplier to a consumer
is very important big data is used to
make this process faster and efficient
the most important factor in logistics
is the time taken for the products to
reach their destination to achieve
minimum time sensors within the vehicle
analyze the fastest route this analysis
is based on various data such as the
weather traffic the list of orders and
so on by doing so the fastest route is
obtained and the delivery time is
reduced capacity planning is another
factor which needs to be taken into
consideration details regarding the
workforce and the number of vehicles are
analyzed thoroughly and each vehicle is
allocated a different route this is done
as there is no need for many trucks to
travel in the same direction which will
be pointless depending on the analysis
of the available workforce and resources
this decision is taken big data
analytics also finds its use in managing
warehouses efficiently this analysis
along with tracking sensors provide
information regarding the underutilized
space which results in efficient
resource allocation and eventually
reduces the cost customer satisfaction
is important in logistics just like it
is in any other sector customer
reactions are analyzed from the
available data which will eventually
create an instant feedback loop a happy
customer will always help the company
gain more customers let us now look into
a use case of ups as you know ups is one
of the biggest shipping company in the
world they have a huge customer database
and they work on data every minute ups
uses big data to gather different kinds
of data regarding the weather the
traffic jams the geography the locations
and so on after collecting all this data
they analyze it to discover the best and
the fastest route to the destination in
addition to this they also use big data
to change the routes in real time this
is how efficiently ups leverages big
data next up we have a very interesting
sector that is the travel and tourism
sector the global tourism market is
expected to grow in the near future big
data is used in various ways in this
sector let us look into a few of them
hotels can increase their revenue by
adjusting the room tariffs depending on
the peak seasons such as holiday seasons
festive seasons and so on the tourism
industry uses all of this data to
anticipate the demand and maximize their
revenue big data is also used by resorts
and hotels to analyze various details
regarding their competitors this
analysis result helps them to
incorporate all the good facilities
their competitors are providing and by
doing so the hotel is able to flourish
further a customer always comes back if
they are offered good packages which are
more than just the basic ones looking
into a customer's past travel history
likes and preferences hotels can provide
its customers with personalized
experiences which will interest them
highly investing in an area which could
be the hub of tourism is very wise few
countries use big data to examine the
tourism activities in their country and
this in turn helps them discover new and
fruitful investment opportunities let us
look into one of the best online
homestay networks airbnb and see how big
data is used by them airbnb undoubtedly
provides its customers with the best
accommodation across the world big data
is used by it to analyze the different
kinds of available properties depending
on the customer's preferences the
pricing the keywords previous customers
ratings and experiences airbnb filters
out the best result big data works its
magic yet again now we will move on to
our final sector which is the government
and law enforcement sector maintaining
law and order is of utmost importance to
any government it is a huge task by
itself big data plays an active role
here and in addition to this it also
helps governments bring in new policies
and schemes for the welfare of its
citizens the police department is able
to predict criminal activities way
before it happens by analyzing big data
information such as the previous crime
records in a particular region the
safety aspect in that region and so on
by analyzing these factors they are able
to predict any activity which breaks the
law and order of the region governments
are able to tackle unemployment to a
great extent by using big data by
analyzing the number of students
graduating every year to the number of
relevant job openings the government can
have an idea of the unemployment rate in
the country and then take necessary
measures to tackle it our next factor is
poverty in large countries it is
difficult to analyze which area requires
attention and development big data
analytics makes it easier for
governments to discover such areas
poverty gradually decreases once these
areas begin to develop governments have
to always be on the lookout for better
development a public survey voices the
opinion of a country's citizens
analyzing all the data collected from
such surveys can help governments build
better policies and services which will
benefit its citizens let us now move on
to our use case did you know that the
new york police department uses big data
analytics to protect its citizens the
department prevents and identifies
crimes by analyzing a huge amount of
data which includes fingerprints certain
emails and records from previous police
investigations and so on after analyzing
all of this data meaningful insights are
drawn from it which will help the police
in taking the required preventive
measures against crimes
thanks shruti now let me tell you how
you can become a big data engineer hi
guys i'm raul from simply learn and
today i'm going to tell you how you can
become a big data engineer now it should
come as no surprise for you guys to know
that organizations generate as well as
use a whole lot of data this vast volume
of data is called big data companies use
big data to draw meaningful insights and
take business decisions and big data
engineers are the people who can make
sense out of this enormous amount of
data now let's find out who is a big
data engineer a big data engineer is a
professional who develops maintains
tests and evaluates the company's big
data infrastructure in other words
develop big data solutions based on a
company's requirements they maintain
these solutions they test out these
solutions as to the company's
requirements they integrate this
solution with the various tools and
systems of the organization and finally
they evaluate how well the solution is
working to fulfill the company's
requirements next up let's have a look
at the responsibilities of a big data
engineer now they need to be able to
design implement verify and maintain
software systems now for the process of
ingesting data as well as processing it
they need to be able to build highly
scalable as well as robust systems they
need to be able to extract data from one
database transform it as well as load it
into another data store with the process
of etl or the extract transform load
process
and they need to research as well as
propose new ways to acquire data improve
the overall data quality and the
efficiency of the system now to ensure
that all the business requirements are
met they need to build a suitable data
architecture they need to be able to
integrate several programming languages
and tools together so that they can
generate a structured solution they need
to build models that reduce the overall
complexity and increase the efficiency
of the whole system by mining data from
various sources and finally they need to
work well with other teams ones that
include data architects data analysts
and data scientists next up let's have a
look at the skills required to become a
big data engineer the first step is to
have programming knowledge one of the
most important skills required to become
a big data engineer is that of
experience with programming languages
especially hands-on experience now the
big data solutions that organizations
would want you to create will not be
possible without experience in
programming languages i can even tell
you an easy way through which you can
get experience with programming
languages practice practice and more
practice some of the most commonly used
programming languages used for big data
engineering are python java and c plus
the second skill that you require is to
have in-depth knowledge about dbms and
sql you need to know how data is
maintained as well as managed in a
database you need to know how sql can be
used to transform as well as perform
actions on a database and by extension
know how to write sql queries for any
relational database management systems
some of the commonly used database
management systems for big data
engineering mysql rackle database and
the microsoft sql server the third skill
that you require is to have experience
working with etl and warehousing tools
now you need to know how to construct as
well as use a data warehouse so that you
can perform the etl operation or the
extract transform and load operations
now as a big data engineer you'll be
constantly tasked with extracting
unstructured data from a number of
different sources transforming it into
meaningful information and loading it
into other data storages databases or
data warehouses now what this is is
basically aggregating unstructured data
from multiple sources analyzing it so
that you can take better business
decisions some of the tools used for
this purpose are talent ibm data stage
pentaho and informatica next up we have
the fourth skill that you require which
is knowledge about operating systems now
since most big data tools have unique
demands such as root access to operating
system functionality as well as hardware
having a strong understanding of
operating systems like linux and unix is
absolutely mandatory some of the
operating systems used by big data
engineers are unix linux and solaris now
the fifth skill that you require to have
experience with hadoop based analytics
since hadoop is one of the most commonly
used tools when it comes to big data
engineering it's understood that you
need to have experience with apache
hadoop based technologies technologies
like hdfs hadoop mapreduce apache edge
base hive and pig the sixth skill that
you require is to have worked with real
time processing frameworks like apache
spark now as a big data engineer you'll
have to deal with vast volumes of data
so for this data you need an analytics
engine like spark which can be used for
large-scale real-time data processing
now spark can process live streaming
data from a number of different sources
like facebook instagram twitter and so
on it can also perform interactive
analysis and data integration and now
we're at our final skill requirement
which is to have experience with data
mining and modeling so as a data
engineer you'll have to examine massive
pre-existing data so that you can
discover patterns as well as new
information with this you'll create
predictive models for your business so
that you can make better informed
decisions some of the tools used for
this are r rapidminer weka and name now
let's talk about a big data engineer's
salary as well as other roles they can
look forward to now the average salary
of a big data engineer in the united
states is approximately ninety thousand
dollars per year now this ranges from
sixty six thousand dollars all the way
to hundred and thirty thousand dollars
per annum in india the average salary is
around seven lakh rupees and ranges from
four lakhs to thirteen lakhs per annum
after you've become a big data engineer
some of the job roles that you can look
forward to are that of a senior big data
engineer a business intelligence
architect and a data architect now let's
talk about certifications that a big
data engineer can opt for first off we
have the cloudera ccp data engineer a
cloudera certified professional data
engineer possesses the skills to develop
reliable and scalable data pipelines
that result in optimized data sets for a
variety of workloads it is one of the
industry's most demanding performance
based certification ccp evaluates and
recognizes a candidate's mastery of the
technical skills most sought after by
employers the time limit for this exam
is 240 minutes and it costs 400 next we
have the ibm certified data architect
big data certification an ibm certified
big data architect understands the
complexity of data and can design
systems and models to handle different
data variety including structured
semi-structured unstructured volume
velocity veracity and so on a big data
architect is also able to effectively
address information governance and
security challenges associated with the
system this exam is 75 minutes long and
finally we have the google cloud
certified data engineer a google
certified data engineer enables data
driven decision making by collecting
transforming and publishing data they
should also be able to leverage deploy
and continuously train pre-existing
machine learning models the length of
the certification exam is two hours and
its registration fee is 200 now let's
have a look at how simply learn can help
you become a big data engineer
simply learn provides the big data
architect masters program this includes
a number of different courses like big
data hadoop and spark developer apache
spark and scala mongodb developer and
administrator big data and hadoop
administrator and so much more this
course goes through 50 plus in-demand
skills and tools 12 plus real-life
projects and the possibility of an
annual average salary of 19 to 26 lakh
rupees per annum it will also help you
get noticed by the top hiring companies
this course will also go through some
major tools like kafka apache spark
flume edge base mongodb hive pig
mapreduce java scala and much more i
hope this helps we have now come to the
final part of our video ajay will take
you through 80 of the most important
interview questions that just might
appear in your big data interview we
will discuss on hadoop interview
questions and we will learn on different
aspects and be prepared for hadoop
interviews so that you can move into the
big data arena here we have some list of
questions and an explanation of those so
that you can be well prepared for your
hadoop interviews now let's look at some
general hadoop questions so what are the
different vendor specific distributions
of hadoop now all of you might be aware
that hadoop or apache hadoop is the core
distribution of hadoop and then you have
different vendors in the market which
have packaged the apache hadoop in a
cluster management solution which allows
everyone to easily deploy manage monitor
upgrade your clusters so here are some
vendor specific distributions we have
cloudera which is the dominant one in
the market we have hortonworks and now
you might be aware that cloudera and
hortonworks have merged so it has become
a bigger entity you have map r you have
microsoft azure ibm's infosphere and
amazon web services so these are some
popularly known vendor-specific
distributions if you would want to know
more about the hadoop distributions you
should basically look into google and
you should check for hadoop different
distributions wiki page so if i type
hadoop different distributions and then
i check for the wiki page that will take
me to the distributions and commercial
support page and this basically says
that the sold products that can be
called a release of apache hadoop come
from apache.org so that's your open
source community and then you have
various vendor-specific distributions
which basically are running in one or
the other way apache hadoop but they
have packaged it as a solution like a
installer so that you can easily set up
clusters on set of machines so have a
look at this page and read through about
different distributions of hadoop coming
back let's look at our next question so
what are the different hadoop
configuration files now whether you are
talking about apache hadoop cloudera
hortonworks map r or no matter which
other distribution these config files
are the most important and existing in
every distribution of hadoop so you have
hadoop environment.sh wherein you will
have environment variables such as your
java path what would be your process id
path where will your logs get stored
what kind of metrics will be collected
and so on your core hyphen site file has
the hdfs path
now this has many other properties like
enabling trash or enabling high
availability or discussing or mentioning
about your zookeeper but this is one of
the most important file you have hdfs
hyphen site file now this file will have
other information related to your hadoop
cluster such as your replication factor
where will name node store its metadata
on disk if a data node is running where
would data node store its data if a
secondary name node is running where
would that store a copy of name node's
metadata and so on your mapred hyphen
site file is a file which will have
properties related to your mapreduce
processing you also have masters and
slaves now these might be deprecated in
a vendor specific distribution and in
fact you would have a yarn hyphen site
file which is based on the yarn
processing framework which was
introduced in hadoop version 2 and this
would have all your resource allocation
and resource manager and node manager
related properties again if you would
want to look at default properties for
any one of these for example let's say
hdfs hyphen site file i could just go to
google and type in one of the properties
for example i would say dfs dot
node
and as i know this property belongs to
hdfs iphone site file and if you search
for this it will take you to the first
link which says sdfs default xml you can
click on this and this will show you all
the properties which can be given in
your sdfs hyphen site file it also shows
you which version you are looking at and
you can always change the version here
so for example if i would want to look
at two point 2.6.5
i just need to change the version and
that should show me the properties
similarly you can just give a property
which belongs to say core hyphen site
file for example i would say fs dot
default fs and that's a property which
is in core hyphen site file and
somewhere here you would see core minus
default.xml and this will show you all
the properties so similarly you could
search for properties which are related
to yarn hyphen site file or map red
hyphen site file so i could say yarn dot
resource manager and i could look at one
of these properties which will directly
take me to yarn default xml and i can
see all the properties which can be
given in yarn and similarly you could
say map reduce dot job dot reduces and i
know this property belongs to mapreduce
hyphen site file and this takes you to
the default xml so these are important
config files and no matter which
distribution of hadoop you're working on
you should be knowing about these config
files whether you work as a hadoop admin
or you work as a hadoop developer
knowing these config properties would be
very important and that would also
showcase your internal knowledge about
the configs which drive your hadoop
cluster let's look at the next question
so what are the three modes in which
hadoop can run so you can have hadoop
running in a standalone mode now that's
your default mode it would basically use
a local file system in a single java
process so when you say standalone mode
it is as you downloading hadoop related
package on one single machine but you
would not have any process running that
would just be to test hadoop
functionalities you could have a pseudo
distributed mode which basically means
it's a single node hadoop deployment now
hadoop as a framework has many many
services so it has a lot of services and
those services would be running
irrespective of your distribution and
each service would then have multiple
processes so your pseudo-distributed
mode is a mode of cluster where you
would have all the important processes
belonging to one or multiple services
running on a single node if you would
want to work on a sudo distributed mode
and using a cloud error you can always
go to google and search for cloudera's
quick start vm you can download it by
just saying cloudera quick start vm and
you can search for this and that will
allow you to download a quick start vm
follow the instructions and you can have
a single node cloudera cluster running
on your virtual machines for more
information you can refer to the youtube
tutorial where i have explained about
how to set up a quick start vm coming
back you could have finally a production
setup or a fully distributed mode which
basically means that your hadoop
framework and its components would be
spread across multiple machines so you
would have multiple services such as
hdfs yarn flume scope
kafka hbase hive impala and for these
services there would be one or multiple
processes distributed across multiple
nodes so this is normally what is used
in production environment so you could
say standalone would be good for testing
pseudo distributed could be good for
testing and development and fully
distributed would be mainly for your
production setup now what are the
differences between regular file system
and hdfs so when you say regular file
system you could be talking about a
linux file system or you could be
talking about a windows based operating
system so in regular file system we
would have data maintained in a single
system so the single system is where you
have all your files and directories so
it is having low fault tolerance right
so if the machine crashes your data
recovery would be very difficult unless
and until you have a backup of that data
that also affects your processing so if
the machine crashes or if the machine
fails then your processing would be
blocked now the biggest challenge with
regular file system is the seek time the
time taken to read the data so you might
have one single machine with huge amount
of disks and huge amount of ram but then
the time taken to read that data when
all the data is stored in one machine
would be very high and that would be
with least fault tolerance if you talk
about sdfs your data is distributed so
sdfs stands for hadoop distributed file
system so here your data is distributed
and maintained on multiple systems so it
is never one single machine it is also
supporting reliability so whatever is
stored in hdfs say a file being stored
depending on its size is split into
blocks and those blocks will be spread
across multiple nodes not only that
every block which is stored on a node
will have its replicas stored on other
nodes replication factor depends but
this makes sdfs more reliable in cases
of your slave nodes or data nodes
crashing you will rarely have data loss
because of auto replication feature now
time taken to read the data is
comparatively more as you might have
situations where your data is
distributed across the nodes and even if
you are doing a parallel read your data
read might take more time because it
needs coordination from multiple
machines however if you are working with
huge data which is getting stored it
will still be beneficial in comparison
to reading from a single machine so you
should always think about its
reliability through auto replication
feature its fault tolerance because of
your data getting stored across multiple
machines and its capability to scale so
when you talk about sdfs we are talking
about horizontal scalability or scaling
out when you talk about regular file
system you are talking about vertical
scalability which is scaling up now
let's look at some specific sdfs
questions what is this why is sdfs fault
tolerant now as i just explained in
previous slides your sdfs is fault
tolerant as it replicates data on
different data nodes so you have a
master node and you have multiple slave
nodes or data nodes where actually the
data is getting stored now we also have
a default block size of 128 mb that's
the minimum since hadoop version 2. so
any file which is up to 128 mb would be
using one logical block and if the file
size is bigger than 128 mb then it will
be split into blocks and those blocks
will be stored across multiple machines
now since these blocks are stored across
multiple machines it makes it more fault
tolerant because even if your machines
fail you would still have a copy of your
block existing on some other machine now
there are two aspects here one we talk
about the first rule of replication
which basically means you will never
have two identical blocks sitting on the
same machine and the second rule of
replication is in terms of rack
awareness so if your machines are placed
in racks as we see in the right image
you will never have all the replicas
placed on the same rack even if they are
on different machines so it has to be
fault tolerant and it has to maintain
redundancy so at least one replica will
be placed on some other node on some
other rack that's how sdfs is fault
tolerant now here let's understand the
architecture of sdfs now as i mentioned
earlier you would in a hadoop cluster
the main service is your hdfs so for
your sdfs service you would have a name
node which is your master process
running on one of the machines and you
would have data nodes which are your
slave machines getting stored across or
getting or the processes running across
multiple machines each one of these
processes has an important role to play
when you talk about sdfs whatever data
is written to hdfs
that data is split into blocks depending
on its size and the blocks are randomly
distributed across nodes with auto
replication feature these blocks are
also auto replicated across multiple
machines with the first condition that
no two identical blocks will sit on the
same machine now as soon as the cluster
comes up your data nodes which are part
of the cluster and based on config files
would start sending their heartbeat to
the name node and this would be every
three seconds what does name node do
with that name node will store this
information in its ram so name node
starts building a metadata in its ram
and that metadata has information of
what are the data nodes which are
available in the beginning now when a
data
writing activity starts and the blocks
are distributed across data nodes data
nodes every 10 seconds will also send a
block report to name node so name node
is again adding up this information in
its ram or the metadata in ram which
earlier had only data node information
now name node will also have information
about what are the files the files are
split in which blocks the blocks are
stored on which machines and what are
the file permissions now while name node
is maintaining this metadata in ram
name node is also maintaining metadata
in disk now that is what we see in the
red box which basically has information
of whatever information was written to
hdfs so to summarize your name node has
metadata in ram and metadata in disk
your data nodes are the machines where
your blocks or data is actually getting
stored and then there is a auto
replication feature which is always
existing unless and until you have
disabled it and your read and write
activity is a parallel activity however
replication is a sequential activity now
this is what i mentioned about when you
talk about name node which is the master
process hosting metadata in disk and ram
so when we talk about disk it basically
has a edit log which is your transaction
log and your fs image which is your file
system image right from the time the
cluster was started this metadata and
disk was existing and this gets appended
every time read write or any other
operations happen on sdfs metadata in
ram is dynamically built every time the
cluster comes up which basically means
that if your cluster is coming up name
node in the initial few seconds or few
minutes would be in a safe mode which
basically means it is busy registering
the information from data nodes so name
node is one of the most critical
processes if name node is down and if
all other processes are running you will
not be able to access the cluster name
node's metadata in disk is very
important for name node to come up and
maintain the cluster name nodes metadata
in ram is basically for all or
satisfying all your client requests now
when we look at data nodes as i
mentioned data nodes hold the actual
data blocks and they are sending these
block reports every 10 seconds so the
metadata in name notes ram is constantly
getting updated and metadata in disk is
also constantly getting updated based on
any kind of write activity happening on
the cluster now data node which is
storing the block will also help in any
kind of read activity whenever a client
requests so whenever a client or an
application or an api would want to read
the data it would first talk to name
node name node would look into its
metadata on ram and confirm to the
client which machines could be reached
to get to that data that's where your
client would try to read the data from
sdfs which is actually getting the data
from data nodes and that's how your read
write requests are satisfied now what
are the two types of metadata in name
node server holds as i mentioned earlier
metadata in disk very important to
remember edit log nfs image metadata in
ram which is information about your data
nodes files files being split into
blocks blocks residing on data nodes and
file permissions so i will share a very
good link on this and you can always
look for more detailed information about
your metadata so you can search for sdfs
metadata directories explained now this
is from hortonworks however it talks
about the metadata in disk which name
node manages and details about this so
have a look at this link if you are more
interested in learning about metadata on
disk coming back
let's look at the next question what is
the difference between federation and
high availability now these are the
features which were introduced in hadoop
version 2. both of these features are
about horizontal scalability of name
node so prior to version 2 the only
possibility was that you could have one
single master which basically me means
that your cluster could become
unavailable if name node would crash so
hadoop version 2 introduced two new
features federation and high
availability however high availability
is a popular one so when you talk about
federation it basically means any number
of name nodes so there is no limitation
to the number of name nodes your name
nodes are in a federated cluster which
basically means name nodes still belong
to the same cluster but they are not
coordinating with each other so whenever
a write request comes in one of the name
node picks up that request and it guides
that request for the blocks to be
written on data nodes but for this your
name node does not have to coordinate
with other name node to find out if the
block id which was being assigned was
the same one as assigned by other name
node so all of them belong to a
federated cluster they are linked via a
cluster id so whenever an application or
an api is trying to talk to cluster it
is always going via and cluster id and
one of the name node would pick up the
read activity or write activity or
processing activity so all the name
nodes are sharing a pool of metadata in
which each name node will have its own
dedicated pool and we can remember that
by a term called namespace or name
service so this also provides high fault
tolerance suppose your one name node
goes down it will not affect or make
your cluster unavailable you will still
have your cluster reachable because
there are other name nodes running and
they are available now when it comes to
heartbeats all your data nodes are
sending their heartbeats to all the name
nodes and all the name nodes are aware
of all the data nodes when you talk
about high availability this is where
you would only have two name nodes so
you would have an active and you would
have a standby now normally in any
environment you would see a
high availability setup with zookeeper
so zookeeper is a centralized
coordination service so when you talk
about your active and standby name notes
election of a name node to be made as
active and taking care of an automatic
failover is done by your zookeeper high
availability can be set up without
zookeeper but that would mean that the
admins intervention would be required to
make a name node as active from standby
or also to take care of failover
now at any point of time in high
availability a active name node would be
taking care of storing the edits about
whatever updates are happening on sdfs
and it is also writing these edits to a
shared location standby name node is the
one which is constantly looking for
these latest updates and applying to its
metadata which is actually a copy of
whatever your active name node has so in
this way your standby name node is
always in sync with the active name node
and if for any reason active name node
fails your standby name node will take
over and become the active remember
zookeeper plays a very important role
here it's a centralized coordination
service one more thing to remember here
is that in your high availability
secondary name node will not be allowed
so you would have a active name node and
then you will have a standby name node
which will be configured on a separate
machine and both of these will be having
access to a shared location now that
shared location could be nfs or it could
be a quorum of general nodes so for more
information refer to the tutorial where
i have explained about sdfs high
availability and federation now let's
look at some logical question here so if
you have a input file of 350 mb which is
obviously bigger than 128 mb how many
input splits would be created by sdfs
and what would be the size of each input
split so for this you need to remember
that by default the minimum block size
is 128 mb now that's customizable if
your environment has more number of
larger files written on an average then
obviously you have to go for a bigger
block size if your environment has a lot
of files being written but these files
are of smaller size you could be okay
with 128 mb remember in hadoop every
entity that is your directory on sdfs
file on sdfs and a file having multiple
blocks each of these are considered as
objects and for each object hadoop's
name nodes ram 150 bytes is utilized so
if your block size is very small then
you would have more number of blocks
which would directly affect the name
nodes ram if you keep a block size very
high that will reduce the number of
blocks but remember that might affect in
processing because processing also
depends on splits more number of splits
more the parallel processing so
setting of block size has to be done
with consideration about your
parallelism requirement and your name
nodes ram which is available now coming
to the question if you have a file of
350 mb that would be split into three
blocks and here two blocks would have
128 mb data and the third block although
the block size would still be 128 it
would have only 94 mb of data so this
would be the split of this particular
file now let's
understand about rack awareness how does
rack awareness work or why do we even
have racks so organizations always would
want to place their nodes or machines in
a systematic way there can be different
approaches you could have a rack which
would have machines running on the
master processes and the intention would
be that this particular rack could have
higher bandwidth more cooling dedicated
power supply top of rack switch and so
on the second approach could be that you
could have one master process running on
one machine of every rack and then you
could have other slave processes running
now when you talk about your rack
awareness one thing to understand is
that if your machines are placed within
racks and we are aware that hadoop
follows auto replication the rule of
replication in a rack of air cluster
would be that you would never have all
the replicas placed on the same rack so
if we look at this if we have block a in
blue color you will never have all the
three blue boxes in the same rack even
if they are on different notes because
that makes us that makes it less fault
tolerant so you would have at least one
copy of block which would be stored on a
different track on a different note now
let's look at this so basically here we
are talking about replicas being placed
in such a way now somebody could ask a
question can i have my block and its
replicas spread across three lakhs and
yes you can do that but then in order to
make it more redundant you are
increasing your bandwidth requirement so
the better approach would be two blocks
on the same rack on different machines
and one copy on a different track now
let's proceed how can you restart name
node and all demons in hadoop so if you
were working on an apache hadoop cluster
then you could be doing a start and stop
using hadoop demon scripts so there are
these hadoop demon scripts which would
be used to start and stop your hadoop
and this is when you talk about your
apache hadoop so let's look at one
particular file which i would like to
show you more information here and this
talks about your different clusters so
let's look into this and
so let's look at the start and stop and
here i have a file let's look at this
one
and this gives you highlights so if you
talk about apache hadoop this is how the
setup would be done so you would have it
download the adopter file you would have
to untie it edit the config files you
would have to do formatting and then
start your cluster and here i have said
using scripts so this is in case of
apache hadoop you could be using a start
all script that internally triggers
start dfs and start yarn and these
scripts start dfs internally would run
hadoop demon multiple times based on
your configs to start your different
processes then your start yarn would run
yarn demon script to start your
processing related processes so this is
how it happens in apache hadoop now in
case of cloudera or hortonworks which is
basically a vendor-specific distribution
you would have say multiple services
which would have one or multiple demons
running across the machines let's take
an example here that you would have
machine 1 machine 2 and machine 3 with
your processor spread across however in
case of cloud error and hortonworks
these are cluster management solutions
so you would never be involved in
running a script individually to start
and stop your processes in fact in case
of cloudera you would have a cloudera
scm server running on one of the
machines and then clouded scm agents
running on every machine if you talk
about hortonworks you would have ambari
server an ambari agent running so your
agents which are running on every
machine are responsible to monitor the
processes send also their heartbeat to
the master that is your server and your
server is the one or a service which
basically will give instructions to the
agents so in case of vendor specific
distribution your start and stop of
processes is automatically taken care by
these underlying services and these
services internally are still running
these commands however only in apache
hadoop you have to manually follow these
to start and stop coming back
we can look into
some command related questions so which
command will help you find the status of
blocks and file system health so you can
always go for a file system check
command now that can show you the files
for a particular sdfs path it can show
you the blocks and it can also give you
information on
status such as under replicated blocks
over replicated blocks misreplicated
blocks default replication and so on so
your fsck file system check utility does
not repair if there is any problem with
the blocks but it can give you
information of
blocks related to the files on which
machines they have stored if they are
replicated as per the replication factor
or if there is any problem with any
particular replica now what would happen
if you store too many small files in a
cluster and this relates to the block
information which i gave some time back
so remember hadoop is coded in java so
here every directory every file and file
related block is considered as an object
and for every object within your hadoop
cluster name node's ram gets utilized so
more number of blocks you have more
would be usage of name nodes ram and if
you're storing too many small files it
would not affect your disk it would
directly affect your name notes ram
that's why in production clusters admin
guys or infrastructure specialist will
take care that everyone who is writing
data to hdfs follows a quota system so
that you could be controlled in the
amount of data you write plus the count
of data and individual writes on hdfs
now how do you copy data from local
system onto sdfs so you can use a put
command or a copy from local and then
given your local path which is your
source and then your destination which
is your sdfs path remember you can
always do a copy from local using a
minus f option that's a flag option and
that also helps you in writing the same
file or a new file to hdfs so with your
minus f you have a chance of overwriting
or rewriting the data which is existing
on sdfs so copy from local or minus put
both of them do the same thing and you
can also pass an argument when you're
copying to control your replication
or other aspects of your file now when
do you use dfs admin refresh nodes or rm
admin refresh nodes so as the command
says this is basically to do with
refreshing the node information so your
refresh nodes is mainly used when say a
commissioning or decommissioning of
nodes is done so when a node is added
into the cluster or when a node is
removed from the cluster
you are actually informing hadoop master
that this particular node would not be
used for storage and would not be used
for processing now in that case you
would be once you are done with the
process of commissioning or
decommissioning you would be giving
these commands that is refreshed nodes
and rm admin refresh nodes so internally
when you talk about commissioning
decommissioning there are include and
exclude files which are updated and
these include and exclude files will
have entry of machines which are being
added to the cluster or machines which
are being removed from the cluster and
while this is being done the cluster is
still running so you do not have to
restart your master process however you
can just use these refresh commands to
take care of your commissioning
decommissioning activities now is there
any way to change replication of files
on sdfs after they are already written
and the answer is of course yes so if
you would want to set a replication
factor at a cluster level and if you
have admin access then you could edit
your sdfs hyphen site file or you could
say hadoop hyphen site file and that
would take care of replication factor
being set at a cluster level however if
you would want to change the replication
after the data has been written you
could always use a set rep command so
set rep command is basically to change
the replication after the data is
written you could also write the data
with a different replication and for
that you could use a minus d dfs dot
replication and give your replication
factor when you're writing data to the
cluster so in hadoop you can let your
data be replicated as per the property
set in the config file you could write
the data with a different replication
you could change the replication after
the data is read so all these options
are available now who takes care of
replication consistency in a hadoop
cluster and what do you mean by under
over replicated blocks now as i
mentioned your fsck command can give you
information of over or under replicated
blocks now in a cluster it is always an
always name node which takes care of
replication consistency so for example
if you have set up a replication of
three and since we know the first rule
of replication which basically means
that you cannot have two replicas
residing on the same node it would mean
that if your replication is three we
would need at least three data nodes
available now say for example you had a
cluster with three nodes and replication
was set to three at one point of time
one of your name node crashed and if
that happens your blocks would be
under-replicated
that means there was a replication
factor set but now your blocks are not
replicated or there are not enough
replicas as per the replication factor
set this is not a problem your master
process or name node will wait for some
time before it will start the
replication of data again so if a data
road is not responding or if a disk has
crashed and if name node does not get
information of a replica name node will
wait for some time and then it will
start re-replication
of those missing blocks from the
available nodes however while name node
is doing it the blocks are in under
replicated situation now when you talk
about over replicated this is a
situation where name node realizes that
there are extra copies of block now this
might be the case that you had three
nodes running with a replication of
three one of the node went down due to a
network failure or some other issue
within few minutes name node
re-replicated the data and then the
failed node is back with its set of
blocks again name node is smart enough
to understand that this is a over
replication situation and it will delete
set of blocks from one of the nodes it
might be the node which has been
recently added it might be your old node
which has joined your cluster again or
any node that depends on the load on a
particular node now we discussed about
hadoop we discussed about sdfs now we
will discuss about mapreduce which is
the programming model and you can say
processing framework what is distributed
cache in mapreduce now we know that when
we talk about mapreduce the data which
has to be processed might be existing on
multiple nodes so when you would have
your mapreduce program running it would
basically read the data from the
underlying disks now this could be a
costly operation if every time the data
has to be read from disk
so distributed cache is a mechanism
wherein data set or data which is coming
from the disk can be cached and
available for all worker nodes now how
will this benefit so when a map reduce
is running instead of every time reading
the data from disk
it would pick up the data from
distributed cache and this this will
benefit your mapreduce processing so
distributed cache can be set in your job
conf where you can specify that a file
should be picked up from distributed
cache now let's understand about these
roles so what is a record reader what is
a combiner what is a partitioner and
what kind of roles do they play in a map
reduce processing paradigm or map reduce
operation so record reader communicates
with the input split and it basically
converts the data into key value pairs
and these key value pairs
are the ones which will be worked upon
by the mapper your combiner is an
optional face it's like mini radios so
combiner does not have its own class
it relies on the reducer class basically
your combiner would receive the data
from your map tasks
which would have completed works on it
based on whatever reducer class mentions
and then passes its output to the
reducer phase partitioner is basically a
phase which decides how many reduced
tasks would be used aggregate or
summarize your data so partitioner is a
phase which would decide based on the
number of keys based on the number of
map tasks your partitioner would decide
if one or multiple reduced tasks would
be used to take care of processing so
either it could be partitioner which
decides on how many reduced tasks would
run or it could be based on the
properties which we have set within the
cluster which will take care of the
number of reduced tasks which would be
used always remember your partitioner
decides how outputs from combiner are
sent to reducer and to how many reducers
it controls the partitioning of keys of
your intermediate map outputs so map
phase whatever output it generates is an
intermediate output and that has to be
taken by your partitioner or by a
combiner and then partitioner to be sent
to one or multiple reduced tasks this is
one of the common questions which you
might face
why is mapreduce lower in processing so
we know mapreduce goes for parallel
processing we know we can have multiple
map tasks running on multiple nodes at
the same time we also know that multiple
reduced tasks could be running now why
does then mapreduce
become a slower approach
first of all your mapreduce is a batch
oriented operation now mapreduce is very
rigid and it strictly uses mapping and
reducing phases so no matter what kind
of processing you would want to do you
would have to still provide the mapper
function and the reducer function to
work on data not only this whenever your
map phase completes
the output of your map face which is an
intermittent output would be written to
hdfs and thereafter underlying disks and
this data would then be shuffled and
sorted and picked up for reducing phase
so every time your data being written to
hdfs and retrieved from sdfs makes
mapreduce a slower approach the question
is for a mapreduce job is it possible to
change the number of mappers to be
created
now
by default you cannot change the number
of map tasks because number of map tasks
depends on the input splits however
there are different ways in which you
can either set a property to have more
number of map tasks which can be used or
you can customize your code or
make it use a different format which can
then control the number of map tasks
by default number of map tasks are equal
to the number of splits of file you are
processing
so if you have a 1 gb of file that is
split into 8 blocks of 128 mb there
would be 8 map tasks running on the
cluster
these map tasks are basically running
your mapper function
if you have hard coded properties in
your map red hyphen site file to specify
more number of map tasks then you could
control the number of map tasks
let's also talk about some data types so
when you prepare for hadoop when you
want to get into big data field you
should start learning about different
data formats now there are different
data formats such as
avro parquet
you have a sequence file or binary
format and these are different formats
which are used now when you talk about
your data types
in hadoop
these are implementation of your
writable and writable comparable
interfaces so for every data type
in java you have a equivalent in hadoop
so ind in java would be intriguable in
hadoop float would be float writable
long would be long writable double
writable boolean writable array writable
map writable and object writable so
these are your different data types that
could be used within your mapreduce
program and these are implementation of
writable and writable comparable
interfaces what is speculative execution
now imagine you have a cluster which has
huge number of nodes and your data is
spread across multiple slave machines or
multiple nodes now at a point of time
due to a disk degrade or network issues
or machine heating up or more load being
on a particular node there can be a
situation where your data node will
execute task in a slower manner now in
this case if speculative execution is
turned on there would be a shadow task
or a another
similar task running on some other node
for the same processing so whichever
task finishes first will be accepted and
the other task would be killed so
speculative execution could be good if
you are working in an intensive workload
kind of environment where if a
particular node is slower you could
benefit from a unoccupied or a node
which has less load to take care of your
processing going further this is how we
can understand so node a which might be
having a slower task you would have a
scheduler which is maintaining or
having knowledge of what are the
resources available so if speculative
execution as a property is turned on
then the task which was running slow a
copy of that task or you can say shadow
task would run on some other node and
whichever task completes first will be
considered this is what happens in your
speculative execution now how is
identity mapper different from chain
mapper now this is where we are getting
deeper into mapreduce concepts so when
you talk about mapper identitymapper
is the default mapper which is chosen
when no mapper is specified in
mapreducedriver class so for every
mapreduce program you would have a map
class which is taking care of your
mapping phase which basically has a
mapper function and which would run one
or multiple map tasks right your
programming your program would also have
a reduce class which would be running a
reducer function which takes care of
reduced tasks running on multiple nodes
now if a mapper is not specified within
your driver class so driver class is
something which has all information
about your flow what's your map class
what is your reduced class what's your
input format what's your output format
what are the job configurations and so
on so identity mapper is the default
mapper which is chosen when no mapper
class is mentioned in your driver class
it basically implements an identity
function which directly writes all its
key pairs into output and it was defined
in old mapreduce api in this particular
package but when you talk about chaining
mappers or chain mapper this is
basically a class to run multiple
mappers in a single map task or
basically you could say multiple map
tasks would run as a part of your
processing the output of first mapper
would become as an input to second
mapper and so on and this can be defined
in the under mentioned class or package
what are the major configuration
parameters required in a mapreduce
program obviously we need to have the
input location we need to have the
output location so input location is
where the files will be picked up from
and this would preferably on sdfs
directory output location is the path
where your job output would be written
by your mapreduce program you also need
to specify input and output formats if
you don't specify the defaults are
considered
then we need to also have the classes
which have your map and reduce functions
and if you intend to run the code on a
cluster you need to package your class
in a jar file
export it to your cluster and then this
jar file would have your mapper reducer
and driver classes so these are
important configuration parameters
which you need to consider for a
mapreduce program now what is the
difference or what do you mean by map
side join and reduce side join map side
join is basically when the join is
performed at the mapping level or at the
mapping phase or is performed by the
mapper so each input data which is being
worked upon has to be divided into same
number of partitions
input to each map is in the form of a
structured partition and is in sorted
order so maps i join you can understand
it in a simpler way that if you compare
it with rdbms concepts where you had two
tables which were being joined it will
always be advisable to give your bigger
table as the left side table or the
first table for your join condition and
it would be your smaller table on the
left side and your bigger table on the
right side which basically means the
smaller table could be loaded in memory
and could be used for joining so map
site drawing is a similar kind of
mechanism where input data is divided
into same number of partitions when you
talk about reduced side join here the
join is performed by the reducer so it
is easier to implement than website join
as all the sorting and shuffling will
send the values
or send all the values having identical
keys to the same reducer so you don't
need to have your data set in a
structured form so look into your map
side join or reduce side join and other
joints just to understand how mapreduce
works however i would suggest not to
focus more on this because mapreduce is
still being used for processing but the
amount of map reduce based processing
has decreased overall or across the
industry now what is the role of output
committer class in a mapreduce job so
output committer as the name says
describes the commit of task output for
a mapreduce job so we could have this as
mentioned or capacity hadoop mapreduce
output committer you could have a class
which extends your output committer
class
so mapreduce relies on this mapreduce
relies on the output committer of the
job to
set up the job initialization cleaning
up the job after the job completion that
means all the resources which were being
used by a particular job setting up the
task temporary output checking whether a
task needs a commit committing the task
output and discarding the task out so
this is a very important class and can
be used within your mapreduce job what
is the process of spilling in mapreduce
what does that mean
so spilling is basically a process of
copying the data from memory buffer to
disk when obviously the buffer usage
reaches a certain threshold so if there
is not enough memory in your buffer in
your memory then the content which is
stored in buffer or memory has to be
flushed out so by default a background
thread starts spilling the content from
memory to disk after eighty percent of
buffer size is filled now when is the
buffer being used so when your mapreduce
processing is happening the data from
data is being read from the disk loaded
into the buffer and then some processing
happens same thing also happens when you
are writing data to the cluster so you
can imagine for a 100 megabyte size
buffer the spilling will start after the
content of buffer reaches 80 megabytes
this is customizable how can you set the
mappers and reducers for a mapreduce job
so these are the properties
so number of mappers and reducers as i
mentioned earlier can be customized so
by default your number of map tasks
depends on the split and number of
reduced tasks depends on the
partitioning phase which decides number
of reduced tasks which would be used
depending on the keys however we can set
these properties either in the config
files or provide them on the command
line or also make them part of our code
and this can control the number of map
tasks or reduce tasks which would be run
for a particular job let's look at one
more interesting question what happens
when a node running a map task fails
before sending the output to the reducer
so there was a node which was running a
map task and we know that there could be
one or multiple map tasks running on one
or multiple nodes and all the map tasks
have to be completed before the further
stages that such as combiner or reducer
come into existence so in a case if a
node crashes where a map task was
assigned to it the whole task will have
to be run again on some other node so in
hadoop version 2 yarn framework has a
temporary demon called application
master so your application master is
taking care of execution of your
application and if a particular task on
a particular node failed due to
unavailability of node it is the role of
application master to have this task
scheduled on some other node now can we
write the output of mapreduce in
different formats
of course we can so hadoop supports
various input and output formats so you
can write the output of mapreduce in
different formats so you could have the
default format that is text output
format wherein records are written as
line of text you could have sequence
file which is basically to write
sequence files or your binary format
files where your output files need to be
fed into another mapreduce jobs you
could go for a map file output format to
write output as map files you could go
for a sequence file as a binary output
format so that's again a variant of your
sequence file input format it basically
writes keys and values to a sequence
file so when we talk about binary format
we are talking about a non-human
readable format db output format now
this is basically used when you would
want to write data to say relational
databases or say nosql databases such as
hbase
so this format also sends the reduce
output to a sql table now let's
learn a little bit about yarn yarn which
stands for yet another resource
negotiator it's the processing framework
so what benefits did yan bring in hadoop
version 2 and how did it solve the
issues of mapreduce version 1. so
mapreduce version 1 had major issues
when it comes to scalability or
availability because sorry in hadoop
version 1 you had only one master
process for processing layer and that is
your job tracker so your job tracker was
listening to all the task trackers which
were running on multiple machines so
your job tracker was
responsible for resource tracking and
job scheduling in yarn you still have a
processing master but that's called
resource manager instead of job tracker
and now with hadoop version 2 you could
even have resource manager running in
high availability mode you have node
managers which would be running on
multiple machines and then you have a
temporary demon called application
master so in case of hadoop version 2
your resource manager or master is only
handling the client connections and
taking care of tracking the resources
the jobs scheduling or basically taking
care of execution across multiple nodes
is controlled by application master till
the application completes
so in yarn you can have different kind
of resource allocations that could be
done and there is a concept of container
so container is basically a combination
of ram and cpu cores
yarn can run different kind of workloads
so it is not just map reduce kind of
workload which can be run on adobe
version 2 but you would have graph
processing massive parallel processing
you could have a real time processing
and huge processing applications could
run on a cluster based on yarn so when
we talk about scalability in case of
your hadoop version 2 you can have a
cluster size of more than 10 000 nodes
and can run more than 100 000 concurrent
tasks and this is because for every
application which is launched you have
this temporary device called application
master so if i would have 10
applications running i would have 10 app
masters running taking care of execution
of these applications across multiple
nodes compatibility so hadoop version 2
is fully compatible with whatever was
developed as per hadoop version 1 and
all your processing needs would be taken
care by yarn
so dynamic allocation of cluster
resources taking care of different
workloads
allocating resources across multiple
machines and using them for execution
all that is taken care by
multi-tenancy which basically means you
could have
multiple users or multiple teams
you could have open source and
proprietary data access engines and all
of these could be basically hosted using
the same cluster now how does yarn
allocate resources to an application
with help of its architecture so
basically you have a client or an
application or an api which talks to
resource manager resource manager is as
i mentioned managing the resource
allocation in the cluster when you talk
about resource manager you have its
internal two components one is your
scheduler and one is your applications
manager so when we say resource manager
being the master is tracking the
resources the source manager is the one
which is negotiating the resources with
slave it is not actually resource
manager who is doing it but these
internal components so you have a
scheduler which allocates resources to
various running applications so
scheduler is not bothered about tracking
your resources or basically tracking
your applications so we can have
different kind of schedulers such as
fifo which is first in first out you
could have a fair scheduler or you could
have a capacity scheduler and these
schedulers basically control how
resources are allocated to multiple
applications when they are running in
parallel so there is a queue mechanism
so scheduler will schedule resources
based on requirements of application but
it is not monitoring or tracking the
status of applications
your applications manager is the one
which is accepting the job submissions
it is monitoring and restarting the
application masters so it's application
manager which is basically then
launching a application master which is
responsible for an application so this
is how it looks
so whenever a job submission happens we
already know that resource manager is
aware of the resources which are
available with every node manager so on
every node which has fixed amount of ram
and cpu cores
some portion of resources that is your
ram and cpu cores are allocated to node
manager now resource manager is already
aware of how much resources are
available across nodes so whenever a
client request comes in resource manager
will make a request to node manager it
will basically request node manager to
hold some resources for processing node
manager would basically approve or
disapprove this request of holding
resources
and these resources that is a
combination of ram and cpu cores are
nothing but containers we can allocate
containers of different sizes within
yarn hyphen site file so your node
manager based on a request from resource
manager guarantees the container which
would be available for processing that's
when your resource manager starts a
temporary demand called application
master to take care of your execution so
your app master which was launched by
resource manager or we can say internal
away applications manager will run in
one of the containers because
application master is also a piece of
code so it will run in one of the
containers and then other containers
will be utilized for execution this is
how yarn is basically taking care of
your allocation your application master
is managing resource needs it is the one
which is interacting with scheduler and
if a particular
node crashes it is the responsibility of
app master to go back to the master
which is resource manager and negotiate
for more resources
so your app master will never ever
negotiate resources with node manager
directly it will always talk to resource
manager and the source manager is the
one which negotiates the resources
container as i said is a collection of
resources like your ram cpu network
bandwidth and your container is
allocated based on the availability of
resources on a particular node so which
of the following has occupied the place
of a job tracker
of mapreduce so it is your resource
manager so resource manager is the name
of the master process in adobe portion
2. now if you would have to
write yarn commands to check the status
of an application so we could just say
yarn application minus status and then
the application id and you could kill it
also from the command line remember your
yarn has a ui and you can even look at
your applications from the ui you can
even kill your applications from the ui
however knowing the command line
commands would be very useful can we
have more than one resource manager in a
young base cluster yes we can that is
what hadoop version 2 allows us to have
so you can have a high availability yarn
cluster where you have active and
standby and the coordination is taking
care by your zookeeper at a particular
time there can only be one active
resource manager and if active resource
manager fails your standby resource
manager comes and becomes active however
zookeeper is playing a very important
role remember zookeeper is the one which
is coordinating the server state and it
is doing the election of active to
standby failover what are the different
schedulers available in yarn so you have
a fifo scheduler that is first in first
out and this is not a desirable option
because in this case a longer running
application might block all other small
running applications your capacity
scheduler is basically a scheduler where
dedicated queues are created and they
have fixed amount of resources so you
can have multiple applications accessing
the cluster at the same time and they
would be using their own queues
and the resources allocated to them if
you talk about fair scheduler you don't
need to have a fixed amount of
resources you can just have a percentage
and you could decide what kind of
fairness is to be followed which
basically means that if you were
allocated 20 gigabytes of memory however
the cluster has 100 gigabytes and the
other team was assigned 80 gigabytes of
memory then you have 20 access to the
cluster another team has 80 percent
however if the other team does not come
up or does not use the cluster in a fair
scheduler you can go up to maximum of
of your cluster
to find out more information about your
schedulers you could either look in
hadoop definitive guide or what you
could do is you could just go to google
and you could type for example yarn
scheduler
let's search for yarn scheduler and then
you can look in
hadoop definitive guide
and so this is your hadoop definitive
guide and it beautifully explains about
your different schedulers how do
multiple applications run and that could
be in your
fifo kind of scheduling it could be in
capacity scheduler or it could be in a
fair scheduling so have a look at this
link it's a very good link you can also
search for yarn untangling and this is a
blog of four or this is a series of four
blocks where it's beautifully explained
about your yarn how it works how the
resource allocation happens what is a
container and what runs within the
container so you can scroll down you can
be reading through this and you can then
also search for part two of it which
talks about allocation and so on so
coming back
we basically have these schedulers what
happens if a resource manager fails
while executing an application in a high
availability cluster so in a high
availability cluster we know that we
would have two resource managers one
being active one being standby and
zookeeper which is keeping a track of
the server states so if a rm fails in
case of high availability the
standby will be elected as active and
then basically your resource manager or
the standby would become the active one
and this one would instruct the
application master to abort
in the beginning then your resource
manager recovers its running state so
there is something called as rm state
store where all the applications which
are running their status is stored so
resource manager recovers its running
state by looking at your state store
by taking advantage of container
statuses and then continues to take care
of your processing now in a cluster of
10 data nodes each having 16 gb and 10
cores what would be total processing
capacity of the cluster take a minute to
think 10 data nodes 16 gb ram per node
10 cores
so if you mention the answer as 160 gb
ram and 100 cores
then
you went wrong now think of a cluster
which has 10 data nodes each having 16
gb ram and 10 cores remember on every
node in a hadoop cluster you would have
one or multiple processors running those
processes would need ram the machine
itself which has a linux file system
would have its own processes so that
would also be having some ram usage
which basically means that if you talk
about 10 data nodes you should deduct at
least 20 to 30 percent towards the
overheads towards the cloud database
services towards the other processes
which are running and in that case i
could say that you could have 11 or 12
gb available on every machine for
processing and say 6 or 7 cores multiply
that by 10 and that's your processing
capacity remember the same thing applies
to the disk usage also so if somebody
asks you in a 10 data node cluster where
each machine has 20 terabytes of disks
what is my total storage capacity
available for sdfs so the answer would
not be 200 you have to consider the
overheads and this is basically which
gives you your processing capacity now
let's look at one more question so what
happens if requested memory or cpu goes
beyond or goes beyond the size of
container now as i said you can have
your configurations which can say that
in a particular data node which has 100
gb ram i could allocate say 50 gb
for the processing like out of 100 cores
i could say 50 cores for processing so
if you have 100 gb ram and 100 cores you
could ideally allocate 100
for processing but that's not ideally
possible so if you have 100 gb ram you
would go for 50 gb and if you have 100
cores you would go for 50 cores now
within this
ram and cpu course you have the concept
of containers right so container is a
combination of ram and cpu cores so you
could have a minimum size container and
maximum size container now at any point
of time if your application starts
demanding
more memory or more cpu cores
and this
cannot fit into a container location
your application will fail your
application will fail because you
requested for a memory or a combination
of memory and cpu cores which is
more than the maximum container size so
look into this yarn tangling website
which i mentioned and look for the
second blog in those series which
explains about these allocations now
here we will discuss on hive peg hbase
and these components of hadoop which are
being used in the industry for various
use cases let's look at some questions
here and let's look how you should
prepare for them so first of all we will
learn on hive which is a data
warehousing package so the question is
what are the different components of a
hive architecture now when we talk about
hive we already know that hive is a data
warehousing package which basically
allows you to work on structured data or
data which can be structuralized so
normally people are well versed with
querying or basically processing the
data using sql queries a lot of people
come from database backgrounds and they
would find it comfortable if they know
structured query language hive is one of
the data warehousing package which
resides within a hadoop ecosystem it
uses hadoop's distributed file system to
store the data and it uses rdbms usually
to store the metadata although metadata
can be stored locally also so what are
the different components of an hive
architecture so it has a user interface
so user interface calls the execute
interface to the driver this creates a
session to the query and then it sends
the query to the compiler to generate an
execution plan for it usually whenever
hive is set up it would have its
metadata stored in an rdbms now to
establish the connection between rdbms
and hadoop we need odbc or jdbc
connector jar file and that connector
jar file has a driver class now this
driver class is mandatory to create a
connection between hive and hadoop so
user interface creates this interface
using the driver now we have metastore
metastore stores the metadata
information so any object which you
create such as database table indexes
their metadata is stored in metastore
and usually this metastore is stored in
an rdbms so that multiple users can
connect to hive so your metastore stores
the metadata information and sends that
to the compiler for execution of a query
what does the compiler do it generates
the execution plan it has a dag now dag
stands for direct acyclic graph so it
has a tag of stages where each stage is
either a metadata operation a map or
reduced job or an operation on sdfs and
finally we have execution engine that
acts as a bridge between hive and hadoop
to process the query so execution engine
communicates bi-directionally with
metastore to perform operations like
create or drop tables so these are four
important components of hive
architecture now what is the difference
between external table and manage table
and height
so we have various kinds of table in
height such as external table manage
table partition table the major
difference between your managed and
external table is in respect to what
happens to the data if the table is
dropped usually whenever we create a
table in hive it creates a manage table
or we could also call that as an
internal table now this manages the data
and moves it into warehouse directory by
default whether you create a manage
table or external table usually the data
can reside in hive's default warehouse
directory or it could be residing in a
location chosen however when we talk
about manage table if one drops a manage
table not only the metadata information
is deleted but the table's data is also
deleted from his dfs if we talk about
external table it is created with an
external keyword explicitly and if an
external table is dropped nothing
happens to the data which resides in
sdfs so that's the main difference
between your managed and external table
what might be the use case if somebody
asks you there might be a migration kind
of activity or you are interested in
creating a lot of tables
using your queries so in that case you
could dump all the data on sdfs and then
you could create a table by pointing to
a particular directory or multiple
directories now you could then do some
testing of your tables and would decide
that you might not need all the tables
so in that case it would be advisable to
create external tables so that even if
the table is later dropped the data on
sdfs will be intact unlike your managed
table where dropping of table will
delete the data from sdfs also let's
learn a little bit on partition so what
is partition and hive and why is
partitioning required in hive if
somebody asks you that now normally in
world of rdbms partition is the process
to group similar type of data together
and that is usually done on basis of a
column or what we call as partitioning
key now each table usually has one
column in context of rdbms which could
be used to partition the data and why do
we do that so that we can avoid scanning
the complete table for a query and
restrict the scan to
set of data or to a particular partition
in hive we can have any number of
partition keys so partitioning provides
granularity in hive table it reduces the
query latency by scanning only relevant
partition data instead of whole data set
we can partition at various levels now
if i compare rdbms with hive in case of
rdbms you could have
one column which could be used for
partitioning and then you could be
squaring the specific partition so in
case of rdbms your partition column is
usually a part of the table definition
so for example if i have an employee
table i might have employee id employee
name employee age and employee salary as
four columns and i would decide to
partition the table based on salary
column now why would i partition it
because i feel that employee table is
growing very fast it is or it will have
huge amount of data and later when we
query the table we don't want to scan
the complete table so i could split my
data into multiple partition based on a
salary column giving some ranges in hive
it is a little different
in hive you can do partitioning and
there is a concept of static and dynamic
partitioning but in hive the partition
column is not part of table definition
so you might have an employee table with
employee id
name age
and that that's it that would be the
table definition but you could then have
partitioning done based on salary column
which will then create a specific folder
on sdfs in that case when we query the
data we can see the partition column
also showing up so we can partition the
transaction data for a bank for example
based on month like jan feb etc and any
operation regarding a particular month
will then allow us to query that
particular folder that is where
partitioning is useful now why does hive
not store metadata information in sdfs
if somebody asks you so we know that
hives data is stored in sdfs which is
hadoop distributed file system however
the metadata is either stored locally
and that mode of hive would be called as
embedded mode or you could have hives
metadata stored in rdbms so that
multiple clients can initiate a
connection now this metadata which is
very important for hive would not be
stored in sdfs so we already know that
sdfs read and write operations are time
consuming it is a distributed file
system and it can accommodate huge
amount of data so hive stores metadata
information in metastore using rdbms
instead of sdfs so this allows to
achieve low latency and faster data
access
now if somebody asks what are the
components used in hive query processor
so usually we have the main components
are your parser your execution engine
logical plan generation optimizer and
type checking so whenever a query is
submitted it will go through a parser
and parser would check the syntax it
would check for objects which are being
queried and other things to see if the
query is fine now internally you have a
semantic analyzer which will also look
at the query you have an execution
engine which basically will work on the
execution part that is the best
generated execution plan which could be
used to get the results for the query
you could also have user defined
functions which a user would want to use
and these are normally created in
java or java programming language and
then basically these user defined
functions are added to the class path
now you would have a logical plan
generation which basically looks at your
query and then generates a logical plan
or the best execution path which would
be required to get to the results
internally there is a physical plan
generated which is then looked in by
optimizer to get the best path to get to
the data and that might also be checking
your different operators which you are
using within your query finally we would
also have type checking so these are
important components and hype so
somebody might ask you if you are
querying your data using hive what are
the different components involved or if
you could explain what are the different
components which
work
when a query is submitted so these are
the components now let's look a scenario
based question suppose there are a lot
of small csv files which are present in
a sdfs directory and you want to create
a single hive table from these files so
data in these files have fields like
registration number name email address
so if this is what needs to be done what
will be your approach to solve it where
will you create a single hive table for
lots of small files without degrading
the performance of the system so there
can be different approaches now we know
that there are a lot of small csv files
which are present in a directory so we
know that when we create a table in hive
we can use a location parameter so i
could say create table give a table name
give the column and their data types i
could specify the delimiters and finally
i could say location and then point it
to a directory on sdfs in this directory
might be the directory which has lot of
csv files so in this case i will avoid
loading the data in the table because
table being point table pointing to the
directory will directly pick up the data
from one or multiple files and we also
know that hive does schema check on read
so it does not do a schema check on
write so in case there were one or two
files which did not follow the schema of
the table it would not prevent data
loading data would anyways be loaded
only when you query the data it might
show you null values if data which was
loaded does not follow the schema of the
table this is one approach what is the
other approach so let's look at that you
can think about sequence file format
which is basically a smart format or a
binary format and you can group these
small files together to form a sequence
file now this could be one other smarter
approach so we could create a temporary
table so we could say create table give
a table name give the column names and
their data types we could specify the
delimiters as it shows here that is row
format and fields terminated by and
finally we can store that as text file
then we can load data into this table by
giving a local file system path and then
we can create a table that will store
data in sequence file format so my point
one is storing the data in this text
file point three would be storing the
data in sequence file format so we say
create table give the specifications we
say row format delimited fields are
terminated by comma stored as sequence
file then we can move the data from test
table into test sequence file table so i
could just say insert overwrite my new
table as select star from other table
remember in hive you cannot do insert
update delete however if the table is
existing you can do a insert overwrite
from an existing table into a new table
so this could be one approach where we
could have a lot of csv files or smaller
files club together as one big sequence
file and then store it in the table now
if somebody asks you write a query to
insert a new column that is
integer data type into a hive table and
the requirement might be that you would
want to insert this table at a position
before an existing column now that's
possible by doing an alter table giving
your table name and then specifying
change column giving you a new column
with the data type before an existing
column this is a simple way wherein you
can insert a new column into a hive
table what are the key differences
between hive and pig
now some of you might have heard high
visit data warehousing package and pig
is more of a scripting language
both of them are used for data analysis
or trend detection hypothesis testing
data transformation and many other use
cases so if we compare hive and pig hive
uses a declarative language called hive
ql that is hive querying language
similar to sql and it is for reporting
or for data analysis even for data
transformation or for your data
extraction pig uses a high level
procedural language called pig latin for
programming both of them remember use
mapreduce processing framework so when
we run a query in hive to process the
data or when we create and submit a pick
script both of them trigger a mapreduce
job unless and until we have set them to
local mode hive operates on the server
side of the cluster and basically works
on structured data or data which can be
structuralized pig usually works or
operates on the client side of the
cluster and allows both structured
unstructured or even i could say
semi-structured data hive does not
support avro file format by default
however that can be done by using the
right serializer d serializer so we can
have hive table related data stored in
avro format in sequence file format in
part k format or even as a text file
format however when we are working on
smarter formats like avro or sequence
file or parquet we might have to use
specific serializers d serializers for
avro this is the package which allows us
to use avro format pig supports avro
format by default hive was developed by
facebook and it supports partitioning
and pig was developed by yahoo and it
does not support partitioning so these
are high level differences there are
lots and lots of differences remember
hive is more of a data housing package
and pig is more of a scripting language
or a
strictly procedural flow following
scripting language which allows us to
process the data now let's get more and
let's get more deeper and learn about
pig which is as i mentioned a scripting
language which can be used for your data
processing it also uses mapreduce
although we can even have pig run in a
local mode let's learn about pig in the
next section now let's learn on some
questions about pig which is a scripting
language and it is extensively used for
data processing and data analysis so the
question is how is apache pig different
from mapreduce now we all know that
mapreduce is a programming model it is
it's quite rigid when it comes to
processing the data because you have to
do the mapping and reducing you have to
write huge code usually mapreduce is
written in java but now it can also be
written in python it can be written in
scala and other programming languages so
if we compare pig with mapreduce pig
obviously is very concise it has less
lines of code when compared to mapreduce
now we also know that pig script
internally will trigger a mapreduce job
however user need not know about
mapreduce programming model they can
simply write simple scripts in pig and
that will automatically be converted
into mapreduce however mapreduce has
more lines of code peak is
high level language which can easily
perform join operations or other data
processing operations mapreduce is a low
level language which cannot perform job
join operations easily so we can do join
using mapreduce however it's not really
easy in comparison to pick now as i said
on execution every pig operator is
converted internally into a mapreduce
job so every pick script which is run
which would be converted into mapreduce
job now map reduce overall is a batch
oriented processing so it takes more
time to compile it takes more time to
execute either when you run a mapreduce
job or when it is triggered by pig
script pig works with all versions of
hadoop and when we talk about mapreduce
program which is written in one hadoop
version may not work with other versions
it might work or it might not it depends
on what are the dependencies what is the
compiler you are using what programming
language you have used and what version
of hadoop you are working on so these
are the main differences between apache
pig and mapreduce what are the different
ways of executing pig script so you
could create a script file store it in
dot pic or dot text and then you could
execute it using the pic command you
could be bringing up the grunt shell
that is pig's shell now that usually
starts with mapreduce mode but then we
can also bring it up in a local mode and
we can also run pic embedded as an
embedded script in other programming
language so these are the different ways
of executing your big script now what
are the major components of pig
execution environment this is this is a
very common question interviewers would
always want to know different components
of hive different components of pig even
different components which are involved
in hadoop ecosystem
so when we want to learn about major
components of big execution environment
here are some so you have pig scripts
now that is written in pig latin using
built-in operators and user-defined
functions and submitted to the execution
environment that's what happens when you
would want to process the data using pic
now there is a parser which does type
checking and checks the syntax of the
script the output of parser is a tag
direct acyclic graph so look in
wikipedia for dag so dag is basically a
sequence of steps which run in one
direction then you have an optimizer now
this optimizer performs optimization
using merge transform split etc it aims
to reduce the amount of data in the
pipeline that's the whole purpose of
optimizer you have a internal compiler
so pick compiler converts the optimized
code into a mapreduce job and here user
need not know the mapreduce programming
model or how it works or how it is
written they all need to know about
running the big script which would be
internally converted into a mapreduce
job and finally we have an execution
engine so mapreduce jobs are submitted
to the execution engine to generate the
desired results so these are major
components of big execution environment
now let's learn about different complex
data types in pig supports various data
types the main ones are tuple bag and
map what is tuple or tuple as you might
have heard a tuple is an ordered set of
fields which can contain different data
types for each field so in array you
would have multiple elements but that
would be of same types list can also
have different types your tuple is a
collection which has different fields
and each field can be of different type
now we could have an example as one
comma three or one comma three comma a
string or a float element and all of
that form a tuple bag is a set of tuples
so that's represented by curly braces so
you could also imagine this like a
dictionary which has various different
collection elements what is a map map is
a set of key value pairs used to
represent data so when you work in big
data field you need to know about
different data types which are supported
by pig which are supported by hive which
are supported in other components of
hadoop so tuple tag map array array
buffer you can think about list you can
think about dictionaries you can think
about map which is key value pair so
these are your different complex data
types other than the primitive data type
such as integer character string boolean
float and so on now what are the various
diagnostic operators available in apache
pick so these are some of the operators
or options which you can give in a big
script you can do a dump now dump
operator runs the pig latin scripts and
displays the result on the screen so
either i could do a dumb and see the
output on the screen or i can even do a
dump into and i could store my output in
a particular file so we can load the
data using load operator and pick and
then pico also has different internal
storage like json loader or big storage
which can be used if you are working on
specific kind of data and then you could
do a dump either before processing or
after processing and dump would produce
the result the result could be stored in
a file or
seen on the screen you also have a
describe operator now that is used to
view the schema of a relation so you can
load the data and then you can view the
schema of relation using describe
operator x-plane as we might already
know displays the physical logical and
mapreduce execution plans normally in
rdbms when we use x-plane we would like
to see what happens behind the scenes
when a particular script or a query runs
so we could load the data using load
operator as in any other case and if we
would want to display the logical
physical and mapreduce execution plans
we could use explain operator there is
also an illustrate operator now that
gives the step-by-step execution of
sequence of statements so sometimes when
we would want to analyze our script to
see how good or bad they are or would
that really serve our purpose we could
use illustrate and again you can test
that by loading the data using load
operator and you could just use a
illustrate operator to have a look at
the step by step execution of the
sequence of statements which you would
want to execute so these are different
diagnostic operators available in apache
pic now if somebody asks state the usage
of group order by and distinct keywords
in big script so as i said pig is a
scripting language so you could use
various operators so group basically
collects various records with the same
key and groups the data in one or more
relations here is an example you could
do a group data so that is basically a
variable or you can give some other name
and you can say group relation name by
age now say i have a file where i have
field various fields and one of the
field is relation name so i could group
that by a different field order by is
used to display the contents of relation
in a sorted order whether ascending or
descending so i could create a variable
called relation 2 and then i could say
order relation name 1 by ascending or
descending order distinct basically
removes the duplicate records and it is
implemented only on entire records
not on individual records so if you
would like want to find out the distinct
values and relation name field i could
use distinct what are the relational
operators in pig so you have various
relational operators which help data
scientists or data analyst or developers
who are analyzing the data such as co
group which joins two or more tables and
then performs group operation on the
join table result you have cross it is
used to compute the cross product that
is a cartesian product of two or more
relations
for each is basically to do some
iteration so if it will iterate through
tuples of a relation generating a data
transformation so for example if i say
variable a equals and then i load a file
in a and then i could create a variable
called b where i could say for each a i
would want to do something say group
join is to join two or more tables in a
relation limit is to limit the number of
output tuples or output results split is
to split the relation into two or more
relations union is to get a combination
that's it will merge the contents of two
or more relations and order is to get a
sorted result so these are some
relational operators which are
extensively used in pig for analysis
what is the use of having filters in
apache pic
now say for example i have some data
which has three fields year product
quantity and this is my phone sales data
so filter operator could be used to
select the required values from a
relation based on a condition it also
allows you to remove unwanted records
from data file so for example filter the
products where quantity is greater than
thousand so i see that i have
one row wherein or multiple rows where
the quantity is greater than thousand
such as 1500 1700 1200 so i could create
a variable called a i would load my file
using pix storage as i explained earlier
big storage is an internal parameter
which can be used to
specify the delimiters now here my
delimiter is comma so i could say using
pick storage as and then i could specify
the data type for each field so here
being integer product being character
array and quantity being integer then b
i could say filter a whatever we have in
a by quantity greater than thousand so
it's very concise it's very simple and
it allows us to extract and process data
in a simpler way now suppose there is a
file called test.txt
having 150 records in hdfs so this is a
file which is stored on his dfs and it
has 150 records where we can consider
every record being one line and if
somebody asks you to write a pick
command to retrieve the first 10 records
of the file first we will have to load
the data so i could create a variable
called test underscore data and i would
say load my file using pick storage
specifying the delimiter as comma as and
then i could specify my fields whatever
fields our file have and then i would
want to get only 10 records for which i
could use the limit operator so i could
say limit on test data and give me 10
records this is very simple and we can
extract 10 records from 150 records
which are stored in the file on sdfs
now we have learnt on pig we have learnt
some questions on hive you could always
look more in books like programming in
hive or programming in pig and look for
some more examples and try out these
examples on a existing hadoop setup now
let's learn on hbase which is a nosql
database now hbase is a four dimensional
database in comparison to your rdbms
which usually are two-dimensional so
rdbms have rows and columns but h base
has four coordinates it has row key
which is always unique column family
which can be any number column
qualifiers which can again be any number
per column family and then you have a
version so these four coordinates make
hbase a four dimensional key value store
or a column family store which is unique
for storing huge amount of data and
extracting data from hbase there is a
very good link which i would suggest
everyone can look at if you would want
to learn more on hbase and you could
just say hbase mapper and this basically
brings up a documentation which is from
mapper but then that's not specific to
map r and you can look at this link
which will give you a detailed
explanation of edge base how it works
what are the architectural components
and how data is stored and how it makes
hbase a very powerful nosql database
so let's learn on some of the important
or critical questions on hbase which
might be asked by the interviewer in an
interview when you are applying for a
big data admin or a developer position
role so what are the key components of
edgeways now as i said this is one of
the favorite questions of interviewers
where they would want to understand your
knowledge on different components for a
particular service hbase as i said is a
nosql database and that comes as a part
of service with cloudera or hortonworks
and with apache hadoop you could also
set up hbase as an independent package
so what are the key components of hbase
hbase has a region server now edge base
follows the similar kind of topology
like hadoop now hadoop has a master
process that is named node and slave
processes such as data nodes and
secondary name node in the same way
hbase also has a master which is h
master and the slave processes are
called region servers so these region
servers are usually co-located with data
nodes however it is not mandatory that
if you have 100 data nodes you would
have 100 region servers so it purely
depends on admin so what does this
region server contain so region server
contains hbase tables that are divided
horizontally into regions or you could
say group of rows is called regions so
in edge base you have two aspects one is
group of columns which is called column
family and one is group of rows which is
called regions now these regions or
these rows are grouped based on the key
values or i would say row keys which are
always unique when you store your data
in each base you would have data in the
form of rows and columns so group of
rows are called regions or you could say
these are horizontal partitions of the
table so a region server manages these
regions on the node where a data node is
running a region server can have up to
thousand regions it runs on every node
and decides the size of region so region
server as i said is a slave process
which is responsible for managing hbase
data on the node each region server is a
worker node or a worker process
co-located with data node which will
take care of your read write update
delete request from the clients now when
we talk about more components of edge
base as i said you have hp h master so
you would always have a connection
coming in from a client or an
application what does hmaster do it
assigns regions it monitors the region
servers it assigns regions to region
servers for load balancing and it cannot
do that without the help of zookeeper so
if we talk about components of hbase
there are three main components you have
zookeeper you have h master and you have
region server region server being the
slave process your edge master being the
master process which takes care of all
your table operations assigning regions
to the region servers taking care of
read and write requests which come from
client and for all of this edge master
will take in help of zookeeper which is
a centralized coordination service so
whenever a client wants to read or write
or change the schema or any other
metadata operations it will contact
hmaster edge master internally will
contact zookeeper so you could have
hbase setup also in high availability
mode where you could have a active edge
master than a backup edge master you
would have a zookeeper quorum which is
the way zookeeper works so zookeeper is
a centralized coordination service which
will always run with a quorum of
processes so zookeeper would always run
with odd number of processes such as
three five and seven because zookeeper
works on the concept of maturity
consensus now zookeeper which is a
centralized coordination service is
keeping a track of all the servers which
are alive available and also keeps a
track of their status for every server
with zookeeper is monitoring zookeeper
keeps a session alive with that
particular server h master would always
check with zookeeper which region
servers are available alive so that
regions can be assigned to the region
server at one end you have region server
which are sending their status to the
zookeeper indicating if they are ready
for any kind of read or write operation
and at other end edge master is querying
the zookeeper to check the status now
zookeeper internally manages a meta
table now that meta table will have
information of which regions are
residing on which region server and what
rookies those regions contain so in case
of a need activity h master will query
zookeeper to find out the region server
which contains that meta table once edge
master gets the information of meta
table it can look into the meta table to
find out the row keys and the
corresponding region servers which
contain the regions for those row keys
now if we would want to understand
rookie and column families in each base
let's look at this and it would be good
if we could look this on an excel sheet
so row key is always unique it acts as a
primary key for any hbase table it
allows a logical grouping of cells and
make sure that all cells with the same
row key are co-located on the same
server so as i said you have four
coordinates for hbase you have a row key
which is always unique you have column
families which is nothing but group of
columns and when i say column families
one column family can have any number of
columns so when i talk about h base h
base is four dimensional and in terms of
h base it is also called as a column
oriented database which basically means
that every row in one column could have
a different data type now you have a row
key which uniquely identifies the row
you have column families which could be
one or many depending on how the table
has been defined and a column family can
have any number of columns or i could
say for every row within a column family
you could have different number of
columns so i could say for my row one i
could just have two columns such as name
and city within the column family for my
row 2 i could have name city age
designation salary for my third row i
could have thousand columns and all that
could belong to one column family so
this is a horizontally scalable database
so column family consists of group of
columns which is defined during table
creation and each column family can have
any number of column qualifiers
separated by a delimiter now a
combination of row key column family
column qualifier such as name city age
and the value within the cell is makes
the edge base a unique four dimensional
database for more information if you
would want to learn on hbase please
refer this link which is hbase mapper
and this gives a complete hbase
architecture that is three components of
name node
three component that is name node region
servers and zookeeper how it works how
each edge master interacts with
zookeeper what zookeeper does in
coordination how are the components
working together and how does hbs take
care of read and write coming back and
continuing why do we need to disable a
table so there are different table
operations what you can do in hbase and
one of them is disabling a table now if
you would want to check the status of
table you could check that by is
disabled and giving the table name order
is enabled and the table name so the
question is why do we need to disable a
table now if we would want to modify a
table or we are doing some kind of
maintenance activity in that case we can
disable the table so that we can modify
or changes settings when a table is
disabled it cannot be accessed through
the scan command now if we have to write
a code to open a connection in hbase now
to interact with hbase one could either
use a graphical user interface such as
hue or you could be using the command
line hb shell or you could be using
hbase admin api if you are working with
java or say happy base if you are
working with python where you may want
to open a connection with hbase so that
you can work with that base
programmatically in that case we have to
create a configuration object that is
configuration my conf and then create a
configuration object and then you can
use different classes like edge table
interface to work on a new table you
could use edge column qualifier and many
other classes which are available in
hbase admin api what does replication
mean in terms of hbase so edge base as i
said works in a cluster way and when you
talk about cluster you could always set
up a replication from one hbase cluster
to another hbase cluster so this
replication feature in hbase provides a
mechanism to copy data between clusters
or sync the data between different
clusters this feature can be used as a
disaster recovery solution that provides
high availability for hbase so if i have
a hbase cluster one where i have one
master and multiple region servers
running in a hadoop cluster i could use
the same hadoop cluster to create a
hbase replica cluster or i could have a
totally different hbase replica cluster
where my intention is that if things are
changing in a particular table in
cluster one i would want them to be
replicated across different clusters so
i could alter the hbase table and set
the replication scope to one now a
replication scope of zero indicates that
table is not replicated but if we set
the replication to one we basically will
have to set up ah base cluster where we
can replicate hbase tables data from
cluster one to cluster so these are the
commands which can be used to enable
replication and then replicate the data
of table across clusters can we import
and export in hbase of course we can it
is possible to import and export tables
from one hbase cluster to other hbase
cluster or even within a cluster so we
can use the hbase export utility which
comes in this particular package give a
table name and then a target location so
that will export the data of hbase table
into a directory on sdfs then i could
create a different table which would
follow some kind of same definition as
the table which was exported and then i
could use import to import the data from
the directory on sdfs to my table if you
would want to learn more on hbase import
and export you could look at hbase
import operations let's search for the
link and this is the link where you
could learn more about hbase import
export utilities how you could do a bulk
import bulk export which internally uses
mapreduce and then you could do a import
and export into hbase tables moving
further what do we mean by compaction in
hbase now we all know that hbase is a
nosql database which can be used to
store huge amount of data however
whenever a data is written in hbase it
is first returned to what we call as
right ahead log and also to mem store
which is
write cache now once the data is written
in wall and your mem store it is
offloaded to form an internal hbase
format file which is called h5 and
usually these edge files are very small
in nature so we also know that sdfs is
good when we talk about few number of
larger files in comparison to
large number of smaller files due to the
limitation of name nodes memory
compaction is process of merging hbase
files that is these smaller edge files
into a single large file this is done to
reduce the amount of memory required to
store the files and number of disk seeks
needed so we could have lot of edge
files which get created when the data is
written to hbase and these smaller files
can then be compacted through a major or
minor compaction creating one big edge
file which internally would then be
written to sdfs and sdfs format of
blocks that is the benefit of compaction
there is also a feature called bloom
filter so how does bloom filter work so
bloom filter or hbase bloom filter is a
mechanism to test whether a h file
contains a specific row or a row column
cell bloom filter is named after its
creator burton harvard bloom it is a
data structure which predicts whether a
given element is a member of a set of
data it provides an in-memory index
structure that reduces the disk reads
and determines the probability of
finding a row in a particular file this
is one of very useful features of edge
base which allows for faster access and
avoids disk seeks does hbase have any
concept of namespace so namespace is
when you have similar elements grouped
together so namespace yes h based
support such namespace so namespace is a
logical grouping of tables analogous to
a database in rdbms so you can create
hbase namespace to the schema of rdbms
database so you could create a namespace
by saying create namespace and giving it
a name and then you could also list the
tables within a namespace you could
create tables within a specific
namespace now this is usually done in
production environment where a cluster
might be multi-tenant cluster and there
might be different users of the same
nosql database in that case admin would
create specific namespace and for
specific namespace you would have
different directories on sdfs and users
of a particular business unit or a team
can work on their hbase objects within a
specific name space this is a question
which is again very important to
understand about the rights or reads so
how does right ahead log wall help when
a region server crashes now as i said
when a write happens it will happen into
mem store and wall that is your edit log
or write ahead log so whenever a write
happens it will happen in two places mem
store which is the right cache and wall
which is a edit log only when the data
is written in both these places and
based on the limitation of mem store the
data will be flushed to create an
edge-based format file called h-file
these files are then compacted and
created into one bigger file which will
then be stored on sdfs and sdfs data as
we know is stored in the form of blocks
on the underlying data nodes so if a
region server hosting a mem store
crashes now where is region server
running that would be co-located with
data node so if a data node crashes or
if a region server which was hosting the
mem store write cache crashes data in
memory the data that in memory which was
not persisted is lost now how does hbase
recover from this as i said your data is
written into wall and mem store at the
same time hbase recovers against that by
writing to wall before the write
completes so whenever a write happens it
happens in mem store and wall at the
same time hbase cluster keeps a wall to
record changes as they happen and that's
why we call it as also an edit log if
edge base goes down or the node that
goes down the data that was not flushed
from mem store to edge file can be
recovered by replaying the right ahead
lock and that's the benefit of your edit
log or write ahead log now if we would
have to write hbase command to list the
contents and update the column families
of a table i could just do a scan and
that would give me complete data of a
table if you are very specific and if
you would want to look at a particular
row then you could do a get table name
and then give the row key however you
could do a scan to get the complete data
of a particular table you could also do
a describe to see what are the different
column families and if you would want to
alter the table and add a new column
family it is very simple you can just
say alter give the hbase table name and
then give you a new column family name
which will then be added to the table
what are catalog tables in hbase so as i
mentioned your zookeeper knows the
location of this internal catalog table
or what we call as the meta table now
catalog tables in edge base have two
tables one is edge base meta table and
one is
hyphen root the catalog table edge base
meta exists as an edge base table and is
filtered out of hbase shells list
command so if i give a list command on
edge base it would list all the tables
which base contains but not the meta
table it's an internal table this meta
table keeps a list of all regions in the
system and location of hbase meta stored
in zookeeper so if somebody wants to
find out or look for particular rows
they need to know the regions which
contain that data and those regions are
located on region server to get all this
information one has to look into this
meta table however we will not be
looking into meta table directly we
would just be giving a write or a read
operation internally uh based master
queries the zookeeper zookeeper has the
information of where the meta table
exists and that meta table which is
existing on region server contains
information of row keys and the region
servers where those rows can be found
your root table keeps a track of
location of the meta table what is hot
spotting in edge base and how to avoid
hot spotting now this is a common
problem and always admin guys or guys
who are managing the infrastructure
would think about it so one of the main
idea is that edge base would be
leveraging the benefit of sdfs you are
all read and write requests should be
uniformly distributed across all of the
regions in region servers otherwise
what's the benefit of having a
distributed cluster so you would have
your data stored across region servers
in the form of regions which are
horizontal partitions of the table and
whenever read and write requests happen
they should be uniformly distributed
across all the regions in the region
servers now hot spotting occurs when a
given region serviced by a region server
receives most or all of read write
request which is basically a unbalanced
way of read write operations now hotspot
can be avoided by designing the row key
in such a way that data being written
should go to multiple regions across the
cluster so you could do techniques such
as salting hashing reversing the key and
many other techniques which are employed
by users of hbase we need to just make
sure that when the regions are
distributed across region servers they
should be spread across region servers
so that your read and write request can
be satisfied
from different region servers in
parallel rather than all read and write
request hitting the same region server
overloading the region server which may
also lead to the crashing of a
particular region server so these were
some of the important questions of hbase
and then there are many more please
refer to the link which i specified in
during my discussion and that gives you
a detailed explanation of how each base
works you can also look into hp's
definitive guide by o'reilly or hbase in
action and these are really good books
to understand about hbase internals and
how it works now that we have learnt on
hive which is a data warehousing package
we have learnt on pig which is a
scripting or a scripting language which
allows you to do data analysis and we
have learned some questions on a nosql
database just note it that there are
more than 225 nosql databases existing
in market and if you would want to learn
and know about more nosql databases you
can just go to google and type no sql
databases
org and that will take you to the link
which is for nosql databases and this
shows there are more than 225
nosql databases existing in market and
these are for different use cases used
by different users and for with
different features so have a look at
this link now when you talk about data
ingestion so let's look at data
ingestion and this is one good link
which i would suggest to have a look at
which lists down around 18 different
ingestion tools so when you talk about
different data injection tools some are
for structured data some are for
streaming data some are for data
governance some are for data ingestion
and transformation and so on so have a
look at this link which also gives you a
comparison of different data ingestion
tools so here let's learn about some
questions on scope which is one of the
data injection tools mainly used for
structured data or you could say data
which is coming in from rdbms or data
which is already structured and you
would want to ingest that you would want
to store that on hdfs which could then
be used for hive which could be used for
any kind of processing using mapreduce
or hive or pig or spark or any other
processing frameworks or you would want
to load that data into say high voltage
based tables scope is mainly for
structured data it is extensively used
when organizations are migrating from
rdbms to a big data platform and they
would be interested in ingesting the
data that is doing import and export of
data from rdbms to sdfs or vice versa so
let's learn about some important
questions on scope which you may be
asked by an interviewer when you apply
for a big data related position how is
scoop different from flow so this is a
very common question which is asked
scope which is mainly for structured
data so scope works with rdbms
it also works with nosql databases to
import and export data so you can import
data into sdfs you can import data into
data warehousing packets such as hive
directly or also in hbase and you could
also export data from hadoop ecosystem
to your rdbms however when it comes to
flow flow is more of
a data injection tool which works with
streaming data or unstructured data so
data which is constantly getting
generated for example log files or
metrics from server or some chat
messenger and so on so if you are
interested in working on capturing and
storing the streaming data in a storage
layer such as sdfs or hbase you could be
using flue there could be other tools
also like kafka or storm or chokwa or
samsa knifi and so on scope however is
mainly for structured data your loading
data in scope is not event driven so it
is not based on event it basically works
on data which is already stored in rdbms
in terms of flume it is completely event
driven that is as the messages or as the
events happen as the data is getting
generated you can have that data
ingested using flow scope works with
structured data sources and you have
various scope connectors which are used
to fetch data from external data
structures or rdbms so for every rdbms
such as mysql oracle db2 microsoft sql
server
you have different connectors which are
available flume it works on fetching
streaming data such as tweets or log
files or server metrics from your
different sources where the data is
getting generated and if you are
interested in not only ingesting that
data which is getting generated in a
streaming fashion but if you would be
interested in processing the data as it
arrives scoop can import data from rdbms
onto sdfs and also export it back to
rdbms flume is then used for streaming
data now you could have one to one one
too many or many to one kind of relation
so in terms of floom you have components
such as your source sync and channel
that's the main difference between your
scope and flow what are the different
file formats to import data using scope
well there are lots and lots of formats
in which you can import data into scope
when you talk about scope you can have
delimited text file format now that's
the default import format it can be
specified explicitly using as text file
argument so when i want to import data
from an rdbms i could get that data in
sdfs using different compression schemes
or in different formats using the
specific arguments so i could specify an
argument which will write string based
representation of each record to output
files with delimiters between individual
columns and rows so that is the default
format which is used to import data
using scope so to learn more about your
scope and different arguments which are
available you can click on
scoop.apache.org
you can look into the documentation and
i would suggest choosing one of the
versions and looking into the user guide
and here you can search for arguments
and look for specific control arguments
which show how you can import data using
scope so here we have common arguments
and then you also have import control
arguments wherein we have different
options like getting data as avro as
sequence file as text file or parquet
file these are different formats you can
also get data in default compression
scheme that is gzip or you can specify
compression codec and then you can
specify what compression mechanism you
would want to use when you are importing
your data using scope when it comes to
default format for flume we could say
sequence file which is a binary format
that stores individual records in record
specific data types so these data types
are manifested as java classes and scoop
will automatically generate these data
types for you so scoop does that when we
talk about your sequence file format in
terms of your scoop you could be
extracting storage of all data in binary
representation so as i mentioned you can
import data in different formats such as
avro parquet sequence file that is
binary format or machine readable format
and then you could also have data in
different compression schemes let me
just show you some quick examples here
so if i look in
the content and here i could search for
a scoop based file where i have listed
down some examples so if i would want to
use different compression schemes here
are some examples have a look at these
so i'm doing a scoop import i'm also
giving an argument so that scoop which
also triggers a map reduced job or i
would say map only job so when you run a
scoop import it triggers a map only job
no reduce happens here and you could
specify this parameter or this argument
on the command line
mapreduce.framework.name
so that you could run your map only job
in a local mode to save time or that
would interact with yarn and run a
full-fledged map only job we can give
the connection and then connect to
whatever rdbms we are connecting
mentioning the database name give your
username and password give the table
name give a target directory or it would
create a directory same as the table
name which would work only once and then
i could say minus z to get data in a
compressed format that is gzip or i
could be specifying compression codec
and then i could specify what
compression codec i would want to use
say snappy b lz4 default i could also
run a query by giving a scope import and
when i'm specifying a query if you
notice i have not given any table name
because that would be included in the
query i can get my data as a sequence
file format which is a binary format
which will create a huge file so we
could also have compression enabled and
then i could say the output of my map
job should use a compression at record
level for my data coming in sequence
file so sequence file or a binary format
supports compression at record level or
at block level i could get my data in an
avro file where data has embedded schema
within the file or a parquet file also
so these are different ways in which you
can set up different compression schemes
or you can even get data in different
formats and you could be doing a simple
scope import for these looking further
what is the importance of eval tool in
scope so there is something called as
eval tool so scoop eval tool allows
users to execute user defined queries
against respective database servers and
preview the result in the console so
either i could be running a straight
away query to import the data into my
sdfs or i could just use scoop eval
connect to my external rdbms specify my
username and password and then i could
be giving in a query to see what would
be the result of the query which we
intend to import now let's learn about
how scope imports and exports data
between rdbms and sdfs with its
architecture so rdbms as we know has
your database structures your tables
which all of them are logical and
internally there is always metadata
which is stored your scope import
connects to an external rdbms and for
this connection it uses an internal
connector jar file which has a driver
class so that's something which needs to
be set up by admin but they need to make
sure that whichever rdbms you intend to
connect to they need to have the jdbc
connector for that particular rdbms
stored within the scope lib folder so
scope import gets the metadata and then
for your scoop command it converts that
into a map only job which might have one
or multiple map tasks
now that depends on your scope command
you could be specifying that you would
want to do a import only in one task or
in multiple tasks these multiple map
tasks will then run on a section of data
from rdbms and then store it in sdfs
so at high level we could say scoop will
introspect database to get gathered the
metadata it divides the input data set
into splits and this division of data
into splits mainly happens on primary
key column of the table now if somebody
might ask what if my table in rdbms does
not have a primary key column then when
you are doing a scope import either you
will have to import it using one mapper
task by specifying hyphen hyphen m
equals one or you would have to say
split by parameter to specify a numeric
column from rdbms and that's how you can
import the data let me just show you a
quick example on this so i could just
look in again into the scoop command
file and here we could be looking at an
example so if you see this one here we
are specifying minus minus m equals 1
which basically means i would want to
import the data using one map task now
in this case whether the table has a
primary key column or does not have a
primary key column will not matter but
if i say a minus minus ms6 where i'm
specifying multiple map tasks to be
imported then this will look for a
primary key column in the table which
you are importing now if the table does
not have a primary key column then i
could be specifying a split by and then
specify the column so that the data
could be split into multiple chunks and
multiple map tasks could take it
now if the second scenario is your table
does not have a primary key column and
it does not have a numeric column on
which you could do a split by in that
case and if you would want to use
multiple mappers you could still say
split by on a textual column but you
will have to add this property so that
it allows splitting the data which is
non-numeric
all of these options are given in the
scoop apache.org link going further how
scoop imports and exports data between
rdbms and sdfs with its architecture so
as i said it submits the map only job to
the cluster and then it basically does a
import or export so if we are exporting
the data from sdfs in that case again
there would be a map only job it would
look at multiple splits of the data
which is existing which your map only
job would process through one or one
table map task and then export it to
rdbms suppose you have a database testdb
in mysql we if somebody asked you to
write a command to connect this database
and import tables to scoop so here is a
quick example as i showed you in the
command file so you could say scoop
import this is what we would want to do
you connect using jdbc now this will
only work if the jdbc connector already
exists within your scope lib directory
admin has to set up that so you can
connect to your rdbms
you can point to the database so
here our database name is test
underscore db i could give user name and
then either i could give password on the
command line or just say capital p so
that i could be prompted for the
password and then i could give the table
name which i would want to import i
could also be specifying minus minus m
and specify how many map tasks do i want
to use for this import as i showed in
previous screen how to export a table
back to rdbms now for this we need the
data in a directory on hdfs so for
example there is a departments table in
retail database which is already
imported into scoop and you need to
export this table back to rdbms so this
is the content of the table now create a
new department table in rdbms so i could
create a table specifying the column
names whether that supports null or no
if that has a primary key column which
is always recommended and then i can do
a scope export i can connect to the
rdbms specifying my username and
password specify the table into which
you want to export the data and then you
give export directory pointing to a
directory on sdfs which contains the
data this is how you can export data
into table seeing example on this so i
could again look into my file and here i
have an example of
import this is where you are importing
data directly into hive and you have
scoop import where you are importing
data directly into hbase table and you
can then query your hbs table to look at
the data you could also do a export by
running your map only job in a local
mode connecting to the rdbms specifying
your username specifying the table where
you would want to export and the
directory on sdfs where you have kept
the relevant data this is a simple
example of export looking further
what is the role of jdbc driver in scoop
setup so as i said if you would want to
use scoop to connect to an external
rdbms we need the jdbc odbc connector
jar file now one or admin could download
the jdbc connector jar file and then
place the jar file within the scoop lib
directory wherever scoop is installed
and this jdbc connector jar file
contains a driver now jdbc driver is a
standard java api which is used for
accessing different databases in rdbms
so this connector jar file is very much
required and this connector jar file has
a driver class and this driver class
enables the connection between your
rdbms and your hadoop structure each
database vendor is responsible for
writing their own implementation that
will allow communication with the
corresponding database and we need to
download the drivers which allow our
scope to connect to external rdbms so
your jdbc driver alone is not enough to
connect to scope we also need connectors
to interact with different database so a
connector is a plugable piece that is
used to fetch metadata and allow scoop
to overcome the differences in sql
dialects so this is how connection can
be established so normally your admins
would when they are setting up scope and
hadoop they would download
say mysql jdbc connector and this is how
they would go to the mysql connectors if
you are connecting to mysql similarly
for your other rdbms you could be say
going in here you could be looking for a
previous version depending you could be
going for platform independent and then
you could be downloading the connected
jar file now if you enter this jar file
you would see a mysql connector jar and
if we look in
com.mysql.jdbcom.mysql.jdbc.driver
so this is the package which is within
the connector jar file and this
has the driver class which allows the
connection of your scope with your rdbms
so these things will have to be done by
your admin so that you can have your
scoop connecting to an external rdbms
now how do you update the columns that
are already exported so if i do a export
and i put my data in rdbms can i really
update the columns that are already
exported yes i can using a update key
parameter so scoop export command
remains the same the only thing i will
have to specify now is the table name
your fields terminated by if you have a
specific delimiter and then you can say
update key and then the column name so
this allows us to update the columns
that are already exported in rdbms
what is code gen so
scope commands translate into your
mapreduce job or map only job so code
gen is basically a tool in scope that
generates data access objects dao java
classes that encapsulate and interpret
imported records so if i do a scoop code
gen connect to an rdbms using my
username and give a table this will
generate a java code for employee table
in the test database so this code gen
can be useful for us to understand what
data we have in this particular table
finally can scope be used to convert
data in different formats i think i
already answered that right if no which
tools can be used for this purpose so
scope can be used to convert data in
different formats and that depends on
the different arguments which you use
when you do a import such as avro file
parquet file binary format with record
or block level compression so if you are
interested in knowing more on different
data formats then i think i can suggest
a link for that and we can say hadoop
formats
i think it is tech
maggie avro
parque let's see you can find out the
link take maggie
yeah this is a very good link which
specifies or talks about different data
formats which you should know such as
your text file format different
compression schemes how is data
organization what are the common formats
what do you have in text file structured
binary sequence files with compression
without compression what is record level
what is block level what is a avro data
file what is a sequence what is a
parquet data file or a columnar format
and other formats like orc rc and so on
so please have a look at this link i
hope this will be helpful in your
interviews with that we've reached the
end of this complete hadoop tutorial for
beginners i hope you enjoyed this video
do like and share it thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
[Music]